THINGS. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
TODAY WE WILL LOOK CLOSELY AGAIN
AT THE CRITICAL SUBJECTS AROUND
FAMILY STABILIZATION AND CHILD
POVERTY IN OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM
. WE WILL BE ADDRESSING MAJOR
AUTOMATION PROJECTS AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND FINALLY
WE WILL BE REVIEWING THE BUDGET
AND PROGRAM UPDATES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT. TODAY WE WILL
HAVE MOST PANELISTS APPEARING
AND TESTIFYING IN PERSON AND A
FEW STAKEHOLDERS WILL APPEAR
VIRTUALLY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT SHOULD BE. ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. 1-877-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC CMMENT AFTER ALL
MEMBERS HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR
QUESTION AND ANSWER SESSION FOR
THE PANEL. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S HEARING
HAS THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO DISCUSS THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS HENCE TO REVIEW
ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION IN THESE
AREAS. I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN FEEDBACK
THROUGH THE BUDGET THROUGH THE
SUB ONE EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THE
ADDRESS IS BUDGET SUB ONE AT S.
M. DOT CA DOT GOV. BEFORE WE
INVITE OUR FIRST PANEL TO BEGIN
I'LL MAKE JUST A FEW
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS. TODAY IS
OUR LAST HEARING OF THIS TYPE
FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE AS WE WILL
MOVE INTO REVIEW OF SPRING
FINANCIAL. IN OUR UPCOMING
HEARINGS IN LATE APRIL AND EARLY
MAY AND THEN WE WILL BE
EXAMINING MAY REVISION. WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING CLOSELY AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND SETTING
UP FURTHER CONSIDERATION OF
PROPOSALS TO MODIFY OR ADD TO
THE GOVERNOR'S FRAMEWORK TO
REFLECT MUTUAL AND LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. I'M GLAD TO SAY THAT
TODAY WERE RETURNING TO CAL
WORKS PROGRAM TO DISCUSS HOW TO
MAKE IT A STRONGER POVERTY
FIGHTING FORCE FOR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN STRUGGLING TO MEET THE
MOST BASIC NEEDS IN OUR STATE.
WE HAVE RECEIVED A POLICY
ALIGNMENT REPORT FROM THE STATE
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
PERSONALLY THANK DIRECTOR KIM
JOHNSON AND HER STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR PROVIDING THIS. AND WE ARE
CLOSELY REVIEWING ITS HIGH
HIGHEST SCORING RECOMMENDATIONS
. OUR GOAL IS TO REALIZE THE
PROMISE OF THE CAL WORKS TWO
POINT OH AND CAL OR EFFORT TO
TRANSITION CAL WORKS INTO A MORE
PERSON CENTERED. TRAUMA INFORMED
AND STRENGTHS BASED PROGRAM. WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
ADVANCE A MAJOR GOAL IN THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT AND
MATERNAL HEALTH AND I HOPE THAT
WE CAN SEIZE THE- SEIZE IT BY
PAVING THE WAY TOWARDS MODEST
TRAILER. BILL CHANGES IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BUDGET SUCH AS
THE REMOVAL OF THE COUNTY SHARE
OF WORK PARTICIPATION RATE OR W.
P. R. PENALTY. THE COUNTY SHARE
OF THE PENALTY HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY INHIBITING ELEMENT
IMPEDING THE WORK INTO WHICH WE
HAVE ALREADY INVESTED SO MUCH
TIME EFFORT AND GOOD WILL. I AM
VERY HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BUILD A BETTER
PROGRAM HERE TOGETHER MUCH LIKE
WE HAVE DONE WITHIN THE MEDICAL
SPACE WITH CAL HM AND WITH THE
FIFTY BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BOLD
GOALS. WE'LL ALSO HEAR ABOUT AND
TALKED TDAY ABOUT MAJOR%
AUTOMATION PROJECTS IN HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WELFARE SERVICES
SINGLE SYSTEM DEVELOPMENT CAL
SAUCE AND OUR CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS ONE OF WHICH IS A
LEGACY SYSTEM AND ANOTHER IS A
DEVELOPING REPLACEMENT SYSTEM.
WE WANT TO HEAR ABOUT BASIC
FEATURES OF COST TIMELINE AND
VALUE. ARE WE GETTING WHAT WE
ARE PAYING FOR IN THESE PROGRAMS
WHEN IT COMES TO CUSTOMER
SERVICE ACCESS RETENTION OF
BENEFITS AND QUALITY OUTCOMES.
THE FINAL PANEL TODAY IS ON THE
BUDGETS AND PROGRAMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT
HOW THE ENERGY AND WATER OF
RELIGIOUS PROGRAMS HAVE OR ARE
IMPLEMENTING. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE AGENDAS TODAY. WITH THAT
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
PANEL. WHICH IS ON THE TOPIC. OF
THE RELEASE OF THE CAL WORKS
POLICY ALIGNMENT REPORT AND THE
NEXUS WITH CHILD WELFARE
DISPARITY REDUCTION GOALS. FOR
THE PANELISTS WHO ARE PRESENTERS
PRISON IN THE THAT YOUR NAME
APPEARS IN THE AGENDA WE HAVE
ASKED BEAKERS TO PLEASE ADDRESS
THE QUESTIONS WHICH ARE LISTED
IN THE AGENDA IN THEIR TESTIMONY
. WE HAVE NINE DISTINGUISHED
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING DIRECTOR KIM JOHNSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. CRISTINA
MANSAB WITH CAL WORKS AND FAMILY
RESILIENCE BRANCH CHIEF FOR D.
S. S. COUNTY SANDERLING MCDONALD
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CW
DA. JENNIFER GREP BEAT THE LEAD
CHAPTER ORGANIZER FOR PARENT
VOICES CALIFORNIA. S. C. HUTCH
FULL POLICY ANALYST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER MIKE HERALDS LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY RYAN ANDERSON
WITH THE L. A. O. JANINE DR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
TYLER WOODS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. LET US PLEASE BEGIN
WITH DIRECTOR JOHNSON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- KIM JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND APPRECIATE THE
OPENING REMARKS AND SHARED
ACROSS IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN OUR CALYX PROGRAM. SO
I WILL JUMP RIGHT INTO THE
QUESTIONS- IN THE AGENDA AND
APPRECIATE THE BACKGROUND THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED AND SO YOU'RE
GOING TO HERE SHORTLY A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE COW
WORKS POLICY ALIGNMENT REPORT. I
WITH BY CHRISTINA MAYES THAT WHO
WILL FOLLOW ME BUT I WILL JUST
GENERALLY SAY THAT THE TWENTY
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS FALL
GENERALLY WITHIN A FOR AREAS NOT
IS ACCESS TO THE CAR WORKS
INCLUDING. OUT REACH AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE WHO
NEEDED ME TO NOTE NEWLY ENROLLED
IN THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS ACCESS
TO THE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND
BENEFITS ONCE AN INDIVIDUAL AND
FAMILY IS ENROLLED INTO THE
PROGRAM. AT THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE PARTICIPANT WHETHER IT'S A
SINGLE CASE WORKER HAVING THAT
NAVIGATOR OR THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR POLICY
SETTING AND PROGRAM DESIGN
PROCESS SEES. AT COUNTY STAFF
THE RELATIONSHIP IN THE
INTERACTIONS- IN THE SUPPORT AND
TRAINING THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL INCLUDING HOW OVER
TIME THE WORK PARTICIPATION RATE
HAS INFLUENCED THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE ARE ENGAGING WITH THE COW
WORKS PARTICIPANT. AND FINALLY
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
WHETHER THAT BE VIA PEER
LEARNING. PARTICIPATE INPUT
SESSIONS OR MORE IN SO THAT'S
THOSE ARE VERY BROADLY AGAIN
YOU'LL HEAR MORE DETAIL JUSTICE
JUST A MOMENT AND I WOULD SAY
THAT EACH OF THESE AREAS AND
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS FIT WITHIN
THE CAL OR- OR THE COW WORKS
OUTCOMES ACCOUNTABILITY IN
REVIEW CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORK. THE
FRAMEWORK WAS DESIGNED OVER TWO
YEARS AGO BY CURRENT AND FORMER
CAL WORKS PARTICIPANTS IN
CLIENTS ADVOCATES COUNTY STAFF
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AS WELL AS A
VARIETY OF OTHER SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS AND I'D NOTE. THAT ON
YOUR AGENDA IN IN THIS PANEL
YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE OF MEMBERS
OF THAT WORK GROUP AT
PARTICIPATING. THIS FRAMEWORK
IDENTIFIES SHORT TERM MEDIUM
TERM AND LONG TERM OUTCOMES THAT
ALL BEST REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAM DESIGNED. AND SO SOME OF
THE- THAT COME. IN THOSE
OUTCOMES THAT WE ARE STRIVING TO
ACHIEVE INCLUDE ENSURING THAT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES BASIC
NEEDS ARE MET. INCREASE
PARTICIPATION PARTICIPANT
SATISFACTION WITH THE PROGRAM
IMPROVED WELL BEING IMPROVED
GOAL ACHIEVEMENT. INCREASED
EMPLOYMENT AND WAGES. REDUCE
NEED FOR INCOME SUPPORTS IN
REDUCED INTER GENERATIONAL
POVERTY. THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ALSO REFLECTIVE OF THE WAYS TO
FURTHER THE COW WORKS TO PLANO.
A. C. W. D. A. LED EFFORT TO
HELP COUNTY STAFF BETTER ENGAGE
FAMILIES IN THE PROGRAM IN A
STRENGTH BASED AS YOU MENTIONED.
COLLABORATIVE IN TRAUMA INFORMED
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE WAY. AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDE A
NUMBER OF STRATEGIES FOR
CONSIDERATION AS WE LAUNCH INTO
THIS FIRST ROUND F. CAL OR- THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKS FORWARD TO
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS TO
BETTER INFORM THE FEASIBILITY OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS RESPECTIVE
TO THEIR IMPLEMENTATION AND
FURTHER. LEARN THROUGH THE
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS OF CALOR. AS IT RELATES
TO YOUR SECOND QUESTION AROUND
KEY CHALLENGES FOR THE CALYXT
CASELOAD AND IT EMPHASIS ON THE
CHILDREN LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY
IN THE PROGRAM I WANT TO FIRST
AND FOREMOST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORK THAT CALIFORNIA HAS DONE.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR POLICIES IN
THE TOWN OF PROGRAM STRENGTHENS
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN INCLUDING
PROVIDING AID TO CHILDREN TO AGE
EIGHTEEN. AND CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE AID. PARENTS PORTION OF
IT IS ENDED AS A RESULT THE
SHARE OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
IN POVERTY WHO RECEIVED JANET
BENEFITS HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
MUCH HIGHER. THAN THE SHARE IN
OTHER STATES IN THE NATION. WITH
THAT SAID THERE'S STILL MORE
WORK TO DO TO DISRUPT AND
ULTIMATELY END CHILD POVERTY IN
OUR STATE. SOME OF OUR RECENT
INVESTMENTS AND STRENGTHEN
EFFORTS ADDRESS TO A DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS THESE KEY CHALLENGES FOR
CALYX PARTICIPANTS NOT JUST NAME
A FEW ONE HOME VISITING. A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AIMING TO
SUPPORT POSITIVE HEALTH
DEVELOPMENT AND WELL BEING
OUTCOMES FOR PREGNANT PARENTING
PEOPLE FAMILIES IN INFANTS BORN
INTO POVERTY EXPANDING THE
FUTURE EDUCATIONAL ECONOMIC AND
FINANCIAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
IMPROVING THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WILL ACCEPT READY. WE
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL
PARTNERS ON THIS EFFORT AND IT
REALLY IS ABOUT THE STRENGTH
BASED APPROACH CONNECTING
FAMILIES TO RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THEM ALONG THE WAY. I ALSO WOULD
NOTE THE COW WORKS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH IS
INTENDED TO FOSTER HOUSING
STABILITY FOR FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
CALYX PROGRAM. WHICH WE TO
SPOKEN TO THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY BUT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED IN THE
BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATING TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS PROGRAM. I'D
ALSO NOTE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
SUBSIDIES ANOTHER PLACE WHERE WE
HAVE INVESTED TOGETHER FOR
EXPANDED ACCESS WHETHER IT BE IN
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM OR FOR THE
ACCOMPANYING PROGRAMS THAT
THOSE. FAMILIES MAY BE ELIGIBLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN FAMILY
STABILIZATION A PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES THAT MAY BE
IN IT IN ADDITION TO THOSE
PROVIDED BY THE COUNTY'S WELFARE
TO WORK PROGRAM. TO CLIENTS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING IDENTIFIED
SITUATION OR CRISIS AND FINALLY
I'D SAY THE OTHER AT STRATEGY
THAT WE CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN
IS HOW WE ARE SUPPORTING ACCESS
TO THE FULL SAFETY NET ARRAY.
AND SO WE HAVE RECENTLY LAUNCHED
AGAIN WE SPOKEN AT PREVIOUSLY TO
THE STATEWIDE OUTREACH ADVISORY
ROUND TABLE THAT'S BEEN NEWLY
CREATED OR STORE. LAUNCHING IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR IN THE
GOAL OF THAT EFFORT IS TO INFORM
OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS TO
PERSPECTIVE CAO WORKS FAMILY
FAMILIES LEVERAGING DATA AND
EXISTING RESOURCES. WE ALSO HAVE
BEEN USING A NUMBER OF
STRATEGIES TO AGAIN MAKE THAT
CONNECTION SO WHETHER IT'S THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT WHETHER
IT WAS COVERED RELIEF THAT WAS
AVAILABLE. I WE ARE LOOKING TO
HAVE TAX FILING SUPPORT ALL OF
THE CONNECTION POINTS FOR CAL
WORKS FAMILIES TO GET CONNECTED
TO ECONOMIC SUPPORTS AN EDITOR.
AT SUPPORT THAT MAY SUPPORT
THEIR STABILITY. THE NEXT
QUESTION HE ASKED HOW THE COW
OR- A COLOR CREATES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IMPROVED
PROGRAM OUTCOMES. AND YOU WORK
AND WPR PENALTIES HELP OR
HINDER. AT THE WORK BEING
UNDERTAKEN CALOR SITE JUST VERY
QUICKLY THE CAL OR AT PER
INITIATIVE CONSISTS OF THREE
CORE COMPONENTS PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS A CAP PATCHWORK SELF
ASSESSMENT COUNTY SELF
ASSESSMENT. AND A SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN. AND I'LL JUST
NOTE THAT ARE POOR PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS THAT WERE DESIGNED
AGAIN TOGETHER IN THAT WORK
GROUP INCLUDE PARTICIPATING
GAUGE MINT SERVICE DELIVERY
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT. PROGRAM
EXITS AND RE ENTRIES
PARTICIPATION BARRIER REMOVAL
FAMILY AND CHILD WELL BEING. AND
TO THE QUESTION AT IN THIS AREA
EMPLOYMENT. WHEN MEASURES. ARE
LOOKING AT THE EMPLOYMENT RATE
OF CURRENT POWER EXPERTISE
DEPENDS THOSE WERE PARTICIPATING
IN SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT AS WELL
AS THE EMPLOYMENT RATES POST CAL
WORKS. SO AGAIN THAT INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE IN A WAY THAT
SUPPORTS OUR ABILITY TO FREEPORT
ON THE FEDERAL MEASURES AT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
AGAIN THE INITIATIVE IS DESIGNED
IN A WAY THAT IT'S A LOCAL DATA
DRIVEN PROGRAM MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
TO FACILITATE THAT CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND
DISSEMINATE BEST PRACTICE AND
ALLOW AS AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
LOOK AT. WHAT DOES THAT WORKING
BEST SO IT IS
TRUE THAT TODAY AT STATE TENNIS
PROGRAMS AGAIN THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT MUST MEET A FEDERAL
WORK PARTICIPATION RATE TO AVOID
FISCAL PENALTIES. THE WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE IS THE
CINGULAR BINARY METRIC USED TO
MEASURE STATE SUCCESS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. WE RECOGNIZE
TOGETHER THE FLAWS EMBEDDED IN
JUST HAVING THIS METRIC ALONG
WITH THE GOAL OF APPLYING MORE
MEANINGFUL METRICS OF SUCCESS TO
THAT CAL OR EFFORT THAT WE JUST
SPOKE TO. AND SO AGAIN WE WOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT WORK IN
EMPLOYMENT R. ONE COMPONENTS OF
MANY THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IN
TERMS OF THE SUCCESS OF CAL
WORKS. YOU ALSO ASK THE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN CAL WORKS
THE CHILD WELL FIRST COUNCIL
VISION AND GOALS AND- AT THE
STATE SCHOOLS AROUND BREAKING TO
GENERATIONAL POVERTY CHILD
DEVELOPMENT GREATER EQUITY. SO
HERE I WOULD JUST POINT OUT TO
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES STRATEGIC PRIORITY
WHICH IS FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN LIVING IN
EXTREME POVERTY AND FOSTER CARE
IN JUVENILE JUSTICE AND- BY
ADDRESSING. ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION NEEDS AND IMPROVING
ACCESS TO PHYSICAL HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES. I'LL
ALSO POINT TO ANOTHER GUIDING
PRINCIPLE I REFERENCED EARLIER
TO THIS COMMITTEE WHICH IS
AROUND EQUITY. AND JUST SIMPLY
PUT TO IN OUR GUIDING PRINCIPLES
IN ORDER TO CREATE THE STATE
WERE ALL OF US CAN HAVE A CHANCE
TO THRIVE BASED ON OUR EFFORTS
AND HARD WORK WE CANNOT. WE
CANNOT ALLOW. CERTAIN GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS TO BE DISADVANTAGED
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN THE GENDER IDENTITY OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AGE. OR
DISABILITY. AND SO AGAIN WE ARE
LOOKING AT DISRUPTING POVERTY BY
PROVIDING STRENGTH BASED
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT
TANGIBLY ADDRESS THE ANY
INEQUALITIES. THE COW WORKS CAL
OR COMPONENT THAT I JUST
REVIEWED THAT FRAMEWORK IS
REALLY THE WAYS IN WHICH WE ARE
DOING THAT IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM ALONG WITH MANY
INVESTMENTS THAT WE RECENTLY. AT
ENACTED TOGETHER INVESTED IN
TOGETHER TO STRENGTHEN THE
PROGRAM. OF COURSE AS IT RELATES
TO ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
THE WORK OF THIS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST SURGEON GENERAL AND- AT
OUR SECONDS AT COMING ON HERE TO
REDUCE ACES AND REALLY ENSURE
THAT THIS TRAINING AND SUPPORT.
FOR NOT ONLY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS BUT MORE BROADLY
ACROSS THE SERVICE SYSTEM.
AROUND WHAT TWO ACES ARE HOW TO
IDENTIFY THEM AND OF COURSE HOW
TO. CREATE THE TRUMP INFORM
NETWORKS OF CARE TO SUPPORT.
THOSE WHO ARE IMPACTED SO
TOGETHER. AGAIN WITH THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL SPEAKING JUST A
SECOND TO YOUR SECOND QUESTION
AROUND THE CHILD WELFARE AT
COUNCIL SCHOOLS. WE ARE TOGETHER
LOOKING HOLISTICALLY. AT HAD NO
MATTER WHAT PROGRAM WHAT FUNDING
STREAM WHAT SOURCE HOW WE ARE
SUPPORTING ADDRESSING THAT CHILD
POVERTY. OR GREATLY ACROSS THE
BOARD. YOU SPOKE AT IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS HERE AND HAVE A
QUESTION HERE AROUND HOW AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. SERVICES AGENCY-
INSURES THAT INITIATIVES LIKE
THE BOLD GOAL OF FIFTY BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AT CONNECT. IN SUPPORT
PROGRAMS LIKE HOW ITWORKS AND-
WHAT I WOULD JUST AGAIN SAY IS
THAT- THAT SECRETARIES OFTEN
TALKING ABOUT OUR WORK IN AB
TESTING SILENCE. THAT WE HAVE TO
AND AGAIN IT'S REFLECTED IN OUR
FRAMEWORK AT IN OUR STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES. I THINK ABOUT A
WHOLE PERSON INFORMED PROCESSES
THAT WE ARE LOOKING. AT TOGETHER
COLLECTIVELY IN RECOGNITION THAT
WE ARE SERVING THE SAME CHILD
AND FAMILY IN SO MANY CASES
ACROSS THESE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AND SO. HOW THESE
COMPONENTS AND HOW THESE GOALS
AND OUTCOMES FIT TOGETHER IS
CRITICAL. THE HOUSING NEEDS THE
CASH ASSISTANCE NEEDS THE MENTAL
AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH SUPPORTS AND
SO AGAIN- WE ARE VERY COMMITTED
AND CONTINUE TO NOT ONLY HAVE.
TABLE SET WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER
JOINTLY IN TERMS OF WORKING TO
ADDRESS THESE AREAS WITH ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS. BUT ALSO WE ARE
SITTING TABLES FOR JUST ASK THE
DEPARTMENTS TO REALLY DIG INTO
SOME OF THAT DETAILED WORK FOR
WE ARE IDENTIFYING. ANY BARRIERS
WE HAVE TO FULLY INTEGRATING.
OUR SERVICES- I ALSO GO AGAIN
THAT- IT BETTER INITIATIVE
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR IN THAT SAME
GOAL FRAMEWORK IN THAT SAME
OBJECTIVE IS THE CHILDREN TO BE
HEALTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AND WELL OVER FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS THAT AGAIN THAT
WE'VE INVESTED TOGETHER IN THE
SPACE BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE. AT IT
CRITICAL NEED AND AGAIN A PLACE
THAT WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER AND
IDENTIFYING THE LEVERAGE THAT WE
HAVE ACROSS PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
THAT. AND FINALLY AGAIN I
MENTIONED AT TROUBLE FOR COUNCIL
GO BACK TO THE FINAL QUESTION
HERE IN IS THE NEAR TERM GOALS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IN THE
CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN LIVING IN
DEEP POVERTY. AND SO I'VE
MENTIONED THAT A LITTLE BIT ON
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SIDE IN IN THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AND CAL WORKS.
OUT BUT I WOULD JUST NOTE AS IT
RELATES TO CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL
ARE CO CHAIRS HAVE RECENTLY-
IDENTIFIED THAT THE THEME OF OUR
NEXT WORK TOGETHER AND THAT'S
ABOUT KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER.
AND SO HOW ARE THESE SUPPORTS
ACROSS THE BOARD THAT WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER WE CANNOT DO MEANINGFUL
PREVENTION WORK WITHOUT
ADDRESSING EQUITY. GIVEN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF BLACK
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILIES IN
NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILIES TO
ENTER INTO AND STAY FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME INTO THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. WITH RESPECT TO
REUNIFICATION OF PERMANENCY.
THAT WE HAVE TO THE WORK WILL
LIKELY NEEDED YOU CONSIDER
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTS FOR
RELATIVES. AND FAIRLY DIVERSE
THAT OPPOSED TO MEET ME AT THE
KITCHEN SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
SINCE MOST FAMILIES AT- INVOLVED
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
WOULD BE CLASSIFIED AS POOR MANY
COMING FROM ENERGY GENERATIONAL
POVERTY. SO AGAIN WE ARE LOOKING
TO THAT WOULD REALLY IDENTIFY
SOME OF THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND OTHERS AT
IN TERMS OF GETTING AHEAD IN OUR
PREVENTIVE SPACE. TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES TOGETHER. AND I JUST
ALSO ADD THAT IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL SHORT TERM GOALS I
WANT TO AGAIN I CAN'T UNDERSCORE
ENOUGH. THE GOVERNOR IN THIS
BODY THE LEGISLATURE'S AT
LEADERSHIP IN IN THE
UNPRECEDENTED AND HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE HAD- IN
OUR PROGRAMS TO REALLY ADDRESS
THE SCHOOL AND REALLY LOOKING AT
DISRUPTING POVERTY AND- AT THAT
NUMBER IF FAMILY MEAN IF.
POLICIES THAT WE'VE AND- IN JUST
THIS CURRENT YEAR- I THAT
PARTICULAR POLICY AREAS WERE WE
REFORMED CAL WORKS EIGHT TO
PREGNANT PARENTS AND ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE SUPPORT EARLIER ON.
THE WORK WE'VE DONE FOR APPLE
CAN INCOME DISREGARD. SPEAKING
TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THIS
REPORT EVEN AND THAT IN
INVESTMENTS WE'VE MADE COUNTY
STAFF TRAINING. ON RACIAL EQUITY
IN IMPLICIT BIAS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN DO THE BEST JOB IN
THOSE INTERACTIONS WITH CLIENTS-
AND MANY MANY MORE- VERY SHORT
TERM IT'S THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL I CAN SPEAK TO AGAIN.
AT IN TERMS OF WHAT OUR GOALS
ARE NOT IS. CONTINUING OUR WORK
ON ASUS EXTENT EXTENDING
PROVIDER TRAINING. OUR WORK
SPACE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU. THAT
SUGGESTING WE INCREASE THE
MAXIMUM A PAYMENT BY SEVEN POINT
1% RIGHT ACTIVISTS PAID FOR
OCTOBER ONE- WE ALSO HAVE ITEMS
LIKE PROPOSING A REFUNDABLE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR
YOUNG ADULTS AGE EIGHTEEN.
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE WHO ARE
FORMALLY FOSTER YOUTH. ABBOTT
MANY MANY OTHERS IN TURN THE
CHILD CARE SUBSIDY ACCESS AND-
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PRIVILEGE TO IMPLEMENT OUT THAT
MANY OF THESE INITIATIVES AND WE
ARE DOING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THOSE WHO WE ARE. HERE AND
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE IN AGAIN
APPRECIATE. ARE THE QUESTIONS
HERE ON THE AGENDA THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
MISMATCHED AFTER SHE- GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AND
ATTENDEES THANK YOU SO MUCH
CRISTINA MESSING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO JOIN YOU ALL TODAY I HAD
TO PROVIDE SOME UPDATES IN
ADDITION TO THE UPDATES WE JUST
HEARD FROM DIRECTOR DIRECT
JOHNSON ON THE HOW ARE POLICY
ALIGNMENT WORKGROUP REPORT AS
WELL AS SOME BROADER CAL WORKS
UP AT PETE'S IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTIONS POSED IN THE AGENDA.
PURCHASE DIRECT JOHNSON. SPEAK
OR POLICY ALIGNMENT WORKGROUP
REPORT RELEASED JUST LAST
FRIDAY- OFFERS RECOMMENDATIONS
FOCUSED ON OPPORTUNITIES
INTENDED TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES. COUNTY WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ADDRESS
PROGRAM FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
SUCH AS THE WORK PARTICIPATION
RATE OUR COMMUNITY OUR- THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT- BOOKS WILL
FIND WITHIN THE REPORT MORE
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE PROGRAM
CHANGES. OF LIKE STREAMLINED
ACCESS TO SUPPORT SERVICES I
WOULD TRANSPORTATION BEING ONE
PRIMARY AREA OF FOCUS FOR
WORKGROUP MEMBERS. I WE ALSO SAW
A RECOMMENDATION TO PROVIDER
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS WITH
THE PROGRAM NAVIGATOR AT THIS
WITH YOU HYPOTHETICALLY A NEW
POSITION WITHIN THE COUNTY. WHO
COME INTO THIS NEW ROLE WITH
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS A FORMER
OUR X. RECIPIENT. WE SAW
RECOMMENDED TO EXPAND OUR
STATEWIDE TRAINING THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE Ë
INSTRUCTOR JOHNSON MENTIONED I
PROVIDING RACHEL EQUITY AN
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING TALK
COUNTY STOP. I TO ALSO INCLUDE
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE PRACTICES
AND RELATED TRAINING FOR TWO
PURPOSES. I WANT ENOUGH FOCUSED
ON ENSURING RECIPIENTS RECEIVE
EQUITABLE SERVICE EXPERIENCES
ACROSS THE STATE WITH SOME
DEGREE OF STANDARDIZATION. AND
SHOOT YOU OFFER TRAINING TO
SUPPORT COUNTY WORKFORCE AND
WORKERS EXPERIENCING IN A SECOND
HAND OF A TRAUMA AND OF COURSE
WORKFORCE. WORKER PRETTY. WE SEE
RECORD. TO RECONSIDERED WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE ARE TO BE.
OUR PENALTY PASSED ON POLICIES.
I WHICH CURRENTLY REQUIRE SHARED
RISK AMONG THE STATE EVER COUNTY
PARTNERS- WINNER IF THE PENALTY
IS PASSED ON TO THE STATE. THERE
WAS ALSO A RECOMMENDATION TO
EXPLORE POTENTIAL FEDERAL
REPRIEVE OF WORK PARTICIPATION
RATE PENALTIES I THINK YOU'RE A
WAIVER PROCESS IF THAT WAIVERS
AVAILABLE OR THROUGH OTHER
MEANS. I WITH OUR FEDERAL
OVERSIGHT AGENCY YEAH. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT FOR THIS
LAST RECOMMENDATION THE
DEPARTMENT DID SUBMIT A REQUEST
YOU EASY ACCESS. FORTY TWENTY
TWENTY FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
ASSESSED PENALTIES TO NOT
COLLECT ON ANY PENALTIES RELATED
TO THE WORK PARTICIPATION RATE.
GIVEN THE PANDEMIC AND RESPECTED
STADIUM OF EMERGENCY IN OUR
PRIORITY IS THE STATE- TO BETTER
SERVE THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES. FACING THE PENNY- AT
CONDITIONS RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC. THAT REQUEST WE ARE
HAPPY TO SHARE HAS BEEN GRANTED
BY ECS. AGAIN THIS IS FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR AND WE PLAN TO CONTINUE TO
SUBMIT THOSEREQUEST I TO EASIER
FOR BOTH YOU TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO FEDERAL
FISCAL YEARS. THIS IS A UNIQUE
AND TEMPORARY OPTION THE ECF IS
MADE AVAILABLE TO STATES DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND STILL
CALIFORNIA PLANS TO CONTINUE TO.
SUBMIT THOSE REQUEST SO LONG AS
THEY ARE AVAILABLE BY APART.
ALREADY YEAH. WELL THERE MAY
RECOMMENDED WITH THE REPORT
STILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS AND REVIEW OF THESE
ABILITY. OF MOSTLY TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON THE POTENTIAL
COST WORKFORCE INNOVATION
IMPACT- THE DEPARTMENT PLANS TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
CONTINUED PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS.
TO WORK HOW IT WORKS OUT COMING
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW PROCESS OR
HOW WORDS AGAIN DIRECTED JOHNSON
MENTIONED IN HER- BUT RESPONSES
TO THE QUESTIONS POSED BY. THE
COMMITTEE. HOW WERE COUNTY. I
BUT THE TO COME COME WILL BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION SURVEY- TO BETTER
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GROWTH- IN SERVING OUR FAMILIES
WILL SIMULTANEOUSLY IDENTIFYING
BEST PRACTICES LIFTING THOSE AS
WELL SUCCESSES OF OUR PROGRAMS.
ACROSS THE STATE. CALOR OFFERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INFORM
CONTINUOUS PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT
TO THIS HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN IN
EQUITY FOCUSED LENS. AND AS A
REMINDER OF HOW OR JUST RE
LAUNCHED IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AFTER ONE YEAR POTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND THROUGH
THIS PAUSE AND DO THIS RELAUNCH
WE REESTABLISH THE CYCLE UP FOR
THIS IF YOU SEE KAY WHY PROCESS
. CALL WORKS AT COUNTY PROGRAM
FOR THREE YEARS TO BUY YEARS I
WITH THE KERN CYCLE IN THE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. IN ADDITION
TO THE HAPPENING WITHIN HOW LORD
ARE OTHER RECOMMENDED WITHIN THE
REPORT THAT COHEN WITH SOME OF
OUR EXIT UPPER. AND WORK IN IN
RIGHT NOW WITH INCOME WORKS TO
SERVE OUR FAMILIES- AND OUR OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS SUCH AS THAT
STATE BY TRAINING. LAST YEAR WE
SAW ON INVESTMENT TO LAUNCH
STATEWIDE RACIAL EQUITY IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING. AT THE DEPARTMENT
IS ON TARGET TO RELEASED A
FORMAL PLAN TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR. THAT
DETAILS THE IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY FOR THAT TRAINING. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO PLANNING A
VERY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS THIS SUMMER
AT TO HELP INFORM THAT FINAL
PLAN WHERE WE CAN LEVERAGE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO INFORM A
BROADER STATEWIDE TREAT EFFORTS
HAPPENING IN OTHER AREAS ACROSS
THE DEPARTMENT. LASTLY WHAT TO
HIRE THAT- CALIFORNIA'S. IN
NATIONAL WORKGROUPS A PART OVER
AT EACH STAGE. I TO IN THE THING
BUT TENET MODERNIZE FOR. AND AS
A MORE FOR. WITH THE SPACE YOU
WILL SOME INHERENT A- I. A RELAY
. WHERE YOU'RE FROM DIRECT
JOHNSON IN THE WORK THAT WE'RE
WITH THAT COW. IT JUST TO I GO
SIX OR- THAT THIS WAY WE HAVE
PART OF THE KIND OF MODERNIZE
THE WORKER. A RECORD. THAT THE
TO MAINTAIN OUT DIRECTLY INCLUDE
AS A CLEAR NORTH STAR READING
EACH THE PRINCIPLES AND AS THE
FUNDING FOR BUILDING MODERN KIND
OF PROGRAM. TO SUPPORT AGAINST
THE CHILD AND FAMILY WELL BEING
. THE SIX CORE PRINCIPLES WE'VE
IDENTIFIED INCLUDE
PRIORITISATION OF HELPING
FAMILIES ACHIEVE ECONOMIC
MOBILITY TO THE SUPPORT. OF
PHYSICAL SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING FOR THE WHOLE FAMILY.
AGAIN THIS TIES IN VERY CLOSELY
TO THE OUTREACH WORK THAT YOU
HEARD DIRECTOR JOHNSON RATES UP
AROUND CONNECTING OUR FAMILIES.
TO CRITICAL TAX BENEFITS ATC
OUTRAGE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
LAUNCH A VERBAL CAL WORKS AND
HOW FRESH RECIPIENTS. AS WELL AS
RECENTLY LAUNCHED A GOLDEN BEAR
PASSED SEPARATE WITH- CAL WORKS
FAMILIES WHERE WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO I DO TARGETED OUTREACH OUR
COLORS FAMILIES TO GIVE THEM
ACCESS TO THE FREE GOLDEN BEAR
PASSED. RESULTING IN
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PASSES BEING DISPERSED
IN JUST THE FIRST THREE WEEKS OF
OUTREACH WHICH IS ALMOST DOUBLE.
THIS DISBURSING. HOW WORKS
FAMILIES LAST YEAR. THE SECOND
CORPORATE PRIORITIES THE OF
TAILORED SOLUTION THAT HELP
FAMILIES. WITH THEIR INDEPENDENT
SUCCESS FOR THE LONG TERM. AT
THE THIRTEENTH FOSTERING
CONDITIONS THAT ADVANCE A PERSON
SINCE THE AGENCY OVER THE LIFE
AND BELONGING WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITY. OF COURSE MEANS
ENTERING POLICIES AND EVIDENCE
AND PROMISING PRACTICES THAT
REFLECT THE LIVED EXPERIENCE OF
FAMILY. IT IS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE BROADER WORKFORCE
SYSTEMS WERE AT FORTY NEEDED
CONTINUE BUT SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR JOB SEEKERS
STRINGS THE GOALS AND THEN
FINALLY- A SIX OR PRINCIPLE
SUPPORTING ACCESS TO AN ADEQUATE
ASSISTANCE AND SERVICES THAT
ALLOW FAMILIES TO MEET BASIC
NEEDS WHILE WORKING TO ACHIEVE
THEIR LONG TERM GOALS. AGAIN
MANY OF THESE PRINCIPLES
ALIGNING WITH SOME OF THE WORK
THAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN CAO
WORKS IN THE INVESTMENTS MADE A
THROUGH THE PROPOSED BUDGET. IT
CAN MUCH ALSO IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING WE
THINK HOW WORKS TO PLANO AND OF
COURSE THE WORK THAT WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO. AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM KATHY CENTRELINE
MCDONALD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH CATHARINE
MCDONNELL WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
WERE REALLY PLEASED TO SEE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE RETURNING TO THIS
ISSUE AND DISCUSSING THE WAYS IN
WHICH ALL OF THE SYSTEMS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS ARE
INTERCONNECTED. MY MEMBERS HAVE
A STRONG SENSE OF URGENCY IN
ADDRESSING THE INTERSECTION OF
THE POVERTY HOMELESSNESS AND
CHILD AND FAMILY WELL BEING WE
KNOW THAT FAMILIES DON'T JUST
EXIST IN ONE SPHERE OR HAVE NEED
TO ANSWERING SOMEONE ARAFAT BUT
YOU THINK SPERRY ITS GREAT
SUCCESS A GREAT CHALLENGES.
ACROSS ALL ASPECTS OF THEIR
LIVES- I WOULD LIKE TO TALK BIT
ABOUT THE IMPORT OF CAN. TO
FURTHER FOR THE WORK I'VE CAL
WORK AND CAL WORKS CHU POINT NO
. THE. DISCRIMINATION THERE ARE-
SO MANY BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES
FOR LATER CONCERNS THAT WE'VE
SEEN- ALWAYS BUT CERTAINLY. AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND THIS
CAN BE REALLY OVERWHELMING TO
FAMILIES. IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER WAITING TO REALLY
INSTALL THE CAL WORKS TO PLAY
NOW AND CAL WAR. PRINCIPLE AND
THE IDEAS BEHIND THESE EFFORTS
TO REALLY ENGAGE WITH OUR
CLIENTS TO MEET THEM WHERE THEY
ARE. IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN BE GOAL
ORIENTED AND LYFT COMPLIANCE
ORIENTED WITH THE FAMILIES THAT
WE WORK WITH AND REALLY ENGAGE
WITH THEM AND MAKE THAT
CONNECTION. SO THAT WE CAN HOPE
TO. ADDRESS NOT JUST THE ISSUES
THAT THEY HAVE BROUGHT THEM IN
THE DOOR I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY FOR EXAMPLE AND CAL WORKS
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO PAY THE
BILLS. I NEED TO HAVE FOOD ON
THE TABLE FOR MY FAMILY BUT TO
ALSO FIND OUT WHAT ELSE IS GOING
ON IN THEIR LIVES AND HELP THEM
GET THE KINDS OF SERVICES THAT
WE CAN OFFER THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
STRENGTHEN THE FAMILY. AND MOVE
FORWARD. INTO THE WORK FORCE
BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE ARE INTO
. AN EDUCATION OR TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT MIGHT MAKE THE MOST
SENSE WHILE THEY'RE ALSO ABLE TO
GET SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
REPEATED ISSUE OTHER ISSUES.
THAT THE FAMILIES. ARE
EXPERIENCING. THINKING ABOUT THE
REPORTS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY- SUCH AS POWER OF
LINE UP. THE BUDGET THAT ARE
WORK THAT I THAT TOUCHED LITTLE
COVER IT IF YOU. BOTH OF THESE
ARE FOR REALLY HIGHLIGHTED TO
CONTINUE REFORMING CAL WORKS IN
THE DIRECTION OF TO POINT OUT.
AND THE FULLY AND SUPPORT AND
EMBRACE THE PRINCIPLE THAT-
FRANKLY DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND-
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR MAKES THAT
WE'RE TALKINGABOUT. INCLUSION
EQUITY AND BUILDING ON THE
STRENGTHS OF FAMILIES TO SUPPORT
THEM AND MOVING FORWARD. WE
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO DO THAT IN
BIG WAYS THAT POSITIVELY IMPACT
CLIENTS. FUNDING SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS AND GIVING THEM
OPPORTUNITIES AND LIKE I SAID
MAKING THAT HE COULD GAUGE MAY
CONNECTION WITH FAMILIES. IT
ALSO TAKES A DEEP CULTURE SEX TO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
PROGRAM. I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT THERE ABOUT THAT WORK
PARTICIPATION RIGHT.
HISTORICALLY W. P. R. HAS BEEN
THE SOLE FOCUS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN PARTICULAR AS THE ONLY
MEASURE AND THAT HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME DRIVER OF POLICY AND
PRACTICE. THERE'S A REAL
RECOGNITION ACROSS THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY THE W. P. R. ISN'T THE
BEST MEASURE AND SHOULDN'T BE
THE ONLY MEASURE AND THIS IS A-
BIPARTISAN. THAT THE KERN IT
JUST HAS NOT YET LED TO. THAT
THE LEVEL. BUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE TAKEN THE
STEPS. MEANT TO POINT OUT TO-
ENACTED NOW BEGIN GETTING BACK
TO IMPLEMENTING CAL OR WHAT
YOU'RE REALLY CLOSE THAT OUR
EFFORTS TO MOVE AWAY FROM THIS
APPROACH FOR CALIFORNIA. OUT
DESPITE THE RECENT EFFORTS
THOUGH THE PENALTY LANGUAGE THAT
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR COMMENTS-
OPENING THAT THE HEARING TODAY.
HAS REALLY SLOWED OUR EFFORTS
AND REMAINS A BARRIER. TO
FURTHER. HELLO OR IS AN EFFORT
TO MEASURE. TO TAKE A 36 DEGREES
LOOK AT GIVEN A SET. WITH ARE
FOR. ARE SOCIAL SIR CAR
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY THE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE WHO HAD EXPERIENCE OF THE
PROGRAM. LOOK AT MEASURES AND
DATA AND HOW WE'RE DOING ON
MULTIPLE MEASURES AND THEN
DEVELOP IMPROVEMENT PLANS. IT'S
THAT ARE CONTINUOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT APPROACH. MOVING
AWAY FROM A PENALTY OR COME.
COMPLIANCE BASED APPROACH WITH
THE COUNTIES IN THE SAME WAY WE
ARE TRYING TO CHANGE THAT
PENALTY BASED. COMPLIANCE BASED
APPROACH WITH OUR OWN CUSTOMERS
THAN THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE.
BUT WHAT THE PENALTY IS HANGING
OUT THERE IT DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO REALLY GO ALL IN
ON THESE OTHER MEASURES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. THOSE AND THESE
APPROACH THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR LONG TERM NATURE WHY
ARE. AND THE W. P. R. IS THE
SHORT TERM WATER OFF KIND OF
MEASURE. AND IT'S THE THING THAT
CAN GET THE COUNTY PENALIZED IT
CREATES A REAL CATCH TWENTY TWO.
FOR COUNTIES FOR INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS FOR SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS AND HOW THEY TALK WITH
STAFF. ABOUT IMPLEMENTING THESE
CHIU REALLY DICHOTOMOUS THINGS
AT THE SAME TIME. SO WE CAN
THINK THE PENALTY PASSED THROUGH
LANGUAGE BEING A- WILL NOT MAKE
COUNTIES LEFT ACCOUNTABLE IN
FACT IT WILL HELP COUNTY SPEAK.
YOU KNOW WITH A UNIFIED VOICE
WITH OUR OTHER WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS WITH OUR STAFF AND BE
ABLE TO I THINK REALLY. AREN'T
EMBRACE TO POINT OUT HOW OR IN A
WAY THAT THEY'VE PERHAPS NOT
FULLY BEEN ABLE TO WIN THAT
LANGUAGES. OUT THERE. WAS ALSO
TO GIVE THE PERSON FROM POLICY
OF MINE REPORTED CERTAINLY HAVE
MORE ACCURATE. I'M SURE IT'S
ABOUT BUT- REALLY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THINK TO THE ABOUT-
SOME OF THE THAT. PIECES OF THAT
REPORT- HAVE REALLY ALSO BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC-
IT'S IMPORTANT TO FACTOR THAT IN
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE- RE ENGAGEMENT OF OUR
CUSTOMERS WHO MADE FOR NOW. I
TWO YEARS NOT HAVE REALLY BEEN
ENGAGED EITHER OR WITH THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM WITH THE WORK
FORCE OR WITH THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT WE OFFER. BECAUSE
THOSE HAVE BEEN LOCKED DOWN
THEMSELVES. WHAT THESE ARE. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING TO MOVE THE
PROGRAM CLOSER TO THAT VISION OF
TWO POINT NOW IN THE LONGER
TERM. AND WHAT IS GOING THE MOST
DIRECTLY HELP PROTECT. I DO WANT
TO ALSO COMMENDED THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THE APPROACH THAT TOOK I
MEAN YOU SEE A LOT IN THERE AND
THERE'S A LOT TO BE CONSIDERED.
THE APPROACH THAT'S NOTED THAT-
IN THE HEARING AGENDA OF HAVING
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JUST THE WORK AROUND- KIND OF
WHAT SAID THAT REPORT AND WHAT
NEXT STEPS MIGHT BE WITH A LOT
OF THAT BECAUSE IT IS A LITTLE
BIT AT- SEEMS LIKE A REALLY.
GOOD SET UP NEXT TO ME. IN A
LONGER TERM I THINK- OF
SOMETHING WE'D ALSO EMPHASIZED
IS TO REALLY REMEMBER THAT
COUNTIES DO HAVE FLEXIBILITY.
BECAUSE OF THE TYPES OF
POPULATIONS WE SERVE THE
INDUSTRIES THAT MAYBE WITHIN THE
COUNTY OF THE NEEDS THAT ARE
PARTICULAR IN ATLANTIC COUNTY
AND SO ENABLING FLEXIBILITY TO
CONTINUE. AND NOT HAVING IT BE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL PROGRAM ACROSS
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IT'S.
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN. AND THEN-
FINAL JUST THINKING ABOUT THE
INNER. BETWEEN CHILD WELFARE.
AND POVERTY CAL WERE. EVERYTHING
THAT I RECKON THANK YOU AS YOU
BOTH LOOK TOWARD POSSIBLE HERE
DURING THIS BUDGET AS WELL AS A
LONGER TERM CONVERSATION FOR US
ALL- WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT
THERE'S INTERSECTION BETWEEN
POVERTY AND THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM NOT THAT POVERTY CLASSES
OF HOUSTON THAT COLLECT BUT THAT
POVERTY CAUSES SIGNIFICANT
STRESS ON FAMILIES. THAT CAN AT
TIMES BRING THEM TO THE
ATTENTION OF CHILD WELFARE. AT
TIMES BECAUSE OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT THAT IS OCCURRING BUT
ALSO BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THEM EVEN IF THERE'S NOT
SOMETHING GOING ON THAT'S RIGHT
INTO THAT LEVEL OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
HELP STRENGTHEN FAMILIES SO THEY
NEVER BECOME TO THE ATTENTION OF
THE SYSTEM OR GET INTO THE
SYSTEM IS REALLY CRITICAL YOU
KNOW- IN THIS CURRENT YEAR WE
HAVE FUNDING FOR A VERY LARGE
PREVENTION EFFORTS. THAT YOU
SUPPORTED MISTER CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE THIS
PAST YEAR THAT HAS YET TO GET
UNDERWAY BUT WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
DEPARTMENT. AS WELL AS THE
EIGHTY PLUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HELPED YOU SUPPORT AND MAKE IT
HAPPEN THIS IS A DEFINITE.
REALLY GET INTO. TO TALK THAT
DOES PER. SAID IN EQUITIES THAT
WE SPEAK AND HOW WE CAN
STRENGTHEN FAMILIES. AND KEEP
THEM OUT OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM BY NOT JUST PROVIDING-
I'D BE USED TO COLLECT BUT
PREVENTING EVEN THAT FIRST CALL.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE PLAN WE WILL
BE STRONGER THE COMMUNITY WILL
HAVE SERVICES IN PLACE. M. THEN-
AWAY TO HELP STRENGTHEN THAT. WE
ALSO NEED TO BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILIES CHILDREN AND CAREGIVERS
WHO ARE SYSTEM INVOLVED- FOR
EXAMPLE WE KNOW THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT CAL WORKS IN CHILD
WELFARE OVERLAP. BETWEEN THE TWO
PROGRAMS WE ARE LAST YEAR-
PROPOSED AND WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE APPROVED- THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE CAL WORKS
PAYMENTS TO FAMILIES. WHEN
THEY'RE SPEAKING TO REUNIFY WITH
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
INTO FOSTER CARE. THERE'S ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT EFFORT UNDER WAY TO
REALLY REVITALIZED AND REVAMPED
OUR LINKAGES PROJECT WILL
CALLING IT LIKE IT JUST TO POINT
OUT. AND THAT REALLY- IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN OUR CAL
WORKS IN OUR CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM LOCALLY. TO IDENTIFY AND
BETTER SERVICE COORDINATOR
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR
FAMILIES INVOLVED IN BOTH
SYSTEMS. THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER
OF DISCUSSIONS THE PAST HEARINGS
ABOUT OTHER WAYS TO SUPPORT
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH. CARE
GIVERS THAT RELATIVE CARE GIVERS
AS WELL SO I WON'T GO INTO THAT
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME BUT- I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY
THINGS OUT THERE THAT. ARE
PRETTY CRITICAL TO HELPING ALL
OF THESE FAMILIES AND WE KNOW
THAT MANY OF OUR CARE GIVERS
ESPECIALLY RELATIVES ARE
THEMSELVES LIVING IN POVERTY.
THE THINKING ABOUT WAYS TO
SUPPORT THEM THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL. AND THEN FINALLY I'LL
JUST SHARE THAT- SUPPORTING AND
STRENGTHENING OUR OWN WORKFORCE
IS REALLY CRITICAL AS WELL.
THERE'S THERE AND- I EFFORT THIS
YEAR TO REALLY LOOK I THINK
ACROSS A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
AS WELL AS WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON HOW WE CAN
ENHANCE OUR WORKFORCE WE HAVE
OUR OWN PROPOSAL TO WTA ALONG
WITH AN S. W. S. I. U. AND THAT
. USE OF THIS WORK WILL. TO AND
AFTER MASTERS OF SOCIAL WORK
FOR. BUT WE DON'T ALSO A ROOM-
TRAINING FOR COUNTY STAFF JUST.
OF DISPROPORTIONATELY ACT. AND
INCLUDED ISSUE. BUT ALSO JOB TO
THAT THEY- FEEL. I TRIED AND P.
T. GET THAT WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
SEEING A OUR- JUST AS OTHER
WORK. THAT ARE THE- AND ALL HOW
TO ENTER TOM INFORMED. TO DO
THEIR OWN WORK WITH FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY GIVEN WHAT ALL OF US
HAVE EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS. WITHOUT ALL WRAPPED
UP AND AS YOU KNOW I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU GET
INTO DISCUSSION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
AS HE HOOKED FULLER MASK FINANCE
IF I CAN TO CREATE A LITTLE
SPACE FOR. THEM AS WELL AS MY
CARROLL- THAT'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU. I CAN HEAR IT.
WONDERFUL HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR A MINUTE IF YOU CUT
FULL- THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY. I WANT TO START BY
STRESSING THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES WANT THE ABILITY TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE. KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS AND HELP THEIR
CHILDREN THRIVE. FAMILIES ALSO
NEED SUPPORT TO DEAL WITH THE
MYRIAD STRESSORS OF POVERTY.
RACE AND GENDER DISCRIMINATION
IN THE LABOR MARKET AND OTHER
BARRIERS TO HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY. YES UNDER THE FEDERAL
CANNOT PROGRAM STATES CAN BE
PENALIZED FOR HELPING PARENTS
WITH THESE BARRIERS INSTEAD OF
JUST PUSHING THEM INTO PAID
EMPLOYMENT. AND CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT PLANNED TO PASS ANY
POTENTIAL PENALTY ONTO THE
COUNTY'S. MAKES IT HARDER TO
WORK WITH FAMILIES WITH LOW
INCOMES AND TO OFFER THEM THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. WE KNOW
THAT EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS ARE
TRAUMA INFORMED. RECOGNIZE A
FAMILY CIRCUMSTANCES AND FOCUS
ON FAMILY STRENGTH. OVER THE
YEARS THE COMMERCE PROGRAM HAS
RIGHTLY CHANGE TO BETTER REFLECT
THESE PRINCIPLES AND THAT WORK
SHOULD BE CONTINUED. STATE
LEADERS MUST COMMIT TO HELPING
PARENTS ADDRESS BARRIERS AND
THAT MEANS REMOVING OR REVISING
THE PENALTY PASS ON SO THAT IT
NO LONGER DISCOURAGES FULLY
PROVIDING THE CRITICAL
COUNSELING AND EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PARENTS NEED
. WE KNOW THAT CARE HOWARD'S
PARENTS FACE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES AND ADVERSE
EXPERIENCES THAT NEGATIVELY
AFFECT THEIR EMPLOYMENT
PROSPECTS IN THEIR HEALTH. IT
ALMOST FOUR IN TEN CAL WORKS
CASES THE HEAD OF THE HOUSEHOLD
DID NOT COMPLETE HIGH SCHOOL.
ADDITIONALLY ON AVERAGE AT LEAST
31% OF CLIENTS EACH MONTH REPORT
HAVING MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
. I 20% I HAVE FACED DOMESTIC
ABUSE- AND 5% HAVE STRUGGLED
WITH SUBSTANCE USE AND THIS DATA
REFLECTS NATIONAL RESEARCH THAT
MOST TEN OF RECIPIENTS HAVE AT
LEAST ONE BEAR TO WORK AND MANY
HAVE MULTIPLE BARRIERS. AND ALSO
THE LIKELIHOOD OF WORK TO
CLIENTS AS THE NUMBER OF
BARRIERS INCREASES. AND YET
COUNTER INTUITIVELY THE FEDERAL
KIND OF PROGRAM AND ITS
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATES FOCUSES
ONLY ON GETTING PARENTS INTO
JOBS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND
NOT ON HELPINGTHEM ADDRESS
LONGER TERM BARRIERS TO WORK.
THIS SHORT SIGHTED WORK FIRST
MENTALITY IS REFLECTED IN THE
WORK PARTICIPATION RATE OR WPR-
AS OTHERS SPEAKERS HAVE ALREADY
NOTED BEFORE ME. BUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TODAY IS THAT WPR IS
NOT JUST A FLAWED MEASURE BUT
THAT IT IS SPECIFICALLY- A
FEDERALLY DEFINED A NARROW SET
OF WELFARE TO WORK ACTIVITIES.
DESPITE THE RESEARCH THAT SHOWS
THAT PARENTS NEED BOTH
EMPLOYMENT FOCUSED ACTIVITIES
AND OF THOSE SUPPORTING
EDUCATION AND TREATMENT. SUCH
SUPPORT OF ACTIVITIES DO NOT
FULLY COUNT TOWARDS THE WPR. IN
RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA POLICY
MAKERS HAVE TAKEN THE INITIATIVE
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THIS WORK
FORCED MODEL AND INSTEAD TO
FOLLOW THE RESEARCH ON HOW TO
ADVANCE FAMILY WILL BEGINNING.
THESE STEPS INCLUDE SB TEN FORTY
ONE IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHICH
CREATED NEW STATE STANDARDS
UNDER WHICH BARRIER REMOVAL
ACTIVITIES AND EDUCATION ARE
ACTUALLY EQUAL TO WORK
ACTIVITIES. THOUGH IN THE SHORT
TERM CALIFORNIA COULD RISK A
PENALTY FOR NOT MEETING TARGET
WORK RATES. THESE MORE HOLISTIC
STANDARDS ARE BETTER FOR
FAMILIES AND COULD ACTUALLY HELP
INCREASE THE STATE'S WORK RATES
IN THE LONG TERM. UNFORTUNATELY
THE STATE'S LONGSTANDING POLICY-
TO MAKE COMPANIES PAY HALF OF
ANY POTENTIAL PENALTY HINDERS
THIS PROGRESS. THE CALIFORNIA
HAS NEVER ACTUALLY GET PAID UPON
A PENALTY THE PENALTY SHARING
PROVISION EFFECTIVELY
DISCOURAGES COUNTIES FROM FULLY
IMPLEMENTING THE STATE'S OWN
POWERS REFORMS. AND HAS REAL ON
THE GROUND CONSEQUENCES FOR OUR
FAMILIES. ARANDA VALUATION OF
THE RECENT- POLICY CHANGES HAVE
SHOWN THAT COUNTY CASE WORKERS
PERCEIVE AN INHERENT CONFLICT
BETWEEN HOLISTICALLY SUPPORTING
PARENTS ON THE ONE HAND. AND
MEETING THE V. PR IN THE OTHER
BECAUSE CASE WORKERS CAN BE
PENALIZED WHEN THE PARENTS THEY
SUPPORT DO NOT MEET THESE TYPE
WORK AT THESE WORK TARGET. AS A
RESULT OF SOME CASE WORKERS
REPORTED ACTUALLY FEELING LIKE
WE NEEDED TO STEER CLIENTS AWAY
FROM ACTIVITIES LIKE TREATMENT
TREATMENT AND EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY MAY NOT MEET W. P. R. THE
STATE CAN AND SHOULD MOVE ON
FROM THIS UNSUSTAINABLE STATUS
QUO. ONE OPTION IS TO REMOVE THE
PENALTY SHARING POLICY ENTIRELY
SO THAT CASE WORKERS CAN INSTEAD
FOCUS ON HELPING PARENTS REMOVE
BARRIERS TO WORK AND SUPPORTING
THEIR GOALS. ANOTHER OPTION
WOULD BE TO SHIELD COUNTIES FROM
POTENTIAL PENALTIES ARE PROVIDED
THEY WOULD HAVE MEANT WPR
TARGETS IF BARRIER REMOVAL
ACTIVITIES ACTUALLY FULLY
COUNTED AND CALCULATING THE WORK
RATE. BUT BEYOND REVISING THE W.
P. R. POLICY OF THE STATE SHOULD
FOCUS ON STRENGTHENING OUR
OVERALL SO THAT FAX IS DEFINED
AS HELPING PARENTS MOVE. OUT OF
POVERTY AND TOWARDS MEETING
THEIR PERSONAL GOALS. AT THE
STATE LEADERS SHOULD ALSO COMMIT
TO FULLY IMPLEMENTING COVERAGE
TWO POINT NOW AND CAL OR
ENSURING ROBUST GRANTS ABOVE.
THE POVERTY FOR ALL COLORS
FAMILIES AND FOCUS ON PURSUING
POLICIES TO IMPROVE THE LABOR
MARKET FOR PARENTS WITH LOW
INCOMES SO THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
CHILD AND FAMILY COULD THRIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE WILL GO
BACK MY APOLOGIES WE SKIP
JENNIFER CRAPPIE- SHE DAY THEY
ARE ON THE WEBEX AND SO.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN BEGIN WHEN
THEY'RE READY. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH HELLO CHAIRED MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER CRAPPIE WITH
VOICES CALIFORNIA. THE MEMBERS
OF OUR VOICES ARE REALLY
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND THE ISSUES FACING OUR
SYSTEM. BECAUSE MANY LIKE MYSELF
ARE EITHER CURRENT OR FORMER OUR
EXPERTISE IN. WELL PARA VOICES.
SPECIFICALLY WORKS ON CHILD CARE
ISSUES MANY PARENTS ACCESS CHILD
CARE BECAUSE OF THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN CAO WORKS. IT
IS BECAUSE OF THAT CONNECTION
THAT CBS HAS ENGAGED WITH PARA
VOICES MEMBERS TO IDENTIFY
PROBLEMS IN THE CAO WORKS TO
STOP AS WELL AS RECOMMENDATIONS
TO ADDRESS THAT. THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES INTENTIONALLY
ENGAGE PARENTS THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT WAYS AS THEY CREATED
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
REPORT. IT ALL STARTED WITH CAL
OR BAD CALIFORNIA OUTCOME AN
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW WHICH
DEVELOPED A NEW SET OF MEASURES
TO DETERMINE WHAT SUCCESS LOOKS
LIKE IN THE CAO WORKS PROGRAM.
OVER THE COURSE OF TWO YEARS DSS
CONVENED A COHORT OF PARENTS TO
MEET THE- AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CAL OR- IN
ORDER TO HELP PARENTS EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO PARTICIPATE. DSS
PROVIDED PARENTS WITH STIPENDS
FOR PARTICIPATION IN MEETINGS
AND COVER THE COSTOF
TRANSPORTATION CHILDCARE. MEALS
INTERPRETATION AND EVEN PROVIDED
A PRIVATE NURSING ROOM FOR ONE
OF OUR OUR NEW MOBS. THIS THIS
IS WHAT I'VE BEEN TAKE PARENT
ENGAGEMENT REALLY LOOKS LIKE.
AFTER THE CULMINATION OF THE COW
OR PROCESS A SMALLER GROUP OF
AIRPORT ORGANIZER SOME PARENTS
CONTINUE TO MEET AS PART OF THAT
POLICY ALIGNMENT WORKGROUP.
FIFTEEN HELP IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
SHORT MIDDLE AND LONG TERM
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD HELP REALIZE THAT VISION
CREATED BY THE CAL OR G. THERE
ARE THREE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT PURPOSES
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ELEVATED TO
THE TOP PRIORITY. WHILE ALL OF
THE PROPOSALS IN THE REPORT ARE
WORTHY PARENTS ARE ELEVATING THE
FOLLOWING THREE AS THE ONES THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
BUDGET CYCLE. FIRST
RECOMMENDATION THIRTEEN HE FIRST
AND FOREMOST IS THE
RECOMMENDATION TO INSTITUTE A
FAMILY NAVIGATOR FOR PEER
SUPPORT MODEL. AS WE ALL KNOW
HOME NAVIGATING THE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM CAN BE CHALLENGING AND
CAN BE FILLED WITH LOTS OF
INTENSE AND OVERWHELMING
REQUIREMENTS. HAVING ANOTHER
PERSON VERBALLY ONE WHO'S BEEN
THROUGH THE CALL WORK SYSTEM
THEMSELVES CAN HELP FAMILIES
NAVIGATE THE CONFUSING LANDSCAPE
OF SUPPORT. IDEALLY THESE
NAVIGATORS SHOULD HAVE DIRECT
EXPERIENCE WITH THE CALL WORKS
TO STOP. IT'S SO EASY FOR
PARENTS TO FEEL JUDGED FOR BEING
INVOLVED IN THE SYSTEM THAT
JUDGMENT REALLY PREVENTS PARENTS
FROM SEEKING OUT THE RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT THAT THEIR FAMILY SO
DESPERATELY NEED. FORMER CAO
WORKS PARTICIPANTS ARE IN A
POSITION TO MEET INCOMING CALL
WORKS FAMILIES WITH EMPATHY WITH
LOVE AND CARE THAT THEY REALLY
NEED TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
FAMILIES. NO ONE GOES ON WELFARE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO. PEOPLE WHO
SEEK OUT HOW WORKS ARE DOING SO
AT A TIME A TREMENDOUS HONOR
ABILITY. WITHOUT FAIL PARENTS
CONSISTENTLY REPORT FEELING.
THROUGHOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE WITH
OUR- AND THAT THE HUMANIZATION
IS FELT EVEN MORE STRONGLY FROM
PARENTS OF COLOR. FAMILY
NAVIGATORS WHO'VE BEEN THERE
BEFORE WE BRING AN IMPORTANT
HUMAN ELEMENT AND ALLOW FAMILIES
TO LET THEIR GUARDS DOWN AND
OPEN THEMSELVES UP TO THE
POSSIBILITIES FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THAT IS WHY
INSTITUTING A FAMILY NAVIGATOR
MODEL IS THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
OF PARENTS. RECOMMENDATION
THIRTEEN P. RELATED TO FAMILY
NAVIGATORS THANK FAMILY
NAVIGATOR MODEL IS TO REINSTATE
THE FAMILY SERVICE TEAM. I
TESTIFIED IN THIS VERY HEARING
ROOM ABOUT BEING A BENEFICIARY
OF ACCESSING THE FAMILY SERVICE
TEAM WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY APPROACH TO
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR FAMILIES.
IT BEGINS TO ADDRESS ALL THE
CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS THAT
FAMILIES FACE SO I KNOW THAT
THEY CAN GET TO THE PROGRAM AND
HOW FULFILLING AND MEANINGFUL
LIVES. HOWEVER THIS WAS CUT FROM
THE CALL WORKS- BUDGET DURING
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT RECESSION
AND HAS YET TO RETURN. AND
FINALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
NAME OF COW WORKS CHANGED- WOULD
LIKE TO LOOK AT THAT OF THE
SYSTEM IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITY
HISTORICALLY I WORKED WITH FOR
ME MEASURING WORKFORCE
PARTICIPATION. THE ONLY EXTRA OF
. THAT OUT IT WHAT IF THINKING
IS ROOTED IN THE NOTION BUT S
LONG AS PARENTS ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE WORKFORCE
THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL. IT'S NOT
JUST THE NAME IT'S A STATEMENT
OF WHAT THIS PROGRAM IS ALL
ABOUT. OR IS GOING TO WORK COULD
BE A PART OF THAT. BUT IT'S
TRULY ABOUT SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA FOUND AND SO PARENTS
FROM PARAGUAY SAYS REALLY WANT
TO SEE THE NAME CHANGED TO HELP
THEM. THIS REPORT PROVIDES YOU
WITH AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
TO JUST TO CHANGE THE WAY
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE CAN LEAD THE
NATION AND NO MORE EQUITABLE
PROGRAM THAT DELIVERS HIGH
QUALITY COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY AND INTO SUCCESSFUL
THRIVING AND MEANINGFUL LIVES.
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT. IS TO
COME BACK TO IMPLEMENTING THE
ITEMS IN THIS POLICY ALIGNMENT
REPORT ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
RANKED HIGHEST. WHAT'S MOST TO
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS. FOR YOU
WANT IT FOR TO KNOW IS THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED
THE PEOPLE IN OUR WORK
THEMSELVES HAD A VOICE IN MAKING
THESE POLICIES FROM THE
BEGINNING WHICH IN AND OF ITSELF
MEANS THAT THEY HAVE A HIGHER
CHANCE OF BEING SUCCESSFUL.
FAMILIES KNOW WHAT WORKS. AND
WHAT DOESN'T WORK WE'RE ASKING
YOU TO LISTEN TO THEM AND TO
TAKE ACTION ON THE
RECOMMENDATION. IT'S PAST TIME
WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE CAN BE PROUD OF. AND
THIS IS A BLUEPRINT TO ACTUALLY
MAKE IT HAPPEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS CRAPPIE NEXT WE HAVE MY
CARROLLTON IS THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. WITH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND
STAFF APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC- YOU FOR QUITE
AWHILE QUITE A LOT ALREADY FROM.
THE OTHER THE OTHER PANELISTS SO
I'M GOING TO TRY TO FOCUS MY
REMARKS INTO A COUPLE OF AREAS
SOME OF WHICH YOU'VE HEARD A BIT
ABOUT BUT HOPEFULLY PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT-
DIFFERENT- PERSPECTIVE ON THEM-
I THINK YOUR ANALYSIS DOES A
VERY GOOD JOB I THINK ABOUT LINE
SORT OF THE PATH THAT WE'VE BEEN
ON- YOU KNOW I THINK THERE WAS A
REAL CONSENSUS AMONG- THE
COUNTIES THE ADVOCATES. OF
LEGISLATORS THE DEPARTMENT- THAT
WE REALLY NEEDED TO TAKE A REAL
FRESH LOOK AT THE CAR WORKS
PROGRAM- I THINK- WE WILL WE'RE
LEARNING A LOT AND SEEN THAT THE
APPROACH THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TAKING FOR MANY DECADES. NOT
ONLY WAS A COMPLIANCE ORIENTED
MODEL BUT I THINK IN MANY WAYS
HAD SORT OF. PLATEAUED AND WAS
NO LONGER PROVIDING THE BENEFIT
THAT WE THOUGHT WE MIGHT GET
SOME MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF THE
FAMILIES REALLY WEREN'T ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE EFFECTIVELY IN THE
PROGRAM. AND WHILE THERE WAS A
PERCENTAGE OF THE FACT THE CASES
THAT COULD MEET THE WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE AND ALL THE
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS THE
COUNTIES THAT WASN'T THE CASE
FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
FAMILIES AND I THINK THAT
UNDERSTANDING REALLY KIND OF
DROVE THE DESIRE FOR BOTH- CAL
WORKS TWO POINT NO. AND
EVENTUALLY THE FORMATION OF
CALIFORNIA- AND- THE- YOU KNOW
THE- AS WE WENT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS OF DISCOVERY AND I
THINK- I LEARNED MORE ABOUT IT I
THINK IT. IT BECAME APPARENT TO
US THAT- THE RULE OF THE RULES
OF THE PROGRAM ITSELF WERE A
MAJOR BARRIER TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE- WHEN WE WERE
DESIGNING CAL OR FOR EXAMPLE
THERE WERE SEVERAL MOMENTS
WHERE- WE REALIZE THAT WHAT WE
WANTED TO MEASURE SOMETHING WE
HAD A LAW THAT ACTUALLY MANDATED
THE OFFICES. AND SO THAT IT WAS
FROM THAT MOMENT I THINK THAT WE
BEGAN TO REALIZE THAT WE NEEDED
TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE NOW
COME FORWARD TO YOU TODAY- AND I
THINK- THOSE. THE RECKON I THINK
ARE BEGINNING I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY CAPTURE EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEED TO DO AND CAL WORKS- BUT I
DO THINK THAT THEY ARE A START-
BUT WE REALLY HAVE TO GO BACK I
THINK AND I. WILL CALL IT THIS
JUST FOR MAYBE TO BE A LITTLE
BIT COLORFUL- THE ORIGINAL SCENT
OF TANNA WHICH IS. THE WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE THAT WAS
IMPOSED ON COUNTIES COMBINED
WITH THE THIRTY HOUR WORK
REQUIREMENTS AND THE USE OF
SANCTIONS TO COMPLY. PEOPLE TO
HAVE TO PERFORM THE DUTIES THAT
WERE ASSIGNED TO THEM- AND SO I
THINK WE'RE AT THIS REALLY
CRITICAL JUNCTURE WHERE WE
CONTINUE. TO LIVE UNDER THE
FEDERAL LAW AND CONTINUE TO PUSH
COUNTY EMPLOYEES TO CONTINUE TO
HOLD PEOPLE TO THAT STANDARD
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW. IT'S HARD
FOR MANY CASES. OR WE CAN CHOOSE
THE PATH OF BRAVERY WHICH IS TO
SAY WE'RE GOING TO REALLY FOLLOW
CAL WORKS TWO POINT OH AND THE
CALOR MODELS AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
LEARNING IN OUR SESSIONS AND-
TAKE THE RISK. THAT THIS IS
WHAT'S BEST FOR FAMILIES AND
KNOW THAT IN IF SOME FEDERAL
PENALTY WERE TO COME DOWN I
WOULD REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
NO STATE HAS EVER BEEN ASSESSED
A PENALTY ON ON THE ALL FAMILY
RATE ONLY ON THE TWO POUND. RATE
THAT THAT RISK IS WELL WORTH
TAKING. THAT OUR FAMILIES ARE
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO US THAT WE
WOULD DO THE RIGHT THING AND WE
WOULD MOVE BEYOND THE CAL WORKS-
PENALTY FORMULA THAT WE HAVE IN
CURRENT LAW SO YOUR- YOUR
ANALYSIS- PUTS THE LAW RIGHT OUT
THERE THINK IT'S ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS THAT'S
WASN'T HALF A PAGE LONG- AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I REALLY
BELIEVE THE ADMINISTRATION NEEDS
TO TAKE A REALLY STRONG LOOK AT
IF WE WANT THIS PROGRAM TO A
BALL BEYOND WHERE IT IS BANNED
FOR THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
DECADES WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
MOTIVATIONS THAT ARE DRIVING
COUNTIES AND CAO AND THE
WORKERS- THAT WE'VE WE'VE HELD
IN PLACE FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
DECADES. SO AGAIN I WOULD JUST
REMIND THAT THE REASON THAT WE-
WE WENT THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND
I HAVE NOT YET ACKNOWLEDGED THE
GREAT WORK OF CDSS AND MISS MAY
CENTER STAFF THEY'VE BEEN A JOY
TO WORK WITH AND THEY'VE DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB AND WE GOT
INTERRUPTED BECAUSE COVE AND ALL
THAT BUT WE PICKED THE PIECES
BACK UP AND REPORTS NOW IN FRONT
OF YOU AND SO I DO WANT TO
COMMEND THE DEPARTMENT FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE. BUT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS THOUGH WAS TO
IDENTIFY LEGAL BARRIERS TO
REFORMING CAL WORKS AT ALLOWING
TWO POINT OO TO REALLY FUNCTION
THE WAY THAT WE BELIEVE IT CAME
OUT OF THE WAY THE SCIENCE TELLS
US THAT IT CAN AND SO I THINK AS
WE LOOK AT THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
I WOULD REALLY DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THOSE THINGS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT
THAT ARE LEGAL IN NATURE AND- SO
I THINK. YOU KNOW NUMBER ONE OUR
LIST IS CLEARLY THE TOWN OF
PENALTY PASS ON. AND REFORMING
THAT PROCESS I THINK WE'RE
REFORMING THAT SYSTEM TAKING
THAT BERRIER OFF OF COUNTIES IS
THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO MAKE THIS SYSTEM
THIS PROGRAM WORK BETTER. AND
REALLY HELP FAMILIES GET OUT OF
POVERTY. NOW I THINK YOU
PROBABLY HEARD THAT FROM ALMOST
ALL OF US TODAY SO I THINK I
WON'T GO DOWN THAT PATH TO MUCH
FURTHER- BUT I DO WANT TO CALL
OUT A FEW OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
IN THE REPORT- THAT. I THINK ARE
OF THE SAME NATURE- ONE IS THAT
FOR MANY MANY YEARS. CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD A VERY. LIMITED POLICY
OF PROVIDING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WAIVERS FROM WELFARE TO WORK-
RIGHT NOW IT'S COUNTY OPTION
ESSENTIALLY IF A FAMILY COMES IN
HAS A HISTORY OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE COUNTY GETS THE
DETERMINE SENSUALLY WHETHER OR
NOT THAT PERSON SHOULD
PARTICIPATE IN WELFARE TO WORK-
WE THINK THAT'S COMPLETELY
BACKWARDS WE THINK THAT THE
OPTION REALLY OUGHT TO LIVE WITH
FAMILIES ABOUT THEIR WILLINGNESS
AND THEIR READINESS TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE WE ALSO DON'T
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WELLSTONE
AMENDMENT VERY WELL ON OUR STATE
WHICH COULD HELP OUR WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE BY THE WAY.
AND I'M SORRY DO A CHECKPOINT
WILSON AMENDMENT THE WASSERMAN
IS A PART OF THE TOWN OF LAW
THAT SAYS THAT IF I IF THE STATE
DOES- PROVIDE A WAIVER FROM
WELFARE T WORK TO DO
UNDOCUMENTED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THAT THAT CASE DURING THOSE
MONTHS DOESN'T COUNT AGAINST THE
WORK STATION RIGHT SO WE DON'T
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT VERY WELL
ARE LAW ACTUALLY KIND OF PUSHES
IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION SO WE
WOULD WE WOULD WE WOULD LIFT
THAT UP THAT'S SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT AND THIS THIS CONCEPT
IS CAPTURED IN A BILL- BY SIMPLY
MEMBER REYES AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN RIGHT NOW A CO
SPONSOR BY WESTERN CENTER
ANOTHER ADVOCATES. AND SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLY THINK NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED SOON- I WILL PILE ON TO
JENNIFER CRAPPIES COMMENT ABOUT
THE NAVIGATORS- WE THINK OF THE
MORE THAT WE CAN GET FORMER CAL
WORKS RECIPIENTS TO HELP CURRENT
CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS WHO HAVE
THAT KNOWLEDGE I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH MANY
MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WHO HAVE LEARNED THE SYSTEM BY
BEING IN TOWERS ALL THE YEARS
AND KNOW HOW TO MAKE IT WORK FOR
THEM AND I THINK IF WE WERE TO
REACH INTO THE US GIVE THEM JOBS
WITHIN THE COUNTIES HELP THEM.
GET THOSE JOBS FOR THEM SO THEY
CAN HELP FAMILIES I THINK WOULD
REALLY ASSIST A LOT OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE- WE LIKE THE NAME CAL CAL
FAMILIES- WE'VE BEEN FUNNY THAT
SHE SAID THAT BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
CALLING IT CAL FAN FOR A WHILE
WE DON'T USE CAO WORKS MUCH MORE
IN OUR OFFICE AND THEN LASTLY-
THERE ARE TWO RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THIS REPORT WHICH I THINK ALSO
WERE SUBSTANTIVE IN NATURE WHICH
REALLY ADDRESS PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT FOR MANY
YEARS- ONE IS PEOPLE. DO NOT GET
THEIR SUPPORT SERVICES IS. AND
PER. TRANSPORTATION NOT YEARSWE
DID. SOME GREAT WORK AND WE NOW
GET CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES TO
PEOPLE WE MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
GET THEM. FOR THE FIRST TWELVE
MONTHS THAT THEY'RE ON THE
PROGRAM. AND WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO GET TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. NOW I THINK WE NEED TO
DO THE SAME FOR TRANSPORTATION.
IF YOU IF A PERSON IS REQUIRED
TO PARTICIPATE IN WELFARE TO
WORK SERVICES. THEY SHOULD GET
AN ADDITIONAL SUM OF MONEY EVERY
MONTH ON THEIR- ON THEIR- EBT
CARD. SO THEY CAN USE TO PAY FOR
THEIR TRANSPORTATION COST. THE
IDEA OF HAVING. GREATER
BUREAUCRACY AND FORMS OF PEOPLE
HAVING TO FILL THEM OUT AND ALL
OF THAT THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT THAT COULD BE ANOTHER
OPTION. I THINK JUST A
STANDARDIZATION OF THIS APPROACH
WOULD BE THE PROPER WAY TO GO.
I'M NOT KNOWING THAT WE'RE HERE
FROM COUNCILS LATER ON IT MAY
TAKE A WHILE TO BUILD IMPLEMENT
THAT IN. FOR A YEAR TO. BUT I
THINK IF WE MADE THE DECISION
THIS YEAR. TO IMPLEMENT THAT AND
GOT THAT IN THE QUEUE. THEN IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT POLICY
WOULD TAKE EFFECT AND REALLY
HAVE A- MARKET EFFECT FOR FOLKS.
NOT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. AND THEN
LASTLY I THINK A NEW THING THAT
WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF SUPPORT SERVICES. YOU
KNOW YOU CAN'T REALLY DO YOUR
JOB YOU CAN'T. YOUR KIDS CAN'T
STUDY VERY WELL UNLESS THEY HAVE
AN INNER INTERNET CONNECTION-
AND THIS REPORT ALSO CALLS OUT
FOR. LIKE WE DO WITH DIAPERS-
PROVIDING THAT- INTERNET
CONNECTION SO THE FAMILIES
ACTUALLY. HAVE THAT SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO THEM THEY CAN
ATTEND THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COURSE THAT THEY KNEW TWO ONE.
ONLINE AND DO A NUMBER OF OTHER
THINGS THAT REALLY FRANKLY IN
THIS MODERN SOCIETY. ARE REQUIRE
INTERNET CONNECTION. OKAY LASTLY
AND YOU ASKED. ABOUT WHAT OTHER
KIND OF THINGS WE CAN DO TO
SUPPORT OUR FAMILIES. YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW. WHAT'S GONNA COME OUT
OF MY MOUTH NEXT MISTER CHAIR. I
WE NEED TO GIVE PEOPLE MORE
MONEY- WE KNOW MONEY WORKS- YOU
KNOW AND IF WE GIVE PEOPLE MORE
MONEY THEY'RE GONNA STAY HOUSED.
THEY'RE GOING TO THEIR KIDS ARE
GONNA BE BETTER OFF- ALL SORTS
OF GOOD POSITIVE THINGS HAPPEN
FOR MORE MONEY. BUT THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS THAT WE CAN DO. AND
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER. HE IS TAKING A LOOK AT
SOME THINGS THAT WERE NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDED WITHIN.
THE- THE- THE CURRENT REPORT
THAT THAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU- FOR
EXAMPLE. WE REALLY DIDN'T GET TO
HAVE A REAL DEEP EXAMINATION OF
ELIGIBILITY- YOU KNOW WE KNOW WE
HAVE A LOW CASE LOAD NUMBER
RIGHT NOW. AND I THINK WE NEED
TO SPEND THE TIME TO. TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE WAY THAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS GOES. AND
ALL THE BEARS REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE AND
EXAMINE THAT TO SEE IF WE CAN
STRIP SOME OF THAT BACK. AND
HELP FAMILIES GET ON AID MORE-
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD CONSIDER. I THINK ALSO WE
HAVE TO REDUCE THE USE OF
SANCTIONS IN THIS PROGRAM. ARE
AND THE SANCTIONS REALLY GO BACK
TO THIS ISSUE ABOUT THE WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE THE REASON
THAT SANCTIONS ARE YOU SO
HEAVILY IN POWER. CALIFORNIA IS
THAT THEY- ARE THE TOOL. FOR
MAKING PEOPLE COMPLY WHY WE
STRIPPED AWAY FROM. AS A EFFORT
TO. PEOPLE TO TRY TO DO WE WANT
THEM TO DO. THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
APPROACH WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE WHERE THEY'RE AT TO HELP
THEM GET. THEM INTO A PLACE
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO WILLINGLY
PARTICIPATE AND DO THE
ACTIVITIES. THAT THEY KNOW ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT THEM- AND THEN
LASTLY- WE'RE HOPING THAT WE CAN
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT- THE
USE OF. WHAT WE WOULD CONSIDER-
OVER USE OF FRAUD INVESTIGATIONS
WITHIN THE HOURS PROGRAM- THERE
IS SORT OF THIS- NOT EVERY
COUNTY I WOULD NOT SAY THAT BUT
IN SOME COUNTIES WE ARE SEEN-
THE USE OF FRAUD INVESTIGATIONS
AND- THIS CONSTANT KIND OF
EXAMINING PEOPLE AND THEIR
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES- HAS
REALLY THREATENING AND DRIVING
PEOPLE- HERE OFTEN PEOPLE BEING
FORCED TO QUIT THE PROGRAM UNDER
THE THREAT OF A LEGAL
PROSECUTION- THAT DOESN'T FEEL
RIGHT TO US AT ALL AND- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY NEEDS TO
EXAMINE AS WE GO FORWARD WITH
THIS PROGRAM AND WITHOUT I WILL
STOP THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM RYAN ANDERSON
WENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON
RYAN ANDERSON'S LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE. OF FIRST WITH
RESPECT TO THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA- AS SOON AS BEEN
NOTED THIS REPORT JUST CAME OUT
AND HAD A GREAT NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ARE STILL IN
THE EARLY STAGES. OF READING
THROUGH A AND- UNDERSTANDING
EACH OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE SUB
COMMITTEE HAS A PARTICULAR
INTEREST IN IDENTIFYING THE
POTENTIAL FISCAL COSTS AND
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH EACH OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE ARE HAPPY
IN AVAILABLE- TO HELP. WITH ALL
THOSE BUT OF COURSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE- DOING OUR DUE
DILIGENCE WITH EACH OF THEM- NOW
JUST TO TAKE A STEP BACK A
LITTLE BIT- AMONG THE BROADER
ISSUES THAT ARE. BEING RAISED-
BOTH IN THE REPORTS OVER
DISCUSSING AND THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU FOR TODAY. ARE REALLY JUST-
FUNDAMENTALLY IS THIS PROGRAM
WORKING AS INTENDED I AND AS
PART OF THAT IS IT REACHING THE
PEOPLE IT'S INTENDED TO REACH
AND HELPING THEM- WE JUST LIKE
TO KNOW WITH THAT THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF WORK THAT WE THINK
IS RELEVANT AND WILL HELP INFORM
THIS CONVERSATION. LAST YEAR WE-
PUBLISHED THE FIRST A PART IN A
SERIES OF WORK THAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO ON THE CAL WORKS TAKE UP
RATE I KNOW AND IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS JUST THIS YEAR.
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN THAT AND WE'VE
BECAUSE OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
INTEREST CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IDENTIFYING WAYS THAT WE CAN-
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MEASURE. IS
AS APPROPRIATE AND ACCURATE AS
IT COULD WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON THEIR EFFORTS AS
WELL. BUT THE OVERALL ESTIMATE
IS NOT A PARTICULARLY- HIGH TAKE
UP RATE WE THINK ABOUT SIXTY
PERCENT. ABOUT THREE OUT OF
EVERY FIVE ELIGIBLE FAMILIES IS
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM. I'LL WHAT THE REST OF
THAT PROJECT ENTAILS AND A LOT
OF ANALYTICAL WORK OVER THE LAST
YEAR IS GONE INTO THIS AND WE
ARE HOPING. IT WILL BEAR FRUIT
AND- IN THE FORM OF PUBLIC
PRODUCTS VERY SHORTLY. ARE THE
QUESTIONS OF WHY DO THOSE
REMAINING TWO FAMILIES NOT
ENROLL IN THE PROGRAM- WHICH
DEMOGRAPHIC AND ECONOMIC GROUPS
ARE LEAST LIKELY TO ENROLL WHICH
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS SHALL-
CONSISTENT PROPENSITY TO HAVE
LOW TAKE UP RATES. AT THESE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE HOPING TO
DO AGAIN- DEEPER JUST IN THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS AND WE ARE
ALS HOPEFUL THAT. WE'VE BEEN
LEARNING A LOT FROM THIS PROCESS
AND WE THINK THAT IT WILL INFORM
A LOT OF THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO BETTER
TARGET THEIR PRIORITIES FOR
REFORMING THE SYSTEM. AT THE
MOMENT THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I THIS IS JANINE DR
WITH FINANCE- IN RESPONSE TO THE
FIRST TWO QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
REPORT- AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
ASSESS THE REPORT AND WE WILL
CONSIDER THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ALONG SIDE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
HOURS ARE. BUDGET DISCUSSIONS
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
CONTAINED WITHIN IT WE'RE
CONSISTENT WITH THE INVESTMENT
THAT WE MADE AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET OCT-
WHICH AS THE DEPARTMENT AS
MENTIONED BEFORE. DID INCLUDE
THAT STATEWIDE TRAINING ON
RACIAL EQUITY IN IMPLICIT BIAS
FOR CALVERT COUNTY CASE WORKERS.
AS WELL AS AN INCREASED NUMBER
OF HOURS BUDGETED FOR INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT- BENEFITS CAL
USER TESTING. AND A COWARD
STATEWIDE PROMOTIONAL CAMPAIGN
AS WELL SO MOVING FORWARD IT'LL
BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONSIDER.
AND ASSESS THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS AUTOMATION NEEDS
ADMINISTRATION COSTS AND ANY
POSSIBLE IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINES THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AS WE
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS- AND
I'M MOVING ON TO THE OTHER
QUESTION RELATED TO THE WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE- THE W. P. R.
IS AN INHERENT FEATURE OF THE
FEDERAL TANF PROGRAM I'M SO
CALIFORNIA MUST MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO AVOID
PENALTY REDUCTIONS TO THE THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR TANNA
FOR BLOCK GRANTS AND BECAUSE
BOTH THE STATE AND THE COUNTIES
SHARE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OPERATING NOT PROGRAM. IT IS
OPERATIONALLY NECESSARY THAT
BOTH THE STATE AND COUNTY SHARE
THAT LIABILITY- AND WE DO WANT
TO NOTE THAT ONE OF THE PRIMARY
PURPOSES OF CAL OR IS TO COLLECT
BETTER HIGHER QUALITY DATA
SERVER THAT- THAT DATA CAN
INFORM OUTCOME MEASURES- DESPITE
THE- W. P. R. THANK YOU WITH
THAT I WILL BRING IT BACK UP. TO
THE DYESS. FIRST GOING TO START-
MISS SUCH FULL YEAR ROUND YOU
HAD REFERENCED THE RAND STUDY
REGARDING- THE INHERENT CONFLICT
THAT OCCURS BETWEEN W. P. R. AND
BENEFITS AND WOULD LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP MY OFFICE HAS. A
NUMBER OF DATA WONKS WHO LOVE TO
DIG IN AND SO JUST WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL
IF I COULD BUT I'M GONNA BE IN
WITH YOU MISS JOHNSON DIRECTOR
JOHNSON IF I CAN- I'D LIKE TO
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO PAGE
THIRTEEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET AND- POLICY. CENTERS
REPORT THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
AGENDA AND THE MIDDLE PARAGRAPH
THAT STATES. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EVALUATES THE STATE
PROGRAMS ON HOW WILL THEY SERVE
FAMILIES IN CRISIS RATHER THAN-
BUT ON RATHER THAN LOOKING AT
HOW WE ARE SERVING FAMILIES IN
CRISIS INSTEAD WE'RE LOOKING AT
W. P. R. I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
LATITUDE WE DO HAVE AS A STATE.
TO COUNTERACT THIS AND ENABLE
FAMILIES TO THRIVE IN OUR TENNIS
PROGRAMS IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE
HAVE JUST HEARD FROM FINANCE.
HOW COULD THE REMOVAL OF THIS
COUNTY SHARE OF THE PENALTY HELP
US TO ACHIEVE THE AGENCIES
ARTICULATED GOALS AROUND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND WHOLE
PERSON CARE HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT AS WELL AS
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A WAIVER
PROCESS OR OTHER MEANS FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THE SAME
GOALS. THE CHURCH CARE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS- FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD SAY THAT- I WON
IT GONNA RESTATE IN IT IT'S A
COMMITMENT WE MADE TOGETHER. AT
THAT W. P. R. DOES NOT IN AND OF
ITSELF ADEQUATELY DEMONSTRATE
THE SUCCESS OF THOSE THAT
PARTICIPATE IN CARRACKS AND
THOSE THAT SUPPORT THEM TO THE
PER THAT SUCCESS. BOB AND AGAIN
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE WITH THE
ACT CALOR AND MOVING FORWARD TO
A MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE LOOK
AT HOW FAMILIES ARE DOING AND
THAT IS A COMMITMENT IN WHAT WE
ARE DOING AND IMPLEMENTING
TOGETHER- IN TERMS OF-
OPPORTUNITIES TO- INFLUENCE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN AND WHERE
THE STATE CAN AT- INTER
INTERACT. I YOU HEARD ABBAS
MAYES A SPEAK TO WHAT WE HAD WAS
A TEMPORARY OPTION AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RELATED TO COVET
WHICH WAS TO AVOID THE PENALTY
BY BEING ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT IN FACT THE- CIRCUMSTANCES
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
REALLY CREATED ENVIRONMENT CHEN
WHICH- AT THAT WAS UNLIKELY TO
ACHIEVE. WE'VE ALSO LOOKED AT
THAT KIND OF HOLISTICALLY YEAR
TO YEAR. REALLY ASKING THE
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL
MEASURES WHAT ARE THE- VARIABLES
IMPACTING THAT IN I THINK TO MR
HERALD COMMENTS AT THE FRAMEWORK
THAT WE'VE PUT PUT OUT TOGETHER
IN CAL OR- AT IS AT IT AGAIN
WORK AS PART OF. A LARGER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- SET OF OUTCOMES
THAT WE. ARE EXPECTING BE A
CHEAP WITH THE COMPONENTS THE
STRING THAT WE ARE THAT WE
WORKING ON. SO I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT- SO THAT SO WE DO
HAVE THIS TEMPORARY OPTION WHICH
WE HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE EVAN
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK TO ADD
GOING FORWARD. AT TWO TWO ALSO
TESTER HELPS CLARA COMMENTS ON
HOW WE'RE COUNTING THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE HISTORICALLY
LOOKED AT TO THAT SUBPOPULATIONS
WITHIN THE LARGER CASELOAD. I
WHICH ARE ARE COUNTED IN THE
FEDERAL DENOMINATOR IF YOU WELL
TO IT TO HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT THAT'S A PLACE THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE GOING
FORWARD. THE OTHER THING I WANT
TO JUST SAY IS THAT- THE TEN OF
PROGRAM LARGELY ALSO HAS NOT
BEEN RE AUTHORIZED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND SOMETIMES I
THINK THAT'S ANOTHER.
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TOGETHER YOU
HEARD MISS MAKES A SPEAK TO THE
WAYS WITH THAT THE FEDERAL
ASSOCIATION OF STATES HAVE BEEN.
ENGAGED IN SETTING PRIORITIES
BUT IN FACT. WE HAVE IN THAT
SHARED THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
DIFFERENT WAY IN WHICH WE LOOK
AT THE OUTCOMES AND EXPECTATIONS
OF OUR TENNIS PROGRAM. AND
ENCOURAGE THE FEDS TO LOOK MORE
BROADLY SO I DO THINK THAT'S THE
CONTINUED OPPORTUNITY WE SHOULD
ALL LOOK TOWARDS. THAT'S
INFLUENCE- IN TERMS OF THE. WPR
ISSUE AS WELL. I MAY BRING IN
CENTRAL MCDONOUGH. HERE I WAS.
REALLY MOVED WITH YOUR COMMENT
ON HOW ITS A REAL CATCH TWENTY
TWO AND HOW THERE IS THAT
INHERENT CONFLICT. BUT I ALSO
FELT THAT YOU CLEARLY
ARTICULATED THAT THIS WILL NOT
LET COUNTIES BE LESS
ACCOUNTABLE. I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO
EXPRESS HOW. THE CAL OR GOALS
THAT WE ARE DEVELOPING WILL
ALLOW US TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
. SURE ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE
IT YEAH KEVIN SETTLING CWPA THE-
THE IDEA BEHIND CAL OR WAS
REALLY BUILT ON. THAT STRUCTURE
THAT WE'VE YEARS TO REALLY GREAT
A FACT IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
ONE OF THE FIRST BILLS I WORKED
OUT BACK WHEN I CAME TO WORK AT
D. W. D. A. N. TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE. TO DEVELOP
THIS THE IDEA OF A CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT STRUCTURE AT
THAT TIME ON A CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THAT INCLUDED A NUMBER OF
STEPS THAT WE THAT MODELED CAL
OR AFTER. THIS INCLUDES- EVERY
WILL INITIALLY ONCE EVERY THREE
YEARS NOW IT'S EVERY FIVE YEARS
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO DO THE SAME
AND- IN CAL OR- OF A REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK. INTERNALLY
AND EXTERNALLY WITH STAKEHOLDERS
BOTH WITHIN AND OUTSIDE OF THE
ORGANIZATION IN THE COMMUNITY
LIKE  MENTIONED CBO'S- USERS OF
THE SYSTEM OUR CUSTOMERS AND
FAMILIES THAT WE WORK WITH BOTH
CURRENT AND FORMER RECIPIENTS.
AS WELL AS OUR WORKFORCE AND
OTHERS WERE STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
PROGRAM. TO SEE HOW WE DOING
WHAT DO WE DO WELL WATER AREAS
WHERE WE NEED TO IMPROVE AND
THAT DRIVES TO A REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT. AND
COUPLED WITH THE MEASURE IF THE
DATA THAT ARE BEING COLLECTED
THAT MR HERALD TALK A LOT MORE I
THINK ABOUT THAT I HAD TIME TO-
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT- THE USE OF VARIOUS
PROPHECIES THAT WE THINK ARE
VERY PROMISING. OF THE SORT OF
WAYS IN WHICH WERE SERVING AND
ENGAGING WITH FAMILIES AS WELL
AS SURVEY DATA YOU MUST CRAPPIE
AND HER TEAM- AT PARENT VOICES
AND THAT PARENTS AND FAMILIES
THAT THEY WORK WITH REALLY
HELPED TO SPEARHEAD. AND
COUNTIES PILOT DID A SURVEY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE CUSTOMERS OF THE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE THEIR
FEEDBACK AS WELL ALL OF THAT IS
TO FEED INTO HERO. OF. PUBLIC TO
DOCUMENT THROUGH THE WALLS AN
IMPROVEMENT PLAN. TO AND NAY
COUNTY TO SET GOALS. IN HERE.
AND WORK OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. THOSE GOALS. AND I SHE
THEIR PROGRESS. AND HOW THEY'RE
DOING IN YOU KNOW REGULAR KIND
OF REPORTS AND FOLLOWING IT UP.
ON THAT THE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE
SEEN WORK NOW FOR TWO DECADES OF
CHILD WELFARE WE'RE STILL AT THE
FRONT END OF THAT AND CAL WORK.
BUT ALL OF THAT IS TO CREATE
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY THAT YOU
REALLY IF YOU JUST HAVE ONE
MEASURE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
AND ONE. PENALTY AREA- REALLY I
THINK AND OUR SYSTEM ACROSS ALL
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WOULD NOT A LOT AWAY FROM THE
IDEA THAT PENALIZING. THAT
SYSTEM IS THE WAY TO INCENTIVIZE
. BETTER EFFORT AND BETTER
OUTCOMES AND BETTER PROFIT FEES
REALLY I THINK SHINING LIGHT.
AND HAPPY PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT
SYSTEM AND HAVE AVAILABLE
MEASURES- AND PLANS THAT CAN BE
THE PEOPLE CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO FROM THAT YOU
KNOW KIND OF THE DIRECTOR. TO
HELP WITH YOU KNOW STAFF WHO ARE
IMPLEMENTING ANTI HOW WE'RE
DOING AND WORKING WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS IS THE WAY TO REALLY
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY WITHOUT
HAVING TO HOLD THE THREAT OF A
PENALTY OF SOME KIND OVER. THE
COUNTIES HAD IN THIS CASE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I AM TO- MOVE ON TO
MISS GROUPIE. COMMENTS I WANT TO
UP LIFT WHAT YOU SAID HOW THIS
IS AN AUTHENTIC INVOLVEMENT OF
PARENT VOICES THAT SPEAKS LOUDLY
TO MANY OF US. WHO CARE ABOUT
THE INVOLVEMENT HERE IN THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE. THAT TESTIMONY AS A
VALIDATES MUCH OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING HERE WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
UPLIFT YOUR COMMENTS ON THIRTEEN
IAN THIRTEEN DO YOU FOR THE
FAMILY NAVIGATOR PEER SUPPORT
MODEL AS WELL AS- TO REINSTATE
THE FAMILY SERVICE TEAM AND
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THOUGHTS ON THOSE TWO
PROPOSALS. AS WE HEARD THEY ARE
PRIORITIES FOR OUR FAMILIES.
SURE CHAIR IN AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE QUESTION I WILL
TELL YOU HAVE HAD THE GREAT
PRIVILEGE AT AS AS MISS CRAPPIE
MENTIONED THERE'S BEEN A VARIETY
OF WAYS IN WHICH WE'VE BEEN
GAUGED OUT WITH CURRENT AND
FORMER CAL EXPERTISE DEPEND SEN.
I WILL NEVER FORGET- APPARENT
DESCRIBING- THEIR VARIOUS- BOTH
EXPERIENCE WITH DIFFERENT
WORKERS THAT THEY HAD TO
NAVIGATE AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHO TO TELL WHAT
INFORMATION TO CONTINUE IN
SUPPORT BUT ALSO. ADD NOT
KNOWING THE FULL ARRAY OF WHAT
OUR PROGRAM A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
ARRAY THAT WE BUILT OVER TIME
TOGETHER AND- SO I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- I THINK- WE ARE BOTH
COMMITTED AND I THINK TO THAT
THE POINTS MISSING ONLY DONALD
MADE TO ARUND THE- STAFF AT
WIND WE ARE. COMPLETELY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT. THAT
COUNTY STAFF HAVE THE HAVE THE
TOOLS AND SUPPORTS THAT THEY
NEED WE'VE GONE AND DONE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT COUNTY SITE VISITS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. HOW THE
COMPONENTS OF SHARING
INFORMATION ORIENTATIONS WE SAT
THROUGH IT IN A HOW HOW IS THAT
YOU KNOW YOU KIND OF NEED TO
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S AVAILABLE IN
THE MOMENT YOU NEED IT. YOU CAN
ALWAYS- FULLY COMPREHENDS
EVERYTHING BEING OFFERED TO YOU
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND AN
ORIENTATION IT'S GOING GOING
AROUND SO. THE IDEA THAT WE
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN THE
ABILITY IN THE PROGRAM FOR
FAMILIES TO NAVIGATE AND ACCESS
THE RESOURCE AND SUPPORT THEY
NEEDED AT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE-
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO- IN JUST
MORE BROADLY IN TERMS OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WHERE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO LOOK TAKING A LOOK
AND SEE WHAT'S- POSSIBLE FOR
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE FUTURE. I
THINK WE HEARD CLEARLY FROM MY
CARROLLTON ABOUT HOUSE SO OFTEN
FAMILIES. PARENTS ARE ENTERING
IN IN SITUATIONS LIKE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. WHERE THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO IMMEDIATELY BE ABLE TO. HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
RETURNING BACK TO WORK BUT
INSTEAD NEED MANY OF THOSE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. I'M SURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING AND GIVING
THEM THE BEST CHANCE OF SUCCESS.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON
WHAT MY CHARACTER WAS SAYING
ABOUT OTHER SUPPORT OF SERVICES
SUCH AS- TRANSPORTATION AND
INTERNET- WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
WHETHER YOU'D- THINK THOSE WORK
IN CONCERT TORE. IF ARE STAND.
BY THEM SO- AS I BELIEVE THERE'S
A GREAT CHANCE FOR US TO IMPROVE
THE PROGRAM AND MEET PEOPLE'S
BASIC NEEDS. ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE- AGAIN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND HERE ONE
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE
AGAIN TOGETHER- THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE MADE
SOME INVESTMENTS IN BROADBAD SO
GLAD TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
MAXIMIZING THOSE ACROSS AND KIND
OF FULLY GETTING ACCESS TO SEE A
FEW DIFFERENT EXAMPLES HERE. AT
TODAY THAT WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT PICKED THE
PARTICIPANTS AND HOW WORKS ARE
GETTING ACCESS TO OTHER
COMPONENTS WHETHER IT'S THE
ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO GO TO PARKS
IN THE IN THE GOLDEN. BEAR
PASTORE OTHER ECONOMIC SPORTS
EXETER QUITE QUITE A RANGE THAT
WE'RE GLAD T SEE WHAT ELSE WE
CAN BE DOING ON THAT FRONT WE
DID AB. EMPLOYMENT AT DURING THE
PANDEMIC A LAPTOP THAT PROGRAM
WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE
LAPTOPS TO THOSE- IN THE PROGRAM
WAS ALSO IMPLEMENTED A NEW
INITIATIVE WE REFERENCED AT IT'S
CALLED SELL AD WHERE WE HAVE
INCREASED THE ABILITY FOR OUR
PARTICIPANTS TO ENGAGE. THROUGH
THE PHONE- INDIFFERENCE
EDUCATIONAL AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
AND WE'VE SEEN GREAT SUCCESS
WITH THAT IN AGAIN COUNTS AT IT
TOWARDS SOME OF THE MEASUREMENTS
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY REQUIRED
TO LOOK AT SO AS IT RELATES TO
TRANSPORTATION AGAIN. WE HAVE AT
TO THE POINT THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
MADE SOME PROGRESS AND VERY
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND HOW WE
CAN MORE EASILY STREAMLINE
ACCESS TO GET TO GETTING TO
THOSE SERVICES SO GLAD IN THE
SPACE TO CONTINUE EXPLORING THIS
AREA AS WELL. A FINAL QUESTION
IF I COULD- MISS GROUPIES FINAL
RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT- THIS IS
NOT ONLY ABOUT WORKFORCE THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT THE FAMILIES WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR. WHETHER THERE'S A
BENEFIT TO US RENAMING THE
PROGRAM RE PRIORITIZING WHAT
MATTERS FOR US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND PLACING FAMILIES
FIRST. AGAIN OPEN TO. FINANCE
THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE AND WE
HAD WEEK FREQUENTLY ALSO LIFT UP
THE K. AND CAL WORKS FOR KIDS
WHICH WE KNOW IS CRITICAL- INTO
IN IN A PLACE THAT WE TOGETHER
AGAIN HAVE INVESTED. MORE
GREATLY AND OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS SO GLAD TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE WHAT'S
POSSIBLE AND REALLY ENSURING
THAT. AT THE AT THE OFFICE
OFFERING IN THE OPTION
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
PROGRAM IS REPRESENTED IN TERMS
OFWHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. IN
THE STRENGTH BASED APPROACH THAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS. BEFORE WE
GO ON TO THE NEXT ITEM I WANT TO
THANK THIS PANEL FOR THE IN
DEPTH DISCUSSION AND
CONVERSATION. TO PREPARE US IN
THE NEXT STEPS TO REALIZE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE POLICY
ALIGNMENT REPORT. I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK THE L. A. O. TO ASCERTAIN
WHICH OF THE PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATIONS. FROM THE POLICY
ALIGNMENT REPORT COULD BE READY
FOR ADOPTION IN THIS. BUDGET
CYCLE. AND THAT THE L. A. O.
WORK WITH CDSS TO UNDERSTAND THE
GENERAL FUND AMOUNT. WHICH WOULD
BE REQUIRED FOR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND ON GOING TO
ACCOMPLISH IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. IF WORK
FOR A. PARDON WE WILL BE MOVING
ON TO ISSUE TO WHERE WE WILL
DISCUSS THE AUTOMATION PROJECTS
AND DATA OUTCOMES REPORTING
FIRST HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS WE
HAVE TWELVE PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL FOR ISSUE TO. BEGINNING
WITH BRANDON HAMDARD DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CALA HHS FOLLOWED
BY JOHN BELIEVE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CAL SAUCE. JOHN
HENYON WHO IS THE CHIEF DATA
OFFICER FOR THE CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION RYAN
GILLETTE THE RESEARCH AUTOMATION
AND DATA DIVISION CHIEF DATA
OFFICER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
CYNTHIA TUCKER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF CHILD WELFARE DIGITAL.
SERVICES OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION A KELLY CHANGE US.
JENNIFER ROOD JONES CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS BRANCH CHIEF
WITH CDSS JENNIFER TRACY CAL
SAWS ADVOCATES CO LEAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS RUBEN CANNELLA WITH THE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC EQUITY
INITIATIVES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. BASIC NEEDS
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND YOU SEE
BASIC NEEDS COCHAIR. KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD WITH CW DA
BRIAN METZGER WITH THE L. A. O.
TYLER WOODS AND ROB TROJAN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET US
BEGIN WITH DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HANSARD. WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND HAND COMMITTEE
VIRTUAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS- GIVEN
THE SIZE THE PANEL AND WE'RE
JUST LOOKING AT LOGISTICS I
THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS KIND OF
ROTATE THE B. B. AVAILABLE- BUT
FIRST AND FOREMOST GOOD TO BE
BACK IN PERSON SPEAKING WITH
YOU- AFTER THE PAST TWO YEARS-
WITH THE WAY THE AGENDAS LAID
OUT- JOHN BELAY AND MYSELF HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME QUESTIONS BOTH
REPRESENTING CAL SIZE WE WILL
JOINTLY. USE OUR TIME TOGETHER
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS- FIRST
FOREMOST AND BRANDON HANSARD
DEPUTY DIRECTOR- THE BENEFIT
ENROLLMENT TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
DIVISION AT OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. HI JOHN BELAY-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAL SIDES
WILL ANSWER THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE POSED TO BOTH OF US BUT-
WANTED TO THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
THE DETAILED PROJECT OVERVIEW
AND STATUS IN THE AGENDA. DUE TO
THE TIME CONSTRAINTS I'M GOING
TO SUMMARIZE- SOME OF THAT THAT
WILL ALSO ANSWER- BULLET ONE
BULLET FOR OF THE QUESTIONS. SO
I'M VERY HAPPY TO REPORT TO YOU
TODAY THE CALIFORNIA NOW HAS TWO
SAWS SYSTEMS AFTER MANY MANY
YEARS OF PLANNING HARD WORK AND
IS ON TRACK TO MIGRATE TO THE
SINGLE SIZE- IN PRIOR YEARS WE
HAVE REPORTED ON THE
CONSOLIDATION AND MIGRATION
STRATEGY. MY NAME INPUT.
ACTIVITIES CALIFORNIA EMBARKED
ON. TO MEET. THE FEDERAL MANDATE
OF ONE SIZE SYSTEM BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THIS INCLUDED THE
FORMATION OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY COUNCIL'S JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IN TWENTY NINETEEN. A
MONUMENTAL MY MILESTONE OCCURRED
ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHEN THE
THIRTY NINE C. FOR COUNTIES
JOINED LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
THE FORMER LRS SYSTEM IN
CREATING THE FORTY COUNTY
CALCITE SYSTEM. THIS SUCCESS
HIGHLIGHTS THAT THE SIZE SINGLE
SYSTEM STRATEGY IS WORKING WHICH
INCLUDES LEVERAGING CLOUD
HOSTING RE USE OF THE SCALABLE
EXISTING SYSTEM. AND SYSTEM
INTEGRATION BY THE CONSORTIUM
ALL ENSURING THE FUNCTIONALITY
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE CLIENTS
AND BENEFICIARIES FOREMOST
COUNTIES AND THE STATE- THE
APPROACH HAS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO LEVERAGE AND WE USE OUR
TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS IMPLEMENT
SHARED SERVICES AND CONTINUALLY
MODERNIZE THE CAL STAR SYSTEM
EVEN INTO MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS. SO IF A THIRTY NINE
COUNTY MIGRATION TO THE NEW
SYSTEM WASN'T ENOUGH IN TANDEM
WITH THAT WITH THE C. FOR
MIGRATION CAL SAWS ALSO
IMPLEMENTED IMPLEMENTED THE
ENTIRELY NEW PUBLIC FACING
PORTAL CALLED BENEFITS CAO. SO
COUNCILS MULTI VENDOR STRATEGY
SUCCESSFULLY SUPPORTED THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PORTAL
MOBILE APPLICATION WHILE
INTEGRATING THE EFFORT INTOTHE
OVERALL CAL SADDAM MANAGEMENT
AND RELEASED PLAN. THIS INCLUDED
IN THE INTEGRATED PLAN- NEW
IMAGING AND CENTRAL PRINT
SERVICES WERE PROCURED AND BEGAN
FOR THE SAME CAL SIZE COUNTIES.
SO WHILE WE CELEBRATE YOU KNOW
THESE MAJOR MILESTONES AND
SUCCESSES TO DATE THIS PROJECT
IS FAR FROM OVER- IN THE
UPCOMING WEEKS WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO LA COUNTY'S MIGRATION
TO BENEFITS CAL. AND THE IMAGING
SERVICES ALLOWING FOR THE
RETIREMENT OF YOUR BENEFITS NOW
PORTAL. AND THE DEVELOPMENT IN
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE EFFORTS
ARE REALLY NOW FOCUSING ON THE
MIGRATION OF THE EIGHTEEN CALLIN
COUNTIES BEGINNING LATE THIS
BEGINNING LATE THIS YEAR AND A
WAVE ROLLOUT. APPROACH
COMPLETING BEFORE THE FEDERAL
MANDATE AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- THE STRATEGY STAGE
THINGS CAUSAR COW WHEN COUNTY
SLAS DUE TO THE ADDITIONAL
COMPLEXITIES AND COUNTY IMPACTS
FROM MIGRATING FROM CAL INTO
CHAOS. SO AS YOU CAN SEE HERE
AND SEE- FROM THE AGENT AT THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT IS
ENORMOUS- BUT WE DO FILLED VERY
BEING VERY WELL MANAGED AND
REQUIREMENTS ARE BEING MET
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL MANDATE
WITHIN BUDGET AND SCHEDULE-
THERE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN WITH
PROJECTS OF THIS SIZE.
ADJUSTMENTS TO BOTH BUDGET AND
SCHEDULE- AS WE AS YOU LEARN AND
GET THE ACTUALS OF THE LEVEL OF
EFFORT AND THE COSTS THAT ARE
REALIZED BUT AGAIN WE MANAGE
PROACTIVELY AND WOOD COUNTY FOR
EACH EAC YEAR'S BUDGET. WHEN I
TURNED UP AT JOHN FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL ANSWERS TO SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THANK YOU BRANDON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M GLAD
TO BE HERE TODAY MANY OF
DETAILED QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA
SO I'M JUST GOING TO JUMP RIGHT
INTO THOSE AND SORT OF WRK
THROUGH IT. SO ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS AS WE ROLLOUT
CAL SAWS IS THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF NEW POLICY AND NEW
INITIATIVES I KNOW THE COMMITTEE
WANTED TO KNOW WHAT THE NATURE
OF THE UP RELEASES FOR BOTH CAL
SALAS AND BENEFITS CAL AND HOW
DO THEY IMPACT PROGRAM ACCESS
CUSTOMER FRIENDLY DESIGN
LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND PROGRAM
RETENTION. THERE'S A LOT OF NAY.
GIMPLE IN THE LAST BUDGET
SESSION. AND WE'VE MADE
COMMITMENTS TO BE ABLE TO GET
THOSE THINGS ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET. FOR MAY WE'RE GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTING THE MEDIC HOW OLDER
ADULT EXPANSION- AND WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO BE DOING THE EXPANSION
OF THE CAL WORKS TIME CLOCKS
FROM FORTY EIGHT MONTHS TO SIXTY
MONTHS. AT THE SAME TIME WILL BE
INCREASING THE CAL WORKS
PRESIDENT PREGNANCY SPECIAL.
NEEDS THAT IS THE ONLY FOR THE
CALIFORNICUM LEGACY SYSTEM THAT
CURRENTLY SUPPORTS EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES. AS OF JUNE FIRST WILL
BE INCREASING THE COW WORKS
RECIPIENTS EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD TWO SIX TWO SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS AS OUTLINED BY
THE LEGISLATURE. AND FOR JULY
FIRST WILL BE IMPLEMENTED THE
INCREASE TO THE CAL CAL WORKS
APPLICATION EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD. WILL BE INCREASED
WOOD THE INCREASE TO THE MEDIC
CAL ASSET LIMITS AN IMPORTANT
CHANGE FOR ACCESS. AND THE
CHANGE ELIGIBILITY RULES FOR
PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS AND CAL
WORKS WILL ALSO BE IMPLEMENTED.
ALL OF THESE CHANGES ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED ON TIME WITHIN THEIR
LEGISLATIVE TARGET DATES AND
THEY WILL EXPAND THE ACCESS AND
SERVICES FOR THESE IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES. FOR BENEFITS CAL
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
SEVERAL VERY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES TO INCREASE SUPPORT
FOR CALFRESH APPLICANTS AND THE
SISTERS. THAT CDSS IS SUPPORTING
WITH FEDERAL HARPER FINDING AND
SECURING THAT FUNDING- FOR
AUTOMATION AND FOR CALSONIC.
THIS INCLUDES THE CREATION OF A
VERSION OF BENEFITS CAL
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR CAUGHT
THE COLLEGE STUDENT POPULATION.
I'M HERE TO HELP ADDRESS
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND CONCERNS
RELATED TO FEDERAL STUDENT RULES
AND OTHER COMMON SITUATIONS FOR
OUR STUDENTS. WE'RE ALSO WORKING
TO ADD FUNCTIONALITY TO SUPPORT
APPLICATION THE SISTERS AND
THEIR IMPORTANT ROLE AS THEY DO
OUTREACH AND RETENTION WORK WITH
THE PUBLIC- WITH THE ABILITY FOR
CUSTOMERS TO AUTHORIZE SHARING.
CERTAIN TYPES OF INFORMATION
WITH THOSE WITH THOSE A SISTERS
KNOWN AS A RELEASE OF
INFORMATION. AND FOR CBO'S
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
GENERATE TRACKABLE CODES WITHIN
BENEFITS CAL TO USED IN THEIR
OUT REACH ALLOWING FOR TRACKING
AND ANALYSIS OF OUTCOMES FOR
VARIOUS OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS AND
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS. WE'RE
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO MAKE AS
MANY OF THESE CHANGES AS
POSSIBLE BY THE SEPTEMBER THE
END OF THE FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
TO MEET THE TIME LINES- BEFORE
THE USE OF THESE FUNDS. WITH
REGARD TO LANGUAGE ACCESS AS WE
LAUNCHED BENEFITS CAL WE
LAUNCHED THE INITIAL- VERSION OF
BENEFITS CALLIN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SUPPORTING
TWELVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES ON
THE WEBSITE- THIS MONTH WILL ADD
ANOTHER FIVE LANGUAGES TO THAT
AND BY THE END OF MAY WE WILL
ADD ANOTHER THREE SO HAVING
TWENTY LANGUAGES TOTAL-
SUPPORTED AS WE GO FORWARD. THE
COMMITTEES NEXT QUESTION WAS
REVIEW THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
BENEFITS CAL DESCRIBE ANY ISSUES
THAT WE CAME ACROSS ANY
CHALLENGES AND WHAT THE PLANS
ARE TO ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS.
AND HOW DOES LOOKING THEN
PIVOTING TO- DATA ON CASES SINCE
THE IMPLEMENTATION COMPARE WITH
DATA FROM A PRIOR PERIOD SO DO A
LITTLE BIT OF A COMPARISON FROM
A PRIOR PERIOD. BEFORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BENEFITS CALON
CAL SAUCE FOR THE THIRTY NINE C.
FOR COUNTIES AND COMPARE THAT
SETS. I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT THE
COLLABORATION ON BENEFITS CAL
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY
ARE ADVOCATES ARE COUNTIES. OUR
STATE PARTNERS HAS BEEN A
SUCCESS IT'S AN INCREMENTAL
SUCCESS OUR JOB IS IT DONE. BUT
WITHIN THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF BENEFITS
CAL WE HAD OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
REGISTER FOR ACCOUNTS OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED. EIGHT HUNDRED COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION REGISTERING
FOR ACCOUNTS AND CLOSE TO A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS IN THE FIRST FOUR
MONTHS. OF SUBMITTED FOR
CALFRESH CAL WORKS AT MANTA CAL
. IN THE SAME PURCHASE TIME
PERIOD WE'VE HAD OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
VERIFICATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN UP
LOADED INTO BENEFITS CAL. AND
THEY'VE BEEN AND THEY'VE BEEN
SUBMITTED AND ASSISTED IN THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WORKED ON WITH-
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR PRIVATE
PARTNERS IS A MOBILE FIRST
DESIGN. KNOWING THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE USING MORE AND MORE
MOBILE TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE BENEFITS TRACK THEIR
BENEFITS AND GET INFORMATION ON
THE PROGRAMS. WE'RE HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT 71% OF PEOPLE ARE
USING MOBILE DEVICES SUCH AS
SMARTPHONES IN ORDER ACCESS
BENEFITS CAL AND THAT'S JUST FOR
THE THIRTY NINE COUNTIES. ONE OF
THE MOST POPULAR FEATURES OF
BENEFITS CAL THE ABILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO CHECK THEIR EBT
BALANCES. AT ABOUT SIXTY FOUR
HUNDRED PEOPLE PER DAY ARE
ACCESSING BENEFITS CAL TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT THEIR EBT
BALANCES AND TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE THEIR FINANCES. WELL
BENEFITS CAL HAS BEEN SIX
RUSSELL WE HAVE RUN INTO SOME
TECHNOLOGY STABILITY AND
PERFORMANCE PROBLEMS AND ISSUES.
WITH THE KELSALL IMAGING
SOLUTIONS THE NEW- CLOUDBASE
IMAGING SOLUTION THAT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CANCER SPOKE OF- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH%
OUR TECHNOLOGY PARTNER HIGHLAND
TECHNOLOGIES TO RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES. BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE HAD WITH
THE IMAGING SOLUTION AND IT'S
VERY VERY TIGHTLY COUPLED. WITH
BENEFITS CAL THEY HAVE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED HAND IN HAND- THAT
WE DID DELAY L. A. COUNTY. AND
OPTED TO DO MORE PERFORMANCE
TESTING STABILITY TESTING AND
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS WE BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE WEEKS AWAY FROM
IMPLEMENTING BOLD BENEFITS CAL
AND THE NEW IMAGING SOLUTION. IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN THAT STABILITY THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN THAT PERFORMANCE AS WE
SPEAK THERE IS TESTING GOING ON
RIGHT NOW. AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A FACT BASED APPROACH AND
LET THE TESTING AND PERFORMANCE
REALLY DRIVE THAT DATE BECAUSE-
THE CUSTOMERS DESERVE THAT AND
ARE COUNTIES DESERVE THAT. SORT
OF SWITCHING GEARS WITH REGARD
TO THE DATA QUESTION ASKED BY
THE COMMITTEE WE COMPARE THE
DATA FOR THIRTY NINE FORMER C.
FOR COUNTIES. FOR OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THROUGH FEBRUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WITH
OCTOBER IT WILL F. OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THROUGH
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOUR IMPORTANT THINGS SUCH AS-
ADMINISTRATIVE OR PROCEDURAL THE
NILES WHICH ARE THE DENIALS FOR
REASONS LIKE NOT PROVIDING A
VERIFICATION OR NOT COMPLETING
AN INTERVIEW- IF REQUIRED. AND
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO ELIGIBILITY
FACTORS LIKE BEING OVER INCOME.
WE FOUND BETWEEN THE TWO YEARS
FOR THOSE THIRTY NINE COUNTY IS-
THAT THE DATE DATE WAS ACTUALLY
FAIRLY CONSISTENT- FOR THOSE
YEARS- THE CAL WORKS RATE
INCREASED SLIGHTLY FROM 28230%
THE CALIBRATED EIGHT CONSISTENT
AT 27% FOR BOTH YEARS IN THE
MEDICAL RATE DID DECREASE FROM.
1% 22% WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO
REALLY UNPACK OR INVESTIGATE THE
REASONS FOR THE LOWER MEDIC CAL
RATES COMPARED TO THE OTHER
PROGRAMS BUT SUSPECT IT'S LIKELY
DUE TO THE DIFFERING PROGRAM
RULES INCLUDE INCLUDING- GREATER
USE OF ELECTRONIC VERIFICATION
SOURCE VERIFICATION THROUGH OUR
FEDERAL VERIFICATION- FOR TIMELY
DETERMINATIONS OF CAL WORKS. FOR
DETERMINATIONS THE CAL WORKS
RATE WENT FROM 98% ON THIS TIME
PERIOD. TO NINETY TWO PERCENT.
THE CALFRESH RATE WENT FROM
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT. 79% AND A
MEDIC CAL RATE WENT FROM 74% TO
SEVENTY SIX PERCENT. AGAIN WE
HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO UNPACK THE
REASON FOR THE- LARGER DECREASE
IN THE CALCIFIED IN THE
CALIBRATION NUMBER. BUT SUSPECT
IT'S LIKELY DUE TO A COMBINATION
OF INCREASES IN APPLICATIONS
YEAR OVER YEAR APPLICATIONS
INCREASED BY MORE THAN 15%
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND SOME
ISSUES THAT C. W. D. A. HAS
BROUGHT UP IN THE PAST THAT THE
METHODOLOGY FOR FUNDING CALFRESH
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS IS A TWENTY
YEAR OLD PROCESS THAT HAS NOT
BEEN- LOOKED AT AND OVER TWENTY
YEARS AND THERE'S- UNDER FUNDING
THAT'S TAKING PLACE ON THAT. WE
ALSO THINK THAT THE IMPACT OF
THE OMICRON SURGE ON OUR COUNTY
WORKFORCE HAD AN IMPACT. AND
THAT WHEN WE REALLY LOOK AT THAT
YEAH ON- JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO MAY HAVE BEEN A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO LOWERED
LOWER NUMBERS AS WELL. NOW FOR
MEDIC CAL. COUNTIES HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN REGARDS TO
APPLICATION PROCESSING TIME LINE
SO THEY CAN WORK WITH CUSTOMERS
WHO NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME-
TO BE ABLE TO GET THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION IT REALLY IS A
DIFFERENTIATED IN THE DATA. BUT
IT LIKELY CONTRIBUTES TO
GENERALLY THE LOWER RATE MEDIC
CAL VERSES THE CALFRESH AND CAL
WORKS PROGRAM. WE FOUND LITTLE
CHANGE IN THE RATE OF
APPLICATION DENIALS. THAT WERE
RESCINDED- WITH CAL WORK STAY IN
AT 8% CALIFORNIA'S GOING FROM 6%
25% META CAL FROM 3% 24% SO IT'S
IMPORTANT NO ONE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS AND DOING THE RESEARCH
ON THIS DATA. THAT NOT ONLY DID
THE COUNTIES MOVED FROM. C. FOR
THE OLD LEGACY SYSTEM TO CAL
SANTIAGO. BUT ALSO THEY ARE
DOING THAT AT THE SAME TIME OF
THE PANDEMIC. IT'S ECONOMIC
DISRUPTIONS AT THE SAME TIME ITS
WORK FORCE IN LOCATIONS MANY THE
COUNTIES WERE WORKING REMOTE
DURING THOSE TIMES. EDUCATIONS
AND THEN THE SUSPENSION OF SOME
OF THE MITIGATIONS OF LIKE- THE-
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AND OTHER RELIEFS DURING THAT
TIME. GOING ON TO THE OTHER
QUESTION HOW DOES THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
FOR CAL SOUTH COMPARE WITH THAT
OF SIMILAR PROJECTS. ALSO WHEN
WE LOOK AT BENEFITS CALENDAR
PUBLIC FACING TECHNOLOGY ARE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
IS- SO IMPORTANT TO US IT'S BEEN
A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
SUCCESS. AND THE COLLABORATION
THAT WE'VE HAD. HAVING WORKED
AROUND- HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TECHNOLOGY SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND
CALIFORNIA AS A CONSULTANT. AS A
MANAGER WITH AND- COUNTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND FOR FOUR YEARS
AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION I HAVE TO
SAY FOR CAL SAWS THIS IS THE
MOST ROBUST IN. STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS THAT I'VE
EVER BEEN INVOLVED IN AND IT'S
PAID DIVIDENDS. NOT ONLY DO WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF MONTHLY AND
QUARTERLY STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
TO PROVIDE STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT.
AND ACTUALLY TEST PUBLIC FACING
TECHNOLOGIES BUT WE ALSO
MAINTAIN. A VERY EXTENSIVE
WEBSITE WITH INFORMATION ON
PROJECT ACTIVITIES ARE CHANGES
OUR MEETINGS AND WE HAVE A
FUNCTION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE TWO
WAY CONVERSATIONS CALLED PASCAL
SAWS WHERE SOMEBODY COULD ASK A
FEW QUESTIONS AND WE WILL TURN
THAT AROUND. ALSO AT THE JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY- ED MADE UP OF
OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES- OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEETING AS A
PUBLIC MEETING GOVERNED BY THE
BROWN ACT- ARE PROJECT STEERING
COMMITTEE IS A PUBLIC MEETING
GOVERNED BY THE BROWN ACT AS
WELL AS- OUR- HOPEFULLY SOON TO
BE. LEGACY SYSTEM CAL WHEN.
THEIR GOVERNING BOARD IS ALSO A
PUBLIC MEETINGS WE PROVIDE TIME.
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR POSTING
AND FOR INTERACTION. THE LAST
QUESTION I THINK- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR HANSARD ANSWERED VERY
WELL AND I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
WE ARE ON TRACK THIS IS A
CHALLENGING IMPLEMENTATION.
THERE'S MANY MOVING PARTS TO
THIS- NO ONE WOULD HAVE
PREDICTED THE PANDEMIC WHAT THAT
WOULD DO TO OUR WORKFORCE WHAT
THAT WOULD DO TO OUR COMMUNITY
IS WERE ACTIVELY MONITORING THE
PROGRESS REMAIN FOR THE CHANGES
TO PREPARE FOR THE MIGRATION OF
OUR EIGHTEEN COUNTIES. REPRESENT
40% OF THE STATE'S PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE CASELOAD IN THOSE
EIGHTEEN COUNTY SO WE STILL HAVE
A WAYS TO GO. WE'RE WORKING WITH
THOSE EIGHTEEN CAL WHEN COUNTIES
WE HAVE A VENDOR SUPPORTING THEM
DOING THE CHANGE PROCESS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THE CHANGE IN
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO HAVE A
CHANGE OF BUSINESS PROCESS AND
MAPPING OUT THAT CHANGE IN
BUSINESS PROCESS. WE'RE LOOKING
AG PROVIDING THEM WITH MORE
EXTENSIVE TRAINING FOR THE- FOR
THE- ELIGIBILITY WORKERS. SINCE
THE CHANGE FROM CALNGUYEN TO
CAL SAWS IS A MUCH BIGGER CHANGE
SEE FOR AND THE FORMER L.
ARRESTS ARE NOW CAL SAUCES WERE
COUSIN SYSTEMS OF ONE ANOTHER.
THERE WAS MANY SIMILARITIES-
THERE'S GONNA BE MUCH MORE
ROBUST TRAINING. THIS WORK. THE
OUTLINED IN ADDITION TO THE
POLICY COMMITMENTS WE'VE MADE
DURING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
SESSION. OBVIOUSLY HAVE THEIR
PLACE VERY VERY FULL. AND WE
ALREADY HAVE JUST TO BE ABLE TO
GET THAT OUR OUR PLATE IS VERY
VERY FULL- AND YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL POLICY COMMITMENTS
WILL HAVE TO YOU KNOW REALLY
LOOK AT PRIOR TO YOU KNOW MID
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TIME FRAME.
BUT WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE COUNTIES IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE REALISTIC TYPE- THE
TIME FRAMES FOR IMPLEMENTATION
AS MR HERALD OUTLINED IN THE
LAST- LAST ISSUE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXTERA JOHNNO HENYON IF THEY'RE
GOING TO PRESENT. I GET
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME PRESENT MY NAME'S JOHN CHIANG
AND I'M THE FIRST CHIEF DATA
OFFICER FOR ULTIMATE SERVICES I
WAS BROUGHT ON BOARD TO STAND UP
THE CENTER FOR DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION- THERE'S FOUR
QUESTIONS I HAD TO PRIOR INTO
THE- TO POP UP TODAY AND SO ALL
DRESSED. MAYBE GIVING YOU A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF CDS THE CENTER
FOR DATA INSIDE HM. HI THE
ENACTMENT OF TRAILER BILL ONE
SEVENTY TWO SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO FOR ABOUT SIX
MONTHS OLD- CREATED CD I WHICH
WILL HAVE A MERGER OF EXISTING
OFFICES THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
INFORMATION INTEGRITY THE OFFICE
OF ASIAN ADVOCATE. PUTS THAT UP
- COMMITTEE PROTECT HUMAN
SUBJECTS WHICH IS STATE IRB. AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF INNOVATION
AND REALLY THE IDEA WAS HOW DO
WE BRING THESE OFFICE IS THAT
ACTUALLY CAN LEVERAGE EACH OTHER
TO DRIVE THE AGENCY'S MISSION-
TO FOCUS ON EQUITY. TO DRIVE THE
TAP DATA DRIVE ACTION AND TO PUT
THE PERSON BACK INTO HUMAN.
CENTERED DESIGN- WHILE CREATING
A CULTURE OF INNOVATION AND
LEARNING. HI IT'S- WHAT I CAN
HELP GO TO QUESTION NUMBER TWO
IN TERMS OF WHAT CAN ACTION WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW- WE HAVE. THERE
ISN'T A- DETAIL K. BUT WHAT
WE'VE DOING WORKING BUT THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES. AS
AS ALL OF THE- ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN CAL HHS. IS
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE AS A AS- WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
DATA PROFESSIONALS AND OUR
AGENCY. AND WE HAVE NUMEROUS
DATA PROJECTS AND A LOT OF THEM
NOWADAYS WE'RE TRYING TO
DETERMINE- HOW INDIVIDUALS
IMPACTED. HOW TO USE DATA TO
DRIVE ACTION IT REQUIRES DATA
FROM DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS TO
COME TOGETHER- BEFORE MY IME WE
HAD A VERY- ROBUST DATA
COMMUNITY THAT GOT TOGETHER AND
SHE DID A NUMBER OF PROJECTS- I
LIKE THE PROGRAM DASHBOARD WHICH
LOOKED AT INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
SERVED BY MULTIPLE PROGRAMS.
BOTH WITHIN A DEPARTMENT BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE AGENCY. AND OUR
JOB RIGHT NOW IS TO TAKE THAT
RESEARCH DATA UP AND TAKE IT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL AND MAKE IT MORE
OF AN OPERATIONAL CAPACITY. TO
BE ABLE TO DRIVE- EFFORTS LIKE
THE EQUITY TOWARD WHICH WE WERE
TASKED WITH THIS YEAR AS WELL AS
THE ALL HAZARDS DASHBOARD AND
NUMBER OF OTHER PROJECTS. WITH
RESPECT TO CDS THAT'S- ALWAYS
GONNA READ FOR HERE IT BE
EASIER- WELL SEE I UNDERTAKES
MANY OF THE INITIATIVES
DESCRIBED- WE ALSO CONSULT AND
COLLABORATE WITH APARTMENTS ON
DATA SPECIFIC INITIATIVES THAT
THEY HAVE UNDER WAY. WE DON'T
DIRECTLY OVERSEE OR MANAGE THE
DEPARTMENT'S DATA PROJECTS BUT
WE DO WORK WITH ANUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS FOR EXAMPLE WITH
DSS- THE DATA PIPELINES FOR THE
ALL HAZARDS DASHBOARD CDSS IS
CURRENTLY PROVIDING DATA ON
LICENSE FACILITIES CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES- WITH RESPECT TO AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE. ENGAGEMENT
AND DATA LINKAGE TO SUPPORT BOTH
CDSS THE H. THE SDDS AND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ARE
PROVIDING DATA AND CDI IS THE
FACILITATOR OF DATA SHARING THE-
WHAT WE'RE CREATING CALL. THE
AGENCY DATA HUB- IN ADDITION
RESPECT TO THE HOMELESS DATA.
INTEGRATION SYSTEM H. D. I. S.
C. I. IS IN EARLY DISCUSSIONS-
TOWARDS TDI FACILITATING THE
ACCESS TO THE H. D. I. S. DATA
FOR BOTH CDS PASS. AND LINK IT
WITH OTHER KELLY TOUCH S.
PROGRAMS- OUR EVALUATING SUCCESS
WILL WE ARE START UP BUT IN MANY
WAYS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
SHEPHERDING THAT HAVE BEEN-
HAPPENING OVER AT THE CALLIE
JUDGE US DATA JOURNEY WHICH WE
TRACE BACK TO TEN TO FIFTEEN
YEARS AND REALLY BUILDING ON
THAT- WE HAVE A- REPORT THAT WAS
DUE MARCH FIRST WILL HAVE IT TO
YOU BY THE END OF NEXT WEEK-
WE'VE BEEN. WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IT IT ENTAILS AND GIVE
THEM ANOTHER- I'M MORE DETAILED
APPROACH BOOK BURKE WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON- I THINK THE TOP
AREAS- FROM YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT DATA BUT I'LL HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT PEOPLE AND WHO'S IMPACTED.
OUR NUMBER NUMBER. NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES IS IMPROVING THE
SPEED OF SERVICE WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF RESEARCH REQUESTS
THAT COME TO THE- STATE. AND
UNDER OUR NEW TRAILER BILL WE
ARE NOT ONLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESEARCH REQUEST THE COM- TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR PRE PRODUCTION IN
HUMAN SUBJECTS WHICH IS OUR
HIGHER BE. UP FOR THE STATE IS
NOT ONLY CALLIE TAKE US REQUEST
FOR THAT BUT- THEY CAN COME FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE. SO WITH THIS
TRAILER BILL WE'RE LOOKING AT
HOW TO SPEED UP THE REQUEST FROM
THE TIME THAT A RESEARCH REQUEST
THAT DATA. AND PROVIDING
MECHANISMS THAT MORE AUTOMATE
DATA DATA REQUEST- AND AS WELL
AS PROVIDING OPPORTUNITY FOR
RESEARCHERS TO IDENTIFY WHAT
OTHER DATA IS BEING REQUESTED OF
AN UPPER RESEARCHER COMES IN FOR
THE FIRST TIME. IT WOULD BE
REALLY CRITICAL THAT RESEARCHER
TO KNOW WAS THAT DATE ALREADY
REQUESTED FROM OTHER RESEARCHERS
IS THERE MORE. OUT THERE AND SO
REALLY PROVIDING A FIRST CLASS
EXPERIENCE- FOR RESEARCHERS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THEIR
WORK REALLY ELEVATES THE WORK
FOR ALL DOING. I ALL OF ALL
RESERVE- ANY OTHER TIME IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM BRIAN SELECT
RESEARCH AUTOMATION AND DATA
DIVISION CHIEF DATA OFFICER.
WITH CDSS. THERE ARE MANY
STRANGE LET I AM THE CHIEF DATA
OFFICER AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OVER
THE RESEARCH AUTOMATION AND DATA
DIVISION I'M I'VE BEEN ASKED
TODAY TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE STATEWIDE VERIFICATION HUB
AND OTHER MAJOR PROJECTS THAT
RAT IS WORKING ON THAT AFFECTS
THE LARGEST. ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE. TO START
OFF WITH THE STATEWIDE
VERIFICATION IT'S A MULTI
DEPARTMENT. IT SOLUTION
CURRENTLY UNDER DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL IMPROVE FAMILIES ACCESS TO
SERVICES BY STREAMLINING THE
ELIGIBILITY VERIFICATION PROCESS
FOR MANY MEANS TESTED PROGRAMS.
IN PARTICULAR HOW FRESH HOW IT
WORKS. MEDIKAL IN CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS. UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THE VERIFICATION PROCESS
FOR PUBLICASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
ARE SUPPORTED BY MULTIPLE LEGACY
IT SYSTEMS. THERE IS A BROAD
VERY ABILITY AND POLICY
OPERATION AND TECHNOLOGY PROSCAR
GRANTS IN CONTE'S. MANY CROSSES
THESE ARE HIGHLY MANUAL AND
REPETITIVE IT RELY ON TIME
CONSUMING PAPER BASED APPROACHES
TO VERIFICATION. S. B. H. GAINES
TO RIP ADDRESS THE ESPY CREEMOS
CENTRALIZED. HUB THAT WILL
STREAMLINE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION. THIS WILL BENEFIT
PROGRAM CLIENTS BY IMPROVING THE
SPEED OF VERIFICATION
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS BY PROVIDING
ACCESS TO NEAR REAL TIME
VERIFICATION AND PROCESS
SIMPLIFICATION. M. STATE BY
IMPROVING DATA SECURITY AND
REPORTING CAPABILITIES. SB WHICH
WILL FOCUS ON TWO DIFFERENT
VERIFICATION. TWO DIFFERENT
STEPS IN THE VERIFICATION
PROCESS. THE FIRST IS INITIAL
VERIFICATION OF ELIGIBILITY WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL APPLIES FOR
BENEFITS AND THE SECOND IS THE
ONGOING VERIFICATION WE-DETERMINATION GREENWALD AND RE
CERTIFICATION. INITIALLY AS I
MENTIONED THE FOCUS WILL BE ON
HOW WORKS CALFRESH MEDI CAL IN
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS BUT OVER
TIME THE GOAL IS FOR SB H. TO
BECOME THE SINGLE SOURCE OF
CUSTOMER VERIFICATION
INFORMATION FOR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE. AS A RESULT AS USUAL
INTERFACE CLOSELY WITH ALL SIDES
AND OTHER ELIGIBILITY
VERIFICATION SYSTEMS BUT WILL
REMAIN A STANDALONE SOLUTION TO
ENABLE BETTER FUTURE CONNECTIONS
TO OTHER ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WHILE S. B. H. WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY STREAMLINE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION IT
WILL NOT SERVE AS A CENTRALIZED
APPLICATION SYSTEM. CLIENTS WILL
STILL NEED TO APPLY FOR
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS ALTHOUGH THE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
PROCESS SHOULD BE MUCH FASTER
AND EASIER ONCE AN INDIVIDUAL
HAS ALREADY APPLIED FOR ONE
PROGRAM. AS S. B. H. WILL ALLOW
ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS AND OTHER
VERIFICATIONS THAT I'VE ALREADY
BEEN SUBMITTED. THE PROJECT IS
CURRENTLY IN BUSINESS DISCOVERY
PHASE AND WE ARE ENGAGING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ARE WE ARE ENGAGING
IN STAKEHOLDER SESSIONS WITH
COUNTIES TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
NEEDS AND- YOU STATES. ARE
TARGET FOR GO LIVE IS JULY
TWENTY TWENTY FOR. INSTANCE OF
COURSE ON EVERYTHING CONTINUING
TO MOVE SMOOTHLY WITH THE COW
SIZE FIFTY EIGHT. COUNTY GO I'VE
OCCURRING IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE PROJECT HAS A
SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET. FEDERAL SHARING TWELVE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT
AND IT'S TEACHER UP FOR MILLION-
ACROSS FISCAL YEARS TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND- OR- WHAT ABOUT SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION IN STATE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION AND
STATE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND TWO MILLION IN
STATE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. THIS BUDGET DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE ULTIMATE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH DEVELOPING AN
IMPLEMENTATION THE SOLUTION THAT
WILL BE IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
PRODUCT. LIFECYCLE PROCESS THAT
IS INTENDED TO BE- REQUESTED IN
FUTURE SESSIONS. I'M GONNA MOVE
ON NOW TO SOME OF THE OTHER
PROJECTS THAT ROUTE HAS BEEN
WORKING ON. ROBERTS CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
INFORMATION SERVICES DIVISION
TEAM AND- SITES DELIVER SEVERAL
OTHER AUTOMATION INITIATIVES
AFFECTING MAJOR ANY PROPERTY
PROGRAMS IF YOU THESE PROGRAMS
INCLUDE. EARLY BEGINNINGS OF THE
SHIP REALLY BEGINNING SINCE THE
SERIES OF TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
DEVELOPED TO CREATE UNDER
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE A NEW
CHILD CARE DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WILL FACILITATE A BETTER
FLOW OF DATA- PROGRAMS. THIS
INCLUDES CAL SPARK WHICH WILL
SERVE AS A STREAMLINING AT THE
DATA SYSTEMS AND BUSINESS
PROCESSESTHE GOVERNMENT LEVEL
OF INFORMATION BETWEEN FAMILIES
PROVIDERS. STATE OFFICIALS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. IT WILL ALSO
INCLUDE A CONSUMER EDUCATION
PORTAL WHICH IS THE DEVELOPMENT
OF WEB BASED PORTAL TO PROVIDE
FAMILIES WITH BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT. PROVIDER FEATURES
AVAILABILITY. FINALLY THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM
WHICH WILL COMBINE INFORMATION
EARLY CHILDHOOD PASTA BERMAN
CELTIC BETTER LEARNING
OPERATIONS. THESE PRODUCTS ARE
ALL EARLY DEVELOPMENT STAGES IN
RAD SERVES AS A PRODUCT SPONSOR
. FIVE MINUTES HELP DEVELOP THE
STRATEGIC VISION OF THE OVERALL
BEGINS NEXT. IN ADDITION TO
BILLY BEGINNINGS RAD- HAS BEEN
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE BENEFITS
CAL PROJECT I KNOW WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT THAT ALREADY SO I
WON'T SPEND TOO MUCH MORE TIME
DISCUSSING THAT- BUT REID HAS
BEEN WRAPPED HAS BEEN. PROJECT
AND SERVED AS A LIAISON BETWEEN
ALL PROGRAM PARTNERS IN CALCITE
BENEFITS CALIPER DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT TESTING
IMPLEMENTATION. SIMILARLY WITH
OUR ORDER- BRAD HAS- HELP- IS
SERVED AS THE PROJECT SPONSOR IN
ITS HELPED DESIGN THE ORIGINAL
VISION IT REDUCES THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT GO
INTO- THE COLOR TOUCH BOARD.
FINALLY WITH THE EBT SYSTEM- ET
IS THE MECHANISM FOR THE
DELIVERY OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
BENEFITS INCLUDING HOW FAST HOW
WORKS CASCADE AND THE PANDEMIC
EDT PROGRAMS CDSS OVERSEAS DVD
PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH A
WEBSITE AND WITH OUR EDT BENDER
FIDELITY NATIONAL INFORMATION
SERVICES COMING UP IT'S UP I. S.
BASED ON JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DATA. HOW QUESTION HOW WORK
SERVES APPROXIMATELY. FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION PEOPLE WITH
PROTECTED- CALFRESH HOW FRESH
BENEFITS FUNDING AT FIFTEEN
POINT NINE BILLION AND
PROTECTING OUR EXPANDING AT SIX
POINT FIVE BILLION. AB DE IS
PLACE TO DRAW ON THE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY RESPONSE OR THE
PAST TWO YEARS AND IT'S HAD A
NUMBER OF MAJOR PROJECTS IN THE
WORKS AS WELL. ET AND THE
CALIFORNIA EBT FRUIT THAT YOU
PILOT INCREASE CARD SECURITY
MEASURES. I WAS NOT HAPPY TAKE
QUESTIONS LATER. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM CYNTHIA TOCAR
WHO IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CHILD WELFARE DIGITAL SERVICES
AT THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AKALI TRADE JUST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHERMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
INFORMATION ON THE CARRIAGE
PROJECT WHERE WE ARE COST
SCHEDULE SCOPE XTERRA. SO I'M
GONNA GO RIGHT INTO IT AND THEN
WE CAN HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
MIGHT BE. THE SCOPE OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES- CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATED RESPONSE AND
ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM WHICH WE CALL
CTS CARES IS THE FOCUS IS TO
REPLACE OUR EXISTING- CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM ALSO KNOWN AS THE
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM- THE PROJECT
IS FOCUSED ON BUILDING A CHILD
WELFARE INFORMATION SYSTEM THAT.
MEETS THE CHILD WELFARE WORKER
NEEDS ON A DAILY BASIS SUPPORTS
TODAY'S BEST PRACTICES INCLUDING
PROGRAM PRACTICES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY RESULTS. IN IMPROVED
OUTCOMES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN. THE DELIVERY OF CARE
FOR FALLING TO MAJOR RELEASES
VERSION ONE AND VERSION TWO.
VERSION ONE COVERS THE
FUNCTIONALITY REQUIRED TO
REPLACE THE EXISTING SYSTEM-
WHICH AND SUPPORT NEW POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS- THAT EXISTING
SYSTEM DOES NOT SUPPORT. AND
IT'S ALSO LOOKING TO LAY OUR
FOUNDATION FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL COMPREHENSIVE CHILD
WELFARE INFORMATION SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS- THE V. VERSION ONE
WILL ENABLE THAT THOSE CORE
CHILD WELFARE AT PIECES OF WORK
YOU KNOW FOR INTEGRA ELIGIBILITY
COURTS WORK ALL OF THE
INDEPENDENT DAY TO DAY WORK THAT
THEY DO. VERSION TWO LOOKS TO
EXPAND THAT VERSION ONE
FUNCTIONALITY AND PROVIDES AN
EXTENDED CAPABILITIES- AND
IMPLEMENTED- SOME FEDERALLY
REQUIRED DATA EXCHANGES AS WELL
AS- SEVEN EXISTING EXCHANGES
FROM BETWEEN THE STAFF STATE
SYSTEMS. ARE THE CURRENT
SCHEDULE FOR VERSION ONE IS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION TO COMPLETE AND
MAY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
BASED ON LESSONS- THAT WE'VE
LEARNED OVER- I WOULD SAY THE
LAST YEAR AND WITH THE
DEMONSTRATION MODUL
DEMONSTRATION MODULE THAT WE-
IMPLEMENTED TO FIVE COUNTIES- AB
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH OUR
INDEPENDENT ADVISER TO DETERMINE
WHAT- CHANGES. THERE MAY NEED TO
BE TO THE OVERALL PROJECT TIME
LINE WHICH SHOULD BE SUBMITTED
LATER THIS YEAR AND SPECIAL
PROJECTS. SIX THE CURRENT
ESTIMATED TOTAL PROJECT BUDGET
HAS NOT CHANGED SINCE THE SPR
PROVED IN- SPRING OUT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND IS STILL SITTING
AT AS THE OVERALL PROJECT- COST
OF NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION
AND THIS DOES INCLUDE THE-
STABILIZATION AS WELL AS BELIEVE
IT'S ROUGHLY IN NINE MONTHS
EIGHT OR NINE MONTHS- C. WEST
REVIEW PERIOD WHICH EXTENDS
THAT. THE TIME FRAME- AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S IT DO WE HAVE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. I WILL
ADDRESS ALL QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF THAT'S OKAY WE'LL GET THROUGH
THE PANEL- NEXT WILL HAVE
JESSICA- ZHOU CHIEF. CHIEF
WELFARE SYSTEMS BRANCH CHIEF AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU TERM
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME'S
JESSICA RIZZO I AM NOT THAT
CHEAP THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
BRANCH AND THE EXECUTIVE SPONSOR
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CHILD WELFARE
TECHNICAL SERVICES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
WHEN ASKED TODAY TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE FUNCTIONALITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED FOR
MAJOR PARTS THAT THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM AND WHAT'S ON THE
HORIZON FOR FUTURE
IMPLEMENTATION. SUPPRESSED OFF I
HAVEN'T TO DATE WE HAVE RELEASED
TWO KEY PRODUCTS THAT SUPPORT
KEY ELEMENTS IN THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM. THEIR FIRST CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS ASSESSMENT KNOWN AS
PICKING ARMS TOOL- WE RELEASED
THAT THANKS NOW ALREADY IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT CULTURE TOOK. LIVE
INITIALLY IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH TWO SUBSEQUENT
RELEASES AFTERWARDS. AND IT'S
AND IT'S BENEFIT WHITE USAGE
SINCE CHEN AT TWENTY NINETEEN.
AT A LOSS FOR DIRECT ENTRY AT
THESE CHILD AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS AND- BURN YOU CAN
CARE AND IT BE INITIAL ECCENTRIC
SIXTY DAYS. TO QUIT EVERY SIX
MONTHS THEREAFTER. FOR CHILD
WELFARE AND THEIR CRITICAL
PARTNERS- THIS INFORMATION IS
USED FOR COORDINATION OF CARE
FOR YOU. BETWEEN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH EDUCATION CHILD WELFARE
ANOTHER KEY PARTNERS. AND ALSO
SUPPORTS OUR PUBLIC CARE
PROTOCOL- AND WHICH ELEMENTS
THAT KILLED THAT PICKED HIM UP
CARE. IN FEBRUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO WE ALSO
RELEASED OUR PROOF OF CONCEPT
AND I IN THE CWS. DEVELOPMENT
AND WE RECORDED IT SPRINGFIELD.
YEAH IT IS ACTUALLY IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE APPLICATION SUBMISSION
REVIEW AND APPROVAL I'VE
RESOURCE FAMILIES. AND THAT IS A
KEY ELEMENT OF CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM TO SUPPORT EXPANDED
FAMILY BASED CARE. AND THE
REDUCTION OF CONGREGATE CARE.
THIS IS JUST THE VERY FIRST
PIECE FUNCTIONAL FOR THE
RESOURCE PER PROCESS AND FULL
FOR. BOARD REMAINING WILL BE
RELEASED WITH ONE OF CARE- WE-
PLEASE. THAT WE ARE PARTNERING
WITH STATE POLICY AND PROGRAM
STAFF AND COOK COUNTY AND TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO JOINTLY
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL NEEDS FOR
AUTOMATION SOLUTIONS AND THEY
HAVE TO MEET THE OBJECTIVES THAT
C. C. R. AND CARES BUT WE HAVE
SEVERAL. I THINK KEY FEATURES
THAT WE HIGHLIGHT HER VERSION
ONE AND VERSION TWO THAT ARE
ALREADY. PLANT INITIALLY IT WE
WILL HAVE ENHANCED FEATURES FOR
CANCER REPORTING IN PERSON ONE
THAT WILL ALLOW THE ABILITY FOR
ADDITIONAL PARTNERS AND DIRECT
ENTRY AND DATA EXCHANGE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERS. WE WILL
HAVE A PLACEMENT MATCHING
DIRECTORY THAT ALLOWS FOR MORE
DETAILED CHILD PLACEMENT
MATCHING AND SUPPORT TO FIND THE
BEST PLACEMENTS POSSIBLE. THERE
WILL BE AN INITIAL FUNCTIONALITY
AND BE ONE AND WE AND WE- PLAN
FOR OUR ENHANCED FEATURES AND
FUNCTIONALITY TO EXPAND OVER
TIME IN PERSON TO GO.
ADDITIONALLY WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT MORE ROBUST AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AROUND ALL
THE DIFFERENT PLACEMENT TYPES
INCLUDING STR T. P.'S. THIS WILL
SUPPORT PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
PROVIDER ACCREDITATION MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVALS MEDICAL
CERTIFICATION WILL ALSO BE
LOOKING AT B. EDITION OF
ADDITIONAL- LICENSING TYPES SUCH
AS TEMPORARY AND TRANSITIONAL
SHELTERS. IN THAT DIRECTORY AND
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT OUR YOU
ARE TEACHING FACILITIES. WITH
THE DOCUMENTATION AROUND BE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL
ACCREDITATION AT BASIC COURT
INFORMATION AND ENSURES
COMPLIANCE WITH. THE FAMILIES
FIRST PREVENTIVE SERVICES ACT
AND SUPPORTING AFTER CARE. THIS
IS GONNA BE FOCUSED ON YOUTH
STEPPING DOWN COM AT CARE ACT IT
CONGREGATE CARE INTO A LOWER
LEVELS OF KERR WITH WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES. WILL ALSO BE
SUPPORTING. AT ALL OF THE NEW
RATE CAPS- CAR CARE REFORM. AND
IT'S AT IN PERSON TO WE ADVANCE
WE ANTICIPATE MORE ADVANCED
FEATURES INCLUDING MORE I
REQUEST DATA EXCHANGES AND
ALLOWING FOR DIRECT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR COMPLEX CARE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
SYSTEM. WORK AND ADVANCED
ANALYTICS AND REPORTING TOOLS
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR MUCH MORE
DETAILED LONGITUDINAL
EXAMINATION OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AS WELL AS
SYSTEMIC ANALYSIS OUR SYSTEM AND
SERVICE RIGHT. AND I BELIEVE
THAT IS ALL I HAVE IN THIS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM JENNIFER TRACY
WHO IS THE CAL SAWS ADVOCATES CO
LEAD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. OF FOOD BANKS THANK
YOU I THINK THAT MY NAME IS
JENNIFER TRACY I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT
CONSUMER NEEDS TODAY. FOR MY
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT CONCRETE
STRATEGIES FOR THE THAT THE
STATE CAN TAKE ABOUT ENSURING
ACCESS TO BENEFITS THERE'S THREE
MAIN AREAS THAT WE LOOK AT-
ACCESSIBILITY RESOURCES AND
DIGITAL EQUITY SO IN TERMS OF
ACCESSIBILITY- WERE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN AND LANGUAGE
ACCESS WE KNOW FROM THE STATE'S
RESEARCH THAT LANGUAGE
ACCESSIBILITY AS ONE OF THEM.
ONE OF THE MAIN- FACTORS IN IT
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE CAN
ACCESS BENEFITS SO MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS INVESTMENTS FROM
THE STATE LEVEL AND TRANSLATION
SERVICES AND SUPPORTING
INTERPRETATION AT THAT. MORE AT
THE GROUND LEVEL- AND HAVING
COMMUNITY REVIEW OF THOSE
TRANSLATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MAKING THEM ACTUALLY MAKES SENSE
THE FOLKS ON THE GROUND THAT ARE
READING THEM- I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SEE. IF WITH BENEFITS PAL
THAT AS MUCH AS IT'S REALLY
GREAT THAT THE WEBSITE IS
TRANSLATED INTO THE THRESHOLD
LANGUAGES WE WANT PEOPLE TO ALSO
BE ABLE TO AND PUT THEIR DATA.
IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGE AS WELL SO
MOVING TOWARDS A WAY OF FINDING
A WAY FOR THAT SOLUTION TO BE
INTEGRATED INTO BENEFITS CAL. IN
TERMS OF RESOURCES- WE KNOW THAT
THE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN- PUTTING
IN HER OUTLOOK EFFORTS TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
LOOKING AT THAT. TWENTY YEAR OLD
FORMULA FOR SUPPORTING-
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AND BEING
ABLE TO MEET COMMUNITY NEEDS-
AND THEN ALSO PRIORITIZING THE
CBO'S AND A SISTER THAT'S PART
OF THE BENEFITS ECOSYSTEM. SO
MAKING SURE THAT- AS WE'RE
DEVELOPING BENEFITS CAL BUT IT'S
REALLY CLEAR ABOUT THEIR ROLE IN
THE ECOSYSTEM AND HOW THEY- THEY
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT
CONSUMERS CAN ACCESS BENEFITS-
THERE'S DATA THAT SHOWS THAT.
CONSUMERS HAVE A 60% BETTER
CHANCE OF GETTING BENEFITS IF
THEY WORK WITH SOMEBODY AND A
SISTER- AND WE KNOW THAT THE
FOLKS WORKING WITH THE SISTERS
ARE OFTEN PEOPLE OF THE HARDEST
TIME ACCESSING BENEFITS ON THEIR
OWN. IF PEOPLE COULD DO IT ON
THEIR OWN THEY WOULD THEY GO TO
A SISTER BECAUSE THEY NEED HELP-
AND THEN DIGITAL EQUITY- YOU
KNOW WHAT COURSE YOU WANT THE
BENEFITS CAL WEBSITE TO BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE LAW THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. BUT WE ALSO
WANTED TO BE SET UP IN A WAY
WHERE THE INFORMATION FLOW THE
QUESTIONS THE WAY THEY'RE WORDED
ALLOW CONSUMERS TO. BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE LOT AS WELL
SO THEY DON'T GET CONFUSED AND
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS OR OR
JUST GIVE UP AND THE NOT APPLIED
APPLIED ALL- AND SO. HAVING A
HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN APPROACHES
I THINK IT'S BEEN VENTURED
BEFORE AND THAT OFFENSE TAKEN
AUTHENTIC ENGAGEMENT AS PART OF
THE PROCESS. SO THOSE ARE A FEW
OF THE STRATEGIES THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE REALLY GREAT FOR THE
STATE TO SUPPORT AND TO CONTINUE
CHECKING BACK WITH ABOUT HOW IS
THAT GOING AND- AND HOW ARE WE
ACTUALLY MODELING THAT PRACTICE-
AND FOR MY SECOND QUESTION ABOUT
THAT HE- FEATURES- FIRST I'D-
YOU KNOW. I WANTED. THAT THE
COLLABORATION WE'VE BEEN
CREATING WITH CAL STARS AS
CONTINUING TO EVOLVE. AND WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT A NEW WORK
GROUP THAT'S BEING DEVELOPED
THAT WILL INCLUDE CONSUMERS. THE
COUNTIES S. C. B. O. ADVOCATES-
TO ADD TO DECIDE TOGETHER HOW DO
WE PRIORITIZE THINGS. AND SO
WE'RE EXCITED TO INVEST IN THAT
AND LOOKED BACK BEFORE TO COME
BACK TO TELL YOU HOW THAT'S
GOING- THE OVERALL. I THINK ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THINGS WE'D LIKE
TO SEE IS A WAYS TO REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN- SOME OF
US KNOW THE TERM BEING TIME
POOR. WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO DO EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO DO- FOR SOME OF US THAT
MEANS WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO
TO THE GYM OR ANSWER ALL OUR
EMAILS. BUT WE KNOW FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING IT MEANS. DO
I CHOOSE BETWEEN TAKING MY KID
TO THE DOCTOR. WAITING IN LINE
TO GET FOOD OR FILLING OUT
PAPERWORK. TO TRY TO GET
BENEFITS A FEW WEEKS FROM NOW.
AND SO WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ACCESS POINTS WE
HAVE. REDUCE THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN AND THAT WERE FUNDING
COUNTY SO THAT THEY CAN PICK UP
THE SLACK ON THAT FOR THE THINGS
WE KNOW THEY'RE OBLIGATED TO
MAKE SURE HAPPEN AS PART OF THAT
PROCESS. THE LAST JUST COUPLE
THINGS I'LL MENTION- ONE OF THE
BARRIERS THAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW WITH BENEFITS CALLOUS PEOPLE
CAN'T GET AN ACCOUNT. TO USE ALL
OF THE REALLY COOL FUNCTIONALITY
WITHOUT AN EMAIL ADDRESS. AND
FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE LOW. TECH THE
ABILITY THEY CAN USE THE WEBSITE
BUT THEY JUST MIGHT NOT HAVE
THAT EMAIL ADDRESS TO DO IT SO.
WANTING TO SHIFT THAT PART OF
THE PROCESS- WE WANT TO STICK.
BETWEEN THE COUNTIES IN TERMS
OF. ARE THEY- THEY IMPLEMENTING
ALL OF THE OPTIONS THAT THEY
HAVE DIPS A PROFIT PROVIDE
ACCESS FOR CONSUMERS SO THAT.
THERE IS CONSISTENCY IN PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCES ACROSS THE COUNTIES.
AND THEN LASTLY- WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SYSTEMS ARE
WORKING SO HAVING A ROBUST
PUBLIC DASHBOARD THAT WE CAN
SHOW. THOSE METRICS OF POWER
PEOPLE NOT ONLY USING THE SYSTEM
SO WE CAN SEE WHERE WE NEED TO
TWEAK THE SYSTEM. BUT ALSO ARE
WE GETTING THE RESULTS THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE SAID THAT THERE IS
BOTH. THE SYSTEM FUNCTION AND
THE OUTCOMES PIECE AS PART OF
THAT DASHBOARD. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TODAY THANK YOU
NEXT WILL HAVE RUBEN CANNELLA
WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
EQUITY INITIATIVES. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY BASIC NEEDS COMMITTEE.
YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH I JUST
BEFORE I GET STARTED I DO WANT
TO SHARE SOMETHING SO I GREW UP
IN A IN A WOMAN MAJORITY FAMILY
AND THE FAMILIES FEMINISTS
HOUSEHOLD. AND I MOVED BACK HOME
TO TAKE CARE OF FAMILY DURING
THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE IT GOT
ROUGH. AND MY MOM WOULD ALWAYS
COME IN THAT IT WAS ALWAYS A
BUNCH OF CREDITS AND WOMEN AND
ALL OF MY ZOOM SPACES AND IT WAS
A FEMALE MAJORITY SHE WAS ALWAYS
SUPER EXCITED AND THEN SHE OULD
ALSO SPEND TO ME AND SAY. HOW
COME MEN ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH.
SO I'LL MAKE SURE TO LET HER
KNOW TODAY THAT THE SPACE WERE
HELD BY MAIL. WHO SAYS MINE LAST
NAME CORRECTLY AND BUY A WHOLE
BUNCH OF MEN. THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
THINK SHE'S GOING TO BE VERY
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT SO JUST WANT
TO START WITH THAT- I THINK
AFTER ME IN THE TIME THAT I
HAVE. WE WANTED TO WE WANTED TO
REALLY LIFT AND CELEBRATE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS IN THIS
AREA OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS I
THINK OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS.
MAGIC HAPPEN AND WE STARTED
ORGANIZING ACROSS THE DIFFERENT
SECTORS ACROSS A DIFFERENT
COMMUTE TO SAY IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR US TO BE COMPETING
WITH EACH OTHER. IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR US TO NOT BE CONNECTED
TO EACH OTHER AND IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE FOR US TO. CONTINUE
COORDINATING EFFORTS AND THE
SEPARATE ISOLATED AREAS OF THIS
WORK WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING ALL OF US AT ONCE
FOR BETTER OR FOR WORSE.
SOMETHING THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
PROGRESS THAT NOW I FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT WE WERE JUST TALKING
JOHN. AND US THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOW A
NATIONAL MODEL FOR A LOT OF THIS
WORK FROM THE TECHNOLOGY TO THE
ORGANIZING TO THE STRUCTURES TO
THE DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE TO THE WAY THAT WE HAVE
PRIORITIZE IN THE IMPACT THAT
WE'RE HAVING AND YOU CAN SEE. IT
SEE IT AND THE DRASTIC INCREASE
IN APPLICATIONS IF YOU JUST LOOK
AT COLLEGE STUDENTS AS A CASE
STUDY. IT'S A MASSIVE INCREASE
WHERE WE WEREN'T EVEN AT 1% OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT WERE
APPLYING. AND NOW WE'RE ABOUT
12% OF STUDENTS OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS APPLYING FOR CALFRESH
ALONE RIGHT SO THERE'S A LOT TO
CELEBRATE THEIR- AND AS WE HAVE
MADE SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS WE'VE
ALSO BEEN LEARNING ABOUT. WHAT
ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE MISSING
THAT CAN HELP US SCALE BECAUSE
BY THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE
LEAVING A LOT OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES. THAT SHOULD BE COMING
TO CALIFORNIA. IMPROVING THE
LOCAL ECONOMIES IMPROVING THE
STATE ECONOMY. CARING FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND MEETING THE
METRICS OF SUCCESS THAT WE
EXPECT OUT OF THESE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS. TOPPING WHAT WE
WANTED TO LIVE WAS. HOW DO WE
MOVE IN THE DIRECTION OF. AS WE
CONTINUE TO. CELEBRATE OUR CDSS
C. W. D. A. CAL SAUCE THE CBO'S.
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT WILL ALSO
BEING INTENTIONAL ABOUT
INVESTING AND THE FOLLOW THROUGH
OF A LOT OF THIS WORK. OUT
REACH. AS ADULT AT A POINT THAT
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE RIGHT
LIKE THERE'S MANDATED.
VERIFICATIONS COMMUNICATIONS
PROACTIVE ENGAGING WITH THE
COMMUNITY. THAT NOW- AGAIN
COLLEGE STUDENTS AS A CASE
STUDY. RECEIVE MULTIPLE
COMMUNICATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
LEGIBILITY. AND ENCOURAGING THEM
TO APPLY. WHAT WE DON'T SEE IS
WE DON'T SEE. WHAT ARE THE
OUTCOMES OF THOSE APPLICATIONS.
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO IS
THE NEW ONES LEVEL OF. LET'S SAY
AT A COUNTY A COUNTY LIKE
ALAMEDA COUNTY. HAS MULTIPLE
COLLEGES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STATE UNIVERSITY ANNA YOU SEE
WITHIN THE SAME COUNTY. WE HAVE
NO IDEA IF ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
ARE HAVING. EASIER BETTER MORE
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME OF THE UC
BERKELEY APPLICATIONS COMPARED
TO THE CAL STATE EAST BAY
APPLICANTS COMPARED TO LANIER
LOANEES ON AND SO FORTH DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE YUP. BECAUSE THE
APPLICATIONS ARE SO NUANCED.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT ARE THE
OUTCOMES WHAT THE- OUTCOMES DATA
OF THIS WORK. AND HOW DO WE
CONTROL FOR SOME OF THE FACTORS
THAT ARE NO PREVIOUS PANELISTS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT ABOUT. IT I
CAUGHT I'M AN ETHNIC STUDIES
MAJOR SO IUSE INTERSECTION
ALLEY. BUT ON THE DATA SIDE WE
USE MULTI FACTOR ANALYSES. WE
NEED THAT MULTI FACTOR ANALYSIS
TO SEE. FOR THE APPLICANTS THAT
ARE GETTING BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
THE OUT APPLICANTS ARE NOT
GETTING THE BETTER OUTCOMES. SO
THAT WE CAN USE THAT TO EDUCATE
TO TRYING TO COACH EACH OTHER. I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF FEAR THAT
PEOPLE THINK THAT WE WANT TO USE
THAT THE THAT. THAT DATA TO
SHAME OR TO. I DON'T KNOW THOUGH
KINDS OF. IMPLICATIONS TO THE
COMPETITION THAT IS NOT THE
CULTURE AND THE VALUES THAT WE
BRING INTO THIS WORK. NO ONE
WINS FROM SHAMING AND BLAMING
EACH OTHER THERE'S PLENTY OF
THAT GOING ON WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER
SO THAT WE CAN AMPLIFY AND BUILD
ON THE ASSETS. TO THE WORK AND
THE CAPACITY THAT WE HAVE. AND
THE LAST THING TO SHARE WITH YOU
GUYS I THINK OFTENTIMES WE
FORGET THREE KEY THINGS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE COLLEGE DURING OUR
CONVERSATION SPECIFICALLY. WE
THINK THAT THE COLLEGE WORK IS
JUST ABOUT COLLEGE STUDENTS. I'M
A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT I NEED FINANCIAL AID TO
GO TO COLLEGE I KNOW THAT
THROUGH MY YEARS IN COLLEGE. I
WAS STILL TRANSLATING A LOT OF
WORK FOR FAMILIES BACK HOME FROM
MY OWN FAMILY FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE THIS
OUT FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS IS
BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE TO BE THE
PRIMARY SUPPORT SYSTEMS FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. WE'RE NOT JUST
THINKING ABOUT IMPROVING THE
TOOL FOR THE COLLEGE STUDENT THE
COALITION IS PROBABLY SUPPORTING
THE PARENTS THE SIBLINGS THE
WHOEVER IS POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR SOCIAL SERVICES. THROUGH
THEIR TIMING COLLEGE RATHER THAN
JUST FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT. SO
THINKING ABOUT COLLEGE STUDENTS
AS CROSS POLLINATORS AND AS THE
MULTIPLYING EFFECT IS ESSENTIAL
FOR US TO LIFT IN THE
CONVERSATION. BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
WE USE THIS HIERARCHY OF HUMAN
VALUE AND PEOPLE THINK THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT COLLEGE
STUDENTS OVER EVERYONE ELSE. AND
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE WE'RE
TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF EVERYBODY
ESPECIALLY FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS I KNOW THAT I
COME FROM THE IMPERIAL VALLEY.
FOLKS FROM THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
DON'T GO TO THE UC AND VOLUMES
WE DON'T GO TO THE CSU AND
VOLUMES WE MAKE IT INTO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND FROM THERE
HOPEFULLY WE MAKE IT INTO A FOUR
YEAR. SO THAT KIND OF LIKE
HIERARCHY OF HUMAN VALUE MAKES
NO SENSE CULTURALLY ORRIN REACT
AND THE REAL IMPLICATIONS.
SECOND TO LAST THING IS. EVERY
SINGLE STUDY THAT HAS HAPPENED
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS HAS
CONFIRMED. THAT THE METRICS OF
SUCCESS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION THE
CALIFORNIA CARES ABOUT. ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY RETENTION
PERSISTENCE PERFORMANCE AND
COMPLETION ARE ALL AND RIGHT
RELATIONSHIP WITH BASIC NEEDS.
IF WE'RE NOT MEETING THE BASIC
NEEDS OF STUDENTS NONE OF THOSE
METRICS SAYS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
. THAT OUR STATE LEADERSHIP AND
ALEJO AND THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE TO CAN BE
MET. WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS THAT
HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET
PERFORMED AT MUCH BETTER AND
HIGHER RATES AND OUTCOMES IN ALL
OF THOSE METRICS AS A SUCCESS.
AND THE LAST THING AND I THINK
WHAT WOULD BE MOST HELPFUL. IS
TO UNDERSTAND THAT OFTENTIMES
WHEN WE HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
WE IMMEDIATELY THINK ABOUT COST.
AND THE RETURN OF INVESTMENT AND
WE THINK ABOUT THE COST IN REAL
TIME BUT WE DON'T THINK ABOUT
HOW. WHAT'S THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AND THINKING ABOUT.
THE CAPACITY OF STUDENTS BEING
ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE AND
GENERATIVE WAYS THIS IS DATA
THAT WE GOT FROM CDSS AND FROM
C. SACK. FOR THE AMOUNT OF ZERO.
EFC STUDENTS THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY EIGHT STUDENTS IN THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
ONE. WE HAD JUST AND ROLLED 50%
OF THEM. NOT EVEN AT THE MAXIMUM
OF CALIPHATE'S LET'S SAY AROUND
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN FEDERAL DOLLAR VALUE
OF FOURTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH. EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SIX MONTHS
AND A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWELVE
MONTHS. JUST DOING IT FOR THAT
SMALL PORTION OF THE COLLEGE
STUDENT POPULATION. AND YOU
AMPLIFY THAT TO LOW FC TO
WORKING CLASS STUDENTS. THE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
US TO BUILD OUT THIS DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PUBLIC
DASHBOARDS TO INFORM THE WORK.
ESSENTIALLY PAYS ITSELF AND WAY
MORE. SO JUST WANTED TO LIFT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS SO THAT WE
CAN SAY AS WE CELEBRATE AND
WE'RE CONSIDERING WHAT ARE THE
INVESTMENTS TO MAKE. THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING
AND NOT JUST WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
AND WHERE WE ARE TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE INVITATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD WITH
CWDM. THANK YOU MR CAL NUMBERS
CATHOLIC DONALD C. W. DA-
PERFORMING UP TO THE TWO
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THE PANEL IS
SO- DIVERSE WHEN I FIRST BACK
TO- THAT. THE TOPIC THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AND I'M FINDING
IT TO BE EXTREMELY ENJOYABLE AND
REALLY INFORMATIVE AND SO I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND. YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR PUTTING TOGETHER- JUST
A GREAT DISCUSSION ON WHAT CAN
OFTEN BE A VERY PRICE SUBJECT.
THE ISSUE OF HOW THE I. T. AN
AUTOMATION CAN SUPPORT. MY
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFF AS WELL
AS THE CUSTOMERS THAT WE ALSO
SUPPORT- THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO MAKE THAT POINT. I WOULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WS
CARE AND FEW TO BE DA AND THE
COUNTIES ROLL WITH THAT PROJECT. AND HOW WE SEE IT GOING SO FAR. AS WELL AS MY STAFF. AND WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH CDS
ASSET- I FINAL QUESTION HER FROM
TODAY- AND HAVE A NUMBER OF
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL
INTEGRATED INTO THE PROJECT
TEAM. THESE ARE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT RECOGNIZES
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE END USERS ARE
CHILD WELFARE WORKERS.
REPRESENTED AT THE SYSTEM IS
BEING DESIGNED AND BUILT TO
ENSURE THAT IT WILL WORK. COUNTY
WAITING A LONG TIME FOR A NEW
TRIAL SYSTEM AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE THE PROJECT
GETTING STARTED TO BUILD THE
FUNCTIONALITY TO REPLACE. CWS
AT. THE EXISTING SYSTEM IS NOT
ROBUST ENOUGH TO CAPTURE ALL OF
THE INFORMATION AND DATA WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. BOTH FOR THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE DISCUSSED
ON THE PRIOR PANEL AS WELL AS
FOR SERVICE DELIVERY AND
PLANNING COURT ENGAGEMENT AND
THE OTHER VITAL WORK THAT COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES JAIL. AS
THE VENDORS WORK WITH THE
PROJECT TO ADJUST PROJECT PLANS
BASED ON LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE DEMONSTRATION MODEL THAT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WILL NEED TO
ADDRESS THE PLANS AND FUNDING
FOR COUNTY PARTICIPATION TO
ALIGN WITH ANY SCHEDULE CHANGES
THAT HAPPEN. JUST WANT TO MAKE
THE POINT THOUGH THAT
MAINTAINING COUNTY PARTICIPATION
FUNDING AS WELL AS THE
OVERARCHING EXTRICATION OF
COUNTY ENGAGEMENT AND
REPRESENTATION IS ESSENTIAL. TO
ENSURING THAT ROBUST COUNTY
PARTICIPATION AND THAT
PERSPECTIVE AT THE END USER IS
SUPPORT IT. IF NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM MORE
BUILDING WILL MEET COUNTY STAFF
NEEDS AS THEY WORK TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. WELL OUR STAFF ARE THE
END USERS OF THE SYSTEM AS WE
TALK ABOUT WE ALWAYS LET'S KEEP
IN MIND THE NEEDS OF THAT
ALTERNATE CUSTOMER PARTICULARLY
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT
WE SERVE IT MIGHT. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED BOTH AT THAT C. W.
D. A. LEVEL AS WELL AS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. IT IS WITH THE
STATE CONTRACTING PROCESS. AS WE
ENTER INTO WITH THE STATE BOTH
C. W. D. A. CORRECTLY AS WELL AS
COUNTY'S INDIVIDUALLY MUST GO
THROUGH A FULL CONTRACTING
PROCESS AND BE APPROVED. THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES WHICH HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY RESULTING IN DELAYS
THE PRETTIEST GAPS IN OUR
ABILITY TO HAVE COUNTY AND TO
THE MEDIA REPRESENTATIVE. JOIN
THE PROJECT NAMELY AND CAN WE
CAN EXTENDED THE LAYS THE
BILLING VACANCIES THAT OCCUR.
THE WORK AT THE WTA COUNTIES ARE
DOING ON TEARS AND OTHER IT
PROJECTS AS WELL REALLY DOESN'T
FIT NEATLY WITHIN THE NORMAL
STATE CONTACTING PROTOCOLS- THIS
IS NOT A WIDGET THAT WERE
PRODUCING THESE ARE- TECHNICAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS.
AND THERE ARE VARIOUS EGS
PROVISIONS VENDOR MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS THAT REALLY JUST
DON'T APPLY IN THIS TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
SOME DEREK TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD EXEMPT OUR CONTRACTS
FROM THE RULES THAT CREATE
DELAYS WHAT IMPROVE CONTINUITY
ON THIS AND OTHER PROJECTS WITH
COUNTY KNOWLEDGEABLE
CONSULTANTS. THAT EVERYONE
BENEFITS FROM HAVING ON THE
PROJECT WE DON'T THINK THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT ON THAT POINT. OF
AND WOULD BE GLAD TO WORK WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL AS OF
COURSE THE ADMINISTRATION. TO
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE. UNNECESSARY GAPS. IN
ADDITION I WAS AT THE TOP A
LITTLE BIT OF- SOGHAN- THAT. OF
THE COW AND COUNTIES INTERVIEW
CAL THOUGHT A BENEFITS CAL WHICH
OF YOU KNOW- DOUBLE THEY OF
COURSE SINCE RELATED ADDRESS.
BUT I WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED PLANNING
FOR CALIFORNIA ASIAN- IT'S A
PLANNING EFFORT THAT'S FIVE
YEARS IN THE MAKING WITH FIRST
STARTED PLANNING AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AND ACCOUNTED TOP
PRIORITY AT THAT TIME WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TRANSITION
WILL BE A SMOOTH. AND SEAMLESS
AS POSSIBLE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS AS
WELL AS FOR OUR WORKERS IT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE ON BOTH ENDS. TO MAKE
SOMETHING SIMPLER FOR- OF FRONT
END USER CUSTOMER WHOSE SELF
SERVING BUT THAT IT IS EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED OF THE BACK AND FOR
HER ELIGIBILITY STAFF. IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HELP ANYBODY
AND IT STILL CONTINUES THE
POTENTIAL FOR DELAYS OR ERRORS.
ONE MORE SERVING CUSTOMERS. SO
WE WORK WITH THE COW IS A THE
PRICE TO BUILD AND IF THE- BUT
THE TRANSITION PARTICULARLY FOR
THE CALVIN COUNTIES. KNOWING
THAT THEY FACE A BIGGER
CHALLENGE MOVING FROM THEIR
CURRENT SYSTEM TO CALIFON. THAN
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN THE T. FOR
COUNTIES AS MR BLANKENSHIP. SO
THAT'S FOR A INFORMED- AT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE FACED
MIGRATION FOR CALVIN. ALLOWING
BOTH THE SUBSEQUENT COUNTIES IN
THE PROJECT TO BENEFIT FROM
LESSONS LEARNED IN THE PRIOR
WAIT. WHAT WE DIDN'T AND
COULDN'T HAVE PLANNED FOR WHAT
OF LOCAL PANDEMIC THAT LASTED
FOR TWO YEARS AND TECHNICALLY IS
STILL ONGOING THOUGH OF COURSE
IN A MUCH BETTER SITUATION THAN
WE HAPPEN. LOCALLY AND BECAUSE
WORK THE PROJECT DOES YOUR MAY
NOT SCHEDULE AND BOTH THE COUNTY
AND THE FONTS HAVE MANAGED TO
IMPLEMENT NUMEROUS POLICY
CHANGES AT THE SAME TIME. BOTH
TEMPORARY CHANGES THAT WERE
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
PERMANENT DUE TO CHANGING STATE
AND FEDERAL POLICIES. THERE ARE
MANY MORE POLICY CHANGES EVERY
YEAR BEING DISCUSSED UP AS WELL
AS THIS YEAR BOTH IN THE BUDGET
AND LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND WE
REALLY ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT
MANY OF THESE WE PUT A FEW FOR
HERSELF. BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE THE
ORIGINAL FOCUS OF TRYING TO MAKE
THIS. VERY BIG TRANSITION FROM
CAL WENT TO CAL FIVE AS SMOOTH
AS POSSIBLE FOR THE 40% OF OUR
STATE. IT'S GOING TO BE MAKING
THE SWITCH BETWEEN OCTOBER OF.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND OCTOBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. MY STAFF
AND I ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND YOUR STAFF AND CAL SIZE. TO
IDENTIFY IMPLEMENTATION DATES
THAT ARE FEASIBLE FOR ABOUT THE
COUNTY SAN CALIFORNIA'S TO MEET.
AND ALSO INFLOWS AND ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS BY MR BLAIR
REGARDING THE SIGNIFICANT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND IT
HELPS US DEVELOPMENT PROCESS OF
ROLLOUT. AT THE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT I DON'T RECALL SEEING
IN MY FEW DECADES THE C. W. D.
A. WITH OTHER EFFORTS. NOT THAT
THERE WASN'T ENGAGEMENT BUT THAT
THIS ENGAGEMENT IS SO MUCH MORE
ROBUST AND PUBLIC BASED THING
THAT HAPPENS IN RIOR PROJECTS
THAT I AM PARTICIPATED IN OR
OBSERVED. OF IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THAT PROCESS REALLY SPEAKS TO
STRIKE THAT APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE NEED FOR A
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AS WELL
AS THE ABILITY TO KEEP OUR
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. RUNNING
SMOOTHLY AND WORKING WITH.
COUNTY STAFF THAT INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THINGS MOVING AND DEVELOPED-
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AS WE GET TO THAT
POINT AND THAT IN THE HEARING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL. HEAR FROM BRIAN METZGER
WITH THE L. L. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CARL WAS ASKED TODAY TO SOME
HIGH LEVEL ISSUES QUESTIONS
OBSERVATIONS- ABOUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT TOPICS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY SO- I'LL KEEP TO ABOUT
FIVE OBSERVATIONS THAT WE HAVE
FOR YOU TODAY IT'S A LOT BUT
HOPEFULLY WE GET THROUGH THEM
QUICKLY- THE FIRST OF WHICH IS-
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT SEVERAL IT
PROJECTS TODAY AND WE FIND IT IS
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
BASELINE COST SCHEDULE AND SCOPE
OF THESE PROJECTS ARE- BROADLY
THE STATUS TRANSITION TO MORE
INTERACTIVES INCREMENTAL KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROJECTS AND THAT'S SLOWLY BEING
REFLECTED IN THE WAY THAT THE
STATE ADMINISTERS ITS IT
PROJECTS. HOWEVER SOME PROJECTS
HAVE STRUGGLED TO SET THEIR
BASELINE COST AND SCHEDULE AND
SCOPE BECAUSE THE APPROACH
INTRODUCES ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY AND DOES NOT HAVE
COMMENSURATE CHANGES AND
OVERSIGHT AND CONTROL. FOR
EXAMPLE WITH CWS CARES- WE FIND
THAT SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT WERE AFFORDED TO THIS
PROJECT REDUCE THE LEGISLATURE'S
OVERSIGHT. ONE PARTICULAR
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE ALLOWANCE
OF ANNUAL SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORTS WHICH ALLOW FOR MORE
FREQUENT UPDATING OF KIND OF THE
BASELINE COST SCHEDULE AND SCOPE
FOR THE PROJECT. ALSO THERE WERE
ISSUES AROUND THE COST
ESTIMATION FOR THIS PROJECT-
WHEN S. P. R. FOR WAS APPROVED
FOR THIS PROJECT THERE WAS A
CONDITION. THAT THE PROJECT A
CHOIR OF COST ESTIMATION EXPERT
TO MORE PRECISELY ESTIMATE THE
COST OF THE PROJECT AND TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE THAT WAS NOT COMPLETED
. SO IT IN SUMMARY WE REALLY
EMPHASIZED THE NEED TO. FOCUS ON
FIXING THE COST SCHEDULE AND
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT SUCH THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN OVERSEE
WHETHER THERE HAVE BEEN CHANGES
AND WHAT THOSE CHANGES TRULY
REPRESENTED. SECONDLY WE WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE
SEEING PROJECTS WITH METRICS TO
MEASURE COMPLETION AND OUTCOMES
. WHICH WE FIND TO BE A GOOD
DEVELOPMENT- WE DO SEE FOR
EXAMPLE WITH CWS CARES THE USE
OF MILESTONES AND OTHER MEASURES
TO MEASURE COMPLETION. AND THE
USE OF KEY PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS TO KIND OF MONITOR
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE PROJECT
WE FIND THESE ARE HELPFUL BUT
THEY HAVE TO BE FAIRLY
CONSISTENT IN THEIR APPLICATION
ACROSS THE LIFECYCLE OF A
PROJECT TO BE USEFUL AND THEY
NEED TO BE UNDERSTOOD BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS. TO
MONITOR THE PROGRESS OF THE
PROJECT AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
IF THOSE TWO THINGS ARE MATT CAN
USE THEM AS A MECHANISM FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THE FUNDING WE
APPROVE IS TIED TO THE ACTUAL
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT AND
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE GET. OUT OF
THEM. AGAIN WITH THE ABSENCE OF
A CLEAR BASS LINE FOR CWS CARES
THOUGH IT MAKES IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THAT OVERSIGHT TO
HAPPEN. A FEW OTHER OBSERVATIONS
AND THESE ARE JUST GENERAL
OBSERVATIONS TO KEEP IN MIND YOU
AGAIN HEARD A LOT ABOUT
DIFFERENT IT PROJECTS AND
SYSTEMS. I THINK IT PROJECTS AND
SYSTEMS SHOULD BE PLAN DEVELOPED
AND IMPLEMENTED AND I THINK
THERE'S BROAD AGREEMENT WITH
CONSIDERATION OF HOW THE
INTERFACE WITH ONE ANOTHER. AND
ALSO OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INTEGRATION BETWEEN THEM I THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ABOUT HIGHLIGHTED HERE
TODAY BETWEEN. YOU KNOW EXISTING
SYSTEMS AND SAY THE STATE
VERIFICATION HUB YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE ALL- IN
SERVICE OF TRYING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR BENEFICIARIES TO
ACCESS PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
BE MADE AWARE OF HOW ALL OF
THESE I. T. PROJECTS SYSTEMS
WORK TOGETHER- IN THE ABSENCE OF
CLEAR. YOU KNOW- INFORMATION
IT'S PRESENTED IN A VERY USER
FRIENDLY WAY TO MAKE US
UNDERSTAND HOW ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS ARE ALIGNED.
AND THE TIMELINE FOR EACH OF
THEM I THINK IT MAKES IT HARDER
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE.
SITE OUR FOURTH OBSERVATION IS
AGAIN NOT EVERY I. T. PROJECT
AND SYSTEM IS OF THE SAME AGE
AND CRITICALITY. TO THESE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE SYSTEMS THAT
ARE VERY OLD AND HAVE HAD
DISRUPTIONS BECAUSE OF JUST THE
AGE OF THE SYSTEM ITSELF. WE
KNOW THAT THEIR EFFORTS THAT ARE
BEING LED BY DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY TO LOOK AT STATE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS AS A WHOLE.
TO UNDERSTAND WHICH ONES ARE
MOST AT RISK OF DISRUPTION AND
OR FAILURE. WE THINK
UNDERSTANDING THE AGENT
CRITICALITY OF THESE PROJECTS
AND SYSTEMS WITH INTELLIGENT
CHEST. PARTICULAR DEPARTMENTS
WITH THE UNDER THAT AGENCY IS
CRUCIAL FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT HOW BEST.
TO INVEST PROJECT AND SYSTEM
RESOURCES. AND FINALLY WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STAKEHOLDERS AND USERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE IT PROJECTS
AND SYSTEMS. WE THINK THAT MAKES
SENSE GIVEN PERSON CENTER
PROGRAMS AND USER CENTERED
DESIGN BECOMING CRITICAL TO
THESE IT PROJECTS. BUT WE THINK
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME YOU
KNOW. BETTER ORGANIZATION OF THE
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
USERS TO ACTUALLY INFORM IT
PROJECTS AND SYSTEMS WE'VE SEEN
THIS MOST RECENTLY WITH THE CAL
HERE'S DASHBOARD THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER FOR- FUNCTIONALITIES IN
THE KALHOR SYSTEM. THAT COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS REALLY
WANTED TO SEE PUT INTO THAT
SYSTEM AND THAT PROCESS OF
ESTABLISHING A DASHBOARD AND
HAVING ROUTINE MEETINGS WITH.
PROJECT STEERING COMMITTEE
REALLY ALLOWED FOR
PRIORITIZATION AND KIND OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONALITIES THAT WERE NOT
BEING YOU KNOW. PUT INTO PLACE A
AND A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME
. SO GET ARE KIND OF
RECOMMENDATIONS REALLY ARE.
AROUND ONE WITH CWS CARES THAT'S
DOUBLE CHECK THAT BASS LINE
MAKING SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE TRUE COST OF THIS
PROJECT IS THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN
UNDERWAY FOR MANY YEARS AND WE
TRULY DO NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT COSTS WHAT THE SCHEDULE IS
AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO GET FOR
ALL OF THAT MONEY AND TIME. WE
ARE STILL WAITING YOU KNOW
SPECIAL PRODUCT REPORT FIVE AND
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE FUNDING
REQUEST FOR THE LEGISLATURE. I'M
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT- AND AGAIN WE
THINK THE FIRST KIND OF SET OF
METRICS IS A GOOD START. BUT WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTANDS AND
AGREES WITH THE METRICS THAT ARE
USED. TO MONITOR THESE PROJECTS.
SECOND I THINK IT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL FOR SOME OTHER
PROJECTS TO POTENTIALLY CONSIDER
THE USE. OF SOMETHING LIKE A
DASHBOARD SOME MECHANISM FOR
GATHERING THE INPUT OF STATE
COAL THERE'S AND OTHER USERS OF
A SYSTEM. SUCH THAT THEY CAN
PRIORITIZE FUNCTIONALITY CHANGES
ARE THINGS THAT CAN REALLY. KIND
OF BE MADE AND THE CHANGES THAT
WE MADE IN THE SYSTEM- ONCE FOR
EXAMPLE THE MIGRATION HAS
ALREADY HAPPENED A CAL SAUCER TO
BENEFITS CAL. SOMETHING THAT
BETTER ORGANIZES THE INPUT FROM
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT GROUPS ARE
PARTICIPATING. AND THIRD WE
THINK IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR
THE SUB COMMITTEE TO HEAR MORE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. ABOUT HOW
IT'S CONDUCTING THIS KIND OF
STATE GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
ASSESSMENT OF WHICH SYSTEMS
TRULY ARE AT RISK. WHICH
PROJECTS REALLY NEED TO BE
PRIORITIZE. WE CAN AVOID
DISRUPTIONS SERVICE. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM TYLER WOULD ROB TROJAN
WITH PERMANENT FINANCE. YES
TIGER WOODS PERMANENT FINANCE IF
IT'S OKAY I MAY PASS THIS ONE
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES TO DSS
RENTAL AT. HAPPY TO JUMP IN-
SECOND BRANCH BUT- RESEARCH
AUTOMATION DATABASE AND I'M
GOING TO PROVIDE UPDATES ON A
COUPLE OF- PROJECTS SO THE FIRST
IS. MIGRATING DATA FROM LEGACY
SYSTEMS- THIS IS A PROPOSAL TO
REQUEST ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS FOR CONTRACT SERVICES TO
MIGRATE LEGACY DATA SYSTEMS TO
NEW FACILITY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
AND TO EXTEND TO LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS WORKING ON
IMMIGRATION. JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
CONTRACT SERVICES VISIONS ARE
SCHEDULED TO EXPIRE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
SINCE NINETEEN- SINCE FISCAL
YEAR NINETEEN AT NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY CSS HAS BEEN MIGRATING
DATA FROM AN ANTIQUATED SYSTEM
USED BY THE COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING DIVISION YOU TO DATA
COMPLEXITY INVOLVED IN EIGHT
DIFFERENT LEGACY SYSTEMS OR DATA
QUALITY DUE TO EFFORT LEGACY
SYSTEMS- I. T. AND BUSINESS
RESOURCES REQUIRE MORE PROFOUND
UNDERSTANDING THAT INITIALLY
ANTICIPATED- AND SO THE DATA
FROM CURRENT CCL SYSTEM WITH LOW
MARKET. COMPLEX THAN INITIALLY
EXPECTED WHEN THE CONTRACTOR
CAME ON BOARD THESE RESOURCES
WILL HELP MAKE SURE WE ARE ABLE
TO COMPLETE THE MIGRATION
EFFORT. THE PROJECT- TO BE
COUNTY IT'S CLAIM REPORTING
INFORMATION SYSTEMS FUNDING
AUGMENTATION. THIS PROPOSAL
REQUEST TWO MILLION DOLLARS
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTEEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND SIX THOUSAND WHAT YOUR
GENERAL FUND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. I TO COMPLETE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE COUNTY
EXPENSE CLAIMS EASY
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONALITY AND
FOR MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
OF THE COUNTY EXPENSE CLAIM
REPORTING INFORMATION SYSTEM
ALSO THAT SEACREST PROJECT. THE
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT SOLUTION
VENDOR CONTRACT SERVICES FUND OR
LIMITED TERM POSITION. THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE PRODUCT
DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT- I DO
BELIEVE YOU CAN DO BUSINESS NOW
ALSO FOR ANYBODY. AND TESTING OF
COMPLEX BUSINESS RULES FOR THE
REMAINING CLAIM PROCESS SEES
INCLUDES PAYMENT CLOSE OUT AND
OUT OF SEQUENCE CLICK PROCESS
SEES. OF THE SECRET SOLUTION. I
UNDERSTAND THAT- RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE
IMPLEMENTATION ROLLOUT AND
KNOWLEDGE CONDITION MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS OF THE SECRET
SOLUTION USED BY COUNTIES TO
SUBMIT QUARTERLY AND MONTHLY
CLAIMS FOR REIMBURSEMENT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. THE FUNDS
RESOLUTION BETTER SUPPORT WILL
ENSURE DEDICATED EXPERIENCED
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES TO
CONTINUE WITH THE DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE REMAINING ECMASCRIPT
FUNCTIONALITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THAT'S THE COMPLETION OF
THIS PANEL I WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DÍAS TO BEGIN QUESTIONS. I
AM FIRST GONNA START BY ECHOING
WHAT THE L. A. O. HAD SAD OF THE
NEED FOR US TO UNDERSTAND THE
BASELINE COST SCHEDULE AND
SCOPE. AND I WOULD SPECIFICALLY
LIKE TO FOCUS US ON C. W. S.
CARES WHICH IS TO REPLACE CWS
CMS WE HEARD FROM MISS TUCKER
EARLIER THAT THE GOAL OF THIS
TRANSITION HAS TO HELP US TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN. THAT WE CURRENTLY ARE
HAVING A DEMONSTRATION MODEL IN
FIVE COUNTIES BUT IT SOUNDED
LIKE YOU WERE GOING TO SUGGEST
THAT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE A
DELAY. AND I WAS THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT BEGAN IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND HAS COST THE STATE
NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION.
DOLLARS THUS FAR I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
THE FULL COST SCHEDULE AND SCOPE
SO I'D LIKE TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING IF I CAN Y. WHEN
WE ASKED FOR. THE UC THE
ACQUIRING OF A COST ESTIMATE
THAT THIS WAS NOT. COMPLETED AS
WELL AS IF YOU CAN HELP TO
OUTLINED WHEN WE EXPECT. C. WSC
AMASSED TO BE REPLACED WITH C.
W. S. CARES. HOPING THE
DEPARTMENT CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. AT THE TOP- SO I
THINK- FOR CLARITY WE DID A
PUBLIC LAST ESTIMATE WITH OUR
INDEPENDENT ADVISOR- IN THE YOU
KNOW EARLIER ON IN THEIR
CONTRACT AND THEY CAME UP WITH
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AND SOME
YOU KNOW IN DISCUSSIONS WITH US
OF THINGS THAT WE COULD DO SO.
WE ARE WE HAVE REALIGNED DURING
OUR DEMONSTRATION MODEL THE
DEMONSTRATION MODELS FOR A SLICE
OF FUNCTIONALITY WILL BE VERY
CLEAR VERY CLEAR ON THAT- WITH
FIVE COUNTIES. AND SO NOW THE
WITH SOME OF THAT CHANGES WHAT
WE'VE LESSONS LEARNED AT. RIGHT
TO SEPARATING SOME MODIFICATIONS
TO YOU KNOW. RESOURCES ARE
PROCESSES THAT THE INDEPENDENT
ARCHERS ASSISTING US WITH AND
THEN THAT ULTIMATE COST ESTIMATE
THE COMPLETION OF THAT COST
ESTIMATE WILL BE A S. B. R. SIX
WHICH WOULD BE IT- LATER THIS
YEAR. WITH REGARD TO THE
STATEMENT WITH HAT WE'VE SPENT
NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION SO
FAR THAT I I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY
THE NINE ELEVEN. IS ACTUALLY THE
ESTIMATED AMOUNT FOR THE ENTIRE
PROJECT THROUGH- APRIL. ROUGHLY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX IT'S NOT THAT
THAT'S BEEN SPENT THUS FAR. WE
WILL AGAIN THE POINT NOW WE'VE
GOTTEN RFA FOR FIVE COUNTIES OUT
OF THE FUNDS WE'VE SPENT THUS
FAR AND WITHOUT A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SCHEDULED
COST AND SCOPE WE'RE STRUGGLING
AS THE LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW TO MAKE SURE WE'RE HOLDING.
THE ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE
FOR DELIVERING ON THIS NECESSARY
PROGRAM SO I'D LIKE TO ASK
SIMILARLY THE L. A. MENTIONED
THE METRICS THAT WERE- BEING.
MONITORED FOR COMPLETION. AND
I'M HOPING THAT WITHIN YOUR NEXT
SPECIAL- REPORTS THAT YOU CAN
ALSO REPORT TO US AND INCLUDE
THE METRICS TO COMPLETION IN
YOUR NEXT PROJECT REPORT AND
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER SO WE CAN
ENSURE WERE TRACKING AND
TRENDING. THOSE METRICS AND
INVOLVED IN THOSE DECISIONS BUT
IT WAS A LITTLE TROUBLING IF I'M
- BEING FULLY TRANSPARENT THAT A
PROJECT THAT HAS HAD MULTIPLE
DELAYS AND ISSUES IS APPARENTLY
HAVING THAT AGAIN AND SO WOULD
LIKE TO REALLY GET.
CLARIFICATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON. SPECIFIC
DATES THAT WE CAN HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE TO DELIVER ON THIS
PROJECT FOR THE DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE GIVING AND SO- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW WE GET
THERE BUT WHEN YOU'RE DOING THAT
I HOPE YOU CAN EVALUATE WHAT
MANY OF THE PRIMARY COST DRIVERS
ARE. AND WHY WE ARE SO HIGH IN
TOTAL FOR DOLLARS AND C. W. S.
CARES THUS FAR I BELIEVE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND PROCESS
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND AS WERE
LOOKING AT OTHER- CHANGES WITHIN
I. T. SYSTEMS. BUT ULTIMATELY
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF I
CAN FROM THE DEPARTMENT HO THIS
WILL ACHIEVE BETTER CASE
MANAGEMENT THROUGH C. W. S.
CARES. AS WE CURRENTLY ONLY HAVE
RFA IN THAT. MODULE HOW WILL
THIS ULTIMATELY LEAD TOWARDS
BETTER CASE MANAGEMENT WHICH IS
THE ULTIMATE GOAL. I WILL
STARTED OF JESSICA WANTS TO ADD
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE-
BUSINESS ARKAY IS PART OF OUR
DEMONSTRATION MARSHALL- ONE OF
THE SEGMENTS AS- WHILE WE'RE
DEVELOPING THIS FUNCTIONALITY BY
FUNCTIONALITY IT'S A SINGLE
IMPLEMENTATION. THAT IS PLANNED
TO BE COMPLETED IN MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. CURRENTLY- SO. IT'S
BUILDING THE ENTIRE SYSTEM TO
REPLACE THE WCM **** DOES THAT
ASSESSED IN THE TIMING OF WHEN
THE CASE MANAGEMENT. WOULD BE
PROCESSED SYSTEM WIDE I HEAR IT
BUT THE CONFIDENCE WE HAVE TO
DELIVER ON THAT IS- PREDICATED
ON FOLLOWING MANY OF THE METRICS
THAT WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE
THAT ARE BEFORE US AND US. WITH
THE HISTORY WE HAVE WITH THE
PROGRAM WE REALLY ARE LOOKING
FOR ANOTHER LEVEL OF DETAIL
WHICH IS WHY I BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE INSISTED ON THE
ACQUIRING OF A COST ESTIMATE AS
WE WERE NOT HAVING A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SCOPE COST
AND SCHEDULE OF THIS TRANSITION
AND- REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THAT CLARITY ON
THE SPECIFIC PROGRAM- I. WOULD
LIKE TO BRING IN THE L. L. IF I
CAN FOR SURE. RYAN METZGER LA-
JUST TO CLARIFY I BELIEVE THE
EXPENDITURES ON THE PROJECT THUS
FAR HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT IN
EXCESS OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- AND THE- SET OF
FUNCTIONALITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE FOR THIS PROJECT-
ARE NOT JUST RFA APPLICATION AND
THERE ARE SOME FUNCTIONALITIES-
RELATED TO KANSAS- THAT'S CALLED
KERR SLIDE BUT STILL BEING
SUPPORTED FOR SOME COUNTY SO
THERE IS. MORE THAT IS-
AVAILABLE- HOWEVER YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT- THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN CONCERNED OVER TIME
ABOUT KIND OF THE- THE COST
CONTROLS GO FOR THIS PROJECT-
AND IT IS CLEAR TO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES
APPROVAL OF THIS PROJECT. THAT
THEY WERE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST ESTIMATION THAT WAS
DONE AND REQUIRED IT IS PART OF
THE LAST PROJECT APPROVAL
DOCUMENTATION APPROVAL. LETTER
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
HAS NOT BEEN DONE WE WOULD JUST.
REALLY EMPHASIZE THE NEED FOR
THAT- AND THE NEED FOR CLEAR
METRICS AGAIN WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE METRICS FOR COMPLETION
LIKE MILESTONES THAT WILL GIVE
US A SENSE OF WHAT IS ACTUALLY
BEEN DEVELOPED. FROM THERE ARE
METRICS FOR OUTCOMES AND FOR
PERFORMANCE LIKE KEY PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE I
BELIEVE AND- OUR OFFICE WOULD
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THESE
METRICS BE MADE VERY CLEAR TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND POWER
MONITORING THEM OVER TIME. AND
IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
WITHOUT A LOOK FORWARD THE
FOLLOW UP ON THIS TRANSITION AYE
I WILL MOVE TO MR CONNEL THIS
COMMENT ON. CALFRESH WITHIN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION POPULATION I
WILL JUST POINT OUT MY OFFICES
IN BALLSTON WORKING TO MAKE
EXPANSIONS. WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO LOOK AT AB TWENTY EIGHT TEN
AND THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX THAT WE
DID LAST YEAR. THAT ARE LOOKING
TO ACTUALLY TAKE THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION THAT WE KNOW. ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENTS AND
THEN FIGURING OUT IF THEY-
QUALIFY FOR MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THAT SAME LOGIC IF I CAN TO RYAN
GILLETTE. AS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE STATE VERIFICATION
HUB. AND CALFRESH CAL WORKS IN
MEDICAL AND CHILD CARE PROGRAMS.
YOU SAID IT WAS TO HELP TO
STREAMLINE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. BUT DO WE CHECK
WHILE WE ARE VERIFYING THEIR-
INCOME IF THEY QUALIFY FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS DO WE FOLLOW IT UP
WITH. SENDING DOCUMENTS TO THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WE ARE BASED IN THESE
PROGRAMS ON- ARE WE SIMILARLY
FOCUSED ON ENSURING WE ARE
PROVIDING AS MUCH ENGAGEMENT AND
OUTREACH AS WE CAN. SO IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION- THE INITIAL
FUNCTIONALITY OF THAT SPEECH AS
I MENTIONED IT'S PRIMARILY
PRIMARILY JUST TO STREAMLINE THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS WHEN A
PERSON APPLIES FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
SPECIFIC PROGRAM. THAT- WE DON'T
WE GET INITIAL ROLLOUT OF IT
WILL NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BASED ON WHAT SOMEONE HAD
SUBMITTED SAY WHAT OTHER
PROGRAMS SOMEONE MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR- BUT THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW WE WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING WILL PROBABLY REQUIRES
INFORMATION WITH THAT OF
PALESTINE'S. TEENS WELL. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT TOO IF WE CAN
USE THE INFORMATION TO KEEP
PEOPLE OFF THE PROGRAMS WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE THE
INFORMATION TO. FIGURE OUT WHO
QUALIFIES SO WE CAN MAKE OUT
REACH AND ENGAGEMENT AND- AGAIN
PULL DOWN AS MANY FEDERAL
RESOURCES AS POSSIBLE TO BENEFIT
THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND-
WILL JUST ELEVATE AGAIN THE
COMMENTS OF- PROFESSOR CANAL. IF
I CAN- THAT THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF EDUCATION IT'S
AWFULLY HARD TO STUDY AND DO
YOUR JOB AS A STUDENT IF YOU'RE
HUNGRY OR HAVE BASIC NEEDS AND
PLUS I REALLY LOOK TOWARDS THESE
VERIFICATION HUBS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR US TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AS WE'RE GOING
FORWARD AS A STATE. WITH THAT I
WILL THINK IT'S ENTIRE PANEL FOR
THE DISCUSSION AND WE'LL MOVE
ON. TO OUR FINAL PANEL BUT
BEFORE I DO THAT I'D LIKE TO
KINDLY ASK FOR THE FOLLOWING
REGARDING C. W. S. CARES. I
THINK WE NEED MUCH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS PROJECT I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS WELL
AS- S. I TO WORK TOGETHER TO
HELP TO PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL
EXPLANATION. FOR THE COSTS AND
TIMELINES FOR THIS PROJECT. FOR
EXAMPLE WHY HAS THE COST BEEN SO
HIGH. WHY IS IT TAKING LONGER
THAN A DECADE AND WHAT ARE THE
GOALS OF COMPLETION FOR THIS
PROJECT. I ASK FOR THIS BACK
BEFORE THE MAY REVISION RELEASE
PLEASE. BECAUSE WE WILL USE IT
TO REVIEW SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
AS WELL AS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS IN THIS AREA I'D LIKE
TO ASK FOR THE HELP FROM THE L.
A. O. WITH THIS AS WELL TO
SUPPORT THE SUB COMMITTEE STAFF
PLEASE. WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
OPEN ALL OTHER BUDGET ISSUES
PENDING ACTION FOR THE MAY
REVISION HEARINGS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE PANELISTS HERE
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THREE. IS ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. WE WILL HAVE FOUR
PRESENTERS IN THIS PANEL. IT
WILL BEGIN WITH DAVID SCRIBNER
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT WILL JOIN US ON
THE WEB AT. FOLLOWED BY ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE L. A. L. JALIL
BAKER AND KIA CHAU WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CAN WE
PLEASE BEGIN WITH DEPUTY.
DIRECTOR SCRIPT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M DAVID SCRIBNER
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT OR CST. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AN OVERVIEW OF CSP'S BUDGET FOR
THE COMING YEAR AND TO PROVIDE
UPDATES ON THE STATUS OF THOSE
NEW PROGRAMS THE DEPARTMENTS
CHARGED WITH IMPLEMENTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. CSP FOCUSES
ON THE ADMINISTRATION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE AND LIFT UP LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALMOST 1100% FEDERALLY FUNDED.
WITH FUNDING COMING PRIMARILY
FROM THREE FEDERAL GRANTS. THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
OR C. S. B. G. THE LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOR LIKE EIGHT. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY'S
WEATHERIZATION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. SHE'S SHE'S FEDERAL
GRANTS HAVE BEEN FUNDED UNDER A
CONTINUING RESOLUTION UP TO THE
RECENT PASSAGE OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO FEDERAL BUDGET. WHAT
WE DO NOT KNOW FINAL WORDS AS OF
YET. BASED ON THE TOTAL
APPROPRIATIONS C-SPAN DISSIPATES
FUNNY WILL BE RELATIVELY FLAT
YEAR OVER YEAR FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. WITH POTENTIAL MINOR
INCREASES. THE STATE FUNDED LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM OR
LIVE WITH. TWO COMPONENTS OF THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND SOLAR
PEAVEY PROGRAM ARE CURRENTLY IN
OPERATION. THE FARMWORKER
HOUSING COMPONENT WHICH SERVES
LOW INCOME FARMWORKER HOUSING.
AND THE MULTI FAMILY COMPONENT
WHICH SERVES MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE INCLUDES AND DEMAND
INVESTMENT OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR ALL I WANT MULTI
FAMILY TO HELP ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT. SHE IS
THE OTHER ONE BCP THIS YEAR THE
REQUESTED SHIFT OF SEVEN FULL
TIME POSITIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT'S TEMPORARY HELP LINK
IT. TO ITS PERMANENT POSITION OF
AUTHORITY. THE REQUEST PROVIDES
A TRUE UP A POSITION AUTHORITY
TO REFLECT POSITION YOU SHOULD
MORE ACCURATELY BASED ON
LONGEVITY. TENURE WORK LOOK.
THERE'S NO FUNDING ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS REQUEST. AS IT DID
SHIFT THE POSITION OF AUTHORITY
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING
BUDGET. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SINCE HE WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPLEMENT TWO
MAJOR NEW PROGRAMS. FIRST THE
CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT PROGRAM
OR CAP ADDRESSES THE HISTORIC
LEVELS OF ENERGY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ACCRUED DURING THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC BY
DIRECTING ONE BILLION IN FEDERAL
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT
FUNDING. TO REDUCE PASSED TO
ENERGY UTILITY BILL BALANCES. I
AM EXTREMELY PROUD OF CSD STAFF
AND OUR SMALL DEPARTMENTS
ABILITY TO SUCCESSFULLY MISTER
CAP UNDER COMPRESSED TIME FRAME
. AFTER THE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR CST USED EXISTING STAFF
RESOURCES TO SUCCESSFULLY
DISPERSED FUNDING THAT IS
SUPPORTING OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ENERGY CUSTOMERS PAY
DOWN THEIR ENERGY DEATH.
FURTHERMORE CST DISTRIBUTED ALL
CAP FUNDING TO ENERGY UTILITIES
BY THE JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO STATUTORY
DEADLINE. THAT CUSTOMERS HAVE
BEEN RECEIVING CAP BILL CREDITS
SINCE DECEMBER IN NEARLY ALL
QUALIFIED CUSTOMERS HAVE NOW
RECEIVED A CAPITAL CREDIT. WELL
IT DID TAKE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEXITIES OF
SHARED UTILITY BILLING SYSTEMS
AND ENSURING ALL ELIGIBLE
UTILITIES RECEIVE THEIR SHARE OF
CAP FUNDS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
PROGRAM RULES. SHE SHE WAS ABLE
TO NAVIGATE THOSE ISSUES ALONG
WITH OTHER COMPLICATIONS
INEVITABLY ARISE WHEN
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM OF THE
SCALE. ACCORDING CLOSELY WITH
UTILITIES AND THEIR MEMBER
ASSOCIATIONS TO QUICKLY AND
COLLABORATIVELY ADDRESS ISSUES
AS THEY AROSE AND ENSURE THE CAP
BENEFITS RECEIVE OR REACHED
CUSTOMERS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
. CST IS CURRENTLY CONDUCTING A
SURVEY TO DETERMINE THE STATUS
OF PAST YOU BOUNCES AFTER CAP
BENEFITS ARE APPLIED TO CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS. NOTE THAT POINT POINT
IN TIME UTILITIES SURVEY RESULTS
REFERRED FROM SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ESTIMATED THE ONE
BILLION IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
ADDRESS ROUGHLY HALF OF THE TWO
BILLION AN ELIGIBLE STATEWIDE
ENERGY REAR JUST. AND CST
ANTICIPATES UPDATED RICH DATA
WILL BE AVAILABLE BY THE END OF
APRIL. THE FINAL PHASE OF
CAPITAL THE IMPLEMENTATION WILL
INCLUDE UTILITIES REPORTING ON
OUTCOMES INCLUDING DATA ON TOTAL
FUNDS DISTRIBUTED. NUMBER OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND AVERAGE
BENEFIT AMONG OTHER DATA POINTS.
FINAL REPORTING WILL BE PROVIDED
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN THE FALL.
AND UTILITY SURVEY AN ALLOCATION
DATA BOTH STATEWIDE AND BY
UTILITY ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
ON CSU'S WEBSITE. THROUGHOUT CAP
SEIZE THE CLOSELY COORDINATED
PROGRAMMABLE MAGICIAN WITH OTHER
SOURCES OF ENERGY UTILITY
RESEARCH ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE
SUCH AS WITH WITH THE CPUC.
ENERGY UTILITIES COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS AND STATE
ASSOCIATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. CAP IS JUST ONE
PIECE OF THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS ENERGY DEBT INCURRED
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND THESE
EFFORTS TO PREDATE CAP AND WILL
CONTINUE AFTER THE PROGRAM
CONCLUDES. YOU SEE IF YOU SEE AN
ENERGY UTILITIES HAVE TAKEN A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO OFFER
ASSISTANCE TO CUSTOMERS
ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THESE INCLUDE
DISCONNECTION MORATORIUMS
PAYMENT PLANS TO RAISE CUSTOMER
DEBTS AND DISCOUNT PROGRAMS TO
LOWER ONGOING ENERGY COSTS.
OUTSIDE OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS OFFERED UNDER CAP
SHE IS THE OF PROVIDED ENERGY
UTILITIES AND CUSTOMERS WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT OTHER SOURCES
OF ASSISTANCE FOR CUSTOMERS
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR UTILITY
BILLS. INCLUDING GST LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIANS COBIT
NINETEEN RENT RELIEF PROGRAM
WHICH HAS PROVIDED FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR RENT AND
UTILITIES TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS. HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. FOR
SEE LIKE PROGRAM PRAYER TWO
HUNDRED AND THREE MILLION IN
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT. FIRST
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO REDUCE
ENERGY BILL REAR JUST FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. JUST IS ALSO
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW FEDERAL LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR LIKE A
WALK. UNDER MY WALK CALIFORNIA
WAS ALLOCATED ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION AND ONE TIME
FUNDING TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO ADDRESSED
RESIDENTIAL WATER UTILITY COSTS.
PER FEDERAL GUIDANCE WHAT I WANT
IS MODELED ON THE LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THE SERVICES ARE BEING DELIVERED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BY LIKE HEAP
SERVICE PROVIDERS. CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE STATUTE
ESTABLISHING MY WALK THE PROGRAM
FOCUSES ON WATER AND WASTEWATER
REAR JUST FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. SEE IF YOU RECEIVE
FINAL WHY WHAT STATE PLAN
APPROVAL FROM FEDERAL OFFICIALS
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WILL BE RELEASING FINAL
PROGRAM GUIDELINES WITHIN THE
NEXT WEEK. BERMAN IS ENTERING
INTO CONTRACTS WITH LOCAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS THIS MONTH
WITH A CONTRACT START DATE OF
APRIL FIRST. CST IS ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF ESTABLISHING DIRECT
PAYMENT AGREEMENTS. WITH WATER
AND WASTEWATER SYSTEMS TO MEET
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS THE
BENEFITS BE PAID DIRECTLY TO
WATER SYSTEMS. SERVICES
UNDERLYING WHAT WILL BEGIN ON A
ROLLING BASIS OF LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS RAMP UP THE WATER
SYSTEMS ENTER INTO DIRECT PAY
AGREEMENTS. SAID CSTS SERVICE
PROVIDERS HAVE NOT ADMINISTER
WATER BENEFITS IN THE PAST THE
DEPARTMENT IS INVESTED
SIGNIFICANT UP FRONT TIME AND
RESOURCES. TO DEVELOP Y. WAFFEN
ENGAGE WITH WATER PROVIDERS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION AND
SERVICE DELIVERY FOR CUSTOMERS
ACROSS THE STATE. A PROGRAM
LAUNCH. THIS IS INCLUDE
REGULATED REGULAR CONSULTATION
WITH THE CPC. AND THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
THE REALITY THAT WE ARE
DEPENDENT ON WATER UTILITIES
OPTING IN TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM THROUGH DIRECT PAY
AGREEMENTS DOES CREATE SOME
ANNOUNCER OUTSIDE DEPARTMENTS
CONTROL. WITH THAT BEING SAID WE
ARE CONFIDENT WE ARE LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM LAUNCH THANK YOU AND
I'LL BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE L. L. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON ANGELES FOR WITH
THE L. L. TODAY WE'VE BEEN ASKED
TO REVIEW THE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS INCLUDED IN OUR RECENT
ANALYSIS OF CSU PROGRAMS. MUCH
OF THIS ANALYSIS- YOU'VE ALREADY
SEEN YOUR AGENDA AND OF COURSE
STRUCTURE SCRIBNER JUST PROVIDED
A VERY THOROUGH UPDATES ALL
TRYING NOT TO BE TOO REPETITIVE
HERE- AND I'LL JUST FOCUS. ON A
FEW COMMENTS REGARDING- CAPTAIN
LIE WALKED THE TWO MAJOR NEW
PROGRAMS THAT CST HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. FIRSTLY WE JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE CSP'S FUNDING AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OF
MORE THAN ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IS  SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATION- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT'S. PRIOR YEAR BUDGETS
AND THIS IS PRIMARILY DUE TO THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
FUNDING ALLOCATED FOR CAP. AND
WHILE THIS IS QUITE A LARGE
AUGMENTATION AS DR SCRIBNER ALSO
MENTIONED CST WAS ABLE TO
OVERCOME A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
APPLY LESSONS LEARNED. AND
ULTIMATELY- STAND UP THE NEW
PROGRAM QUITE QUICKLY-
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT HAS
PROVIDED HAS BEEN PROVIDING. A
DETAILED PROGRAM UPDATES AND
INFORMATION ON ITS WEBSITE WHICH
WE HAVE FOUND HAS GREATLY
FACILITATED TRANSPARENCY AND
ASSISTED- OUR ABILITY TO UP TO
ASSIST THE LEGISLATURE WITH
OVERSIGHT. ARE WE ALSO NOTED IN
OUR IITIAL ANALYSIS THAT TOTAL
CAP FUNDING OFFSETS ONLY AROUND
HALF OF THE TOTAL CALCULATED
ENERGY UTILITY- RIDGES IN THE
STATE WHICH I DIRECTOR SCRIBNER
ALSO MENTIONED. TOTAL AROUND TWO
BILLION DOLLARS- WE EXPECT THAT
CST IS FORTHCOMING REPORTING ON
TAP- SHOULD SHED MORE LIGHT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE. REGARDING WHO
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
BEEN SERVED OR OR WHO MAY HAVE
REMAINING OR REEMERGES AFTER-
EVEN AFTER CAP FUNDS WERE
APPLIED. ADDITIONALLY WE NOTED
IN OUR ANALYSIS THAT ENERGY
UTILITY CUSTOMERS MAY BE
RECEIVING DEBT RELIEF FOR
THROUGH VARIOUS OTHER PROGRAMS
INCLUDING STATE AND LOCALLY
ADMINISTERED RENTAL- RELIEF
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND ACCORDINGLY WE
HAD SUGGESTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO INQUIRE
ABOUT HOW CST IS COORDINATING-
CAP ASSISTANCE WITH THESE OTHER-
POTENTIAL FORMS OF ASSISTANCE
WHICH AT DIRECTOR SCRIBNER HAS
HAS SPOKEN TO. AND MOVING ON
JUST ONE FINAL COMMENT REGARDING
LIE WALK UP- THE PRIMARY
COMMENTS WE INCLUDED IN OUR
INITIAL ANALYSIS WAS REGARDING
IT- HOUSE CST IS COORDINATING
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. GIVEN THAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD- IS
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM THAT
SIMILARLY AIMS TO ASSIST
RESIDENTIAL WATER AND WASTEWATER
UTILITY CUSTOMERS TO ADDRESS THE
REAR JUST- BUT WITH A
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER FUNDING
ALLOCATION OF A ONE BILLION
DOLLARS RELATIVE TO SEE S. D.'S-
ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS- FOR A LOT OF WHAT. BUT
AGAIN- YOU KNOW DIRECTOR
SCRIBNER HAS HAS SPOKEN A BIT TO
THIS COORDINATION. SO THOSE ARE
ALL OF MY INITIAL COMMENTS BUT
HAPPY TO HELP RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM KIA CHANDRA
LELE BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY CONCERNS OR
ANYTHING ELSE THAT HERE THANK.
THANK YOU WITHTHAT I WILL BRING
IT BACK UP TO THE DIE S. I'M
GONNA STICK WITH DIRECTOR
SCRIBNER FIGHT CAN I. WANNA
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
THE LIE WHILE UP AND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
PROGRAM. HOW THEY ARE
DIFFERENTIATED WHETHER THEY'RE
DUPLICATE AS FAR THEY SEPARATE
I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND AS WELL AS- IF I CAN
DO WE KNOW THE TOTAL OF A REAR
EDGES FOR. WATER NEEDS FOR THE
STATE- IN COMPARISON TO WHAT WE
FUNDED FOR BOTH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND LIVE
OFF. SURE THE FROM WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE WATER-
THE THAT'S THE WATER BOARD'S
PROGRAM IS REALLY JUST BEING
PAID OFF AT THE UTILITY LEVEL SO
THAT FUNDS WILL BE PROVIDED TO
THE WATER UTILITIES THEMSELVES.
WHERE HAS THE LIFELOCK IS
BASICALLY A CUSTOMER BASED
PROGRAM- THE CUSTOMER COMES INTO
A LOCAL SERVICE PROVIDER WITH A
BILL. THAT BILL CAN'T BE PAID
HOWEVER THERE NEEDS TO BE A
DIRECT PAY AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
WATER SERVICE PROVIDER THAT THE
CUSTOMER. PAYS THEIR BILL TO.
ARM AND THAT LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDER IN THE STATE BECAUSE
THE STATE IS NOT ABLE TO PAY
ANY. OF FUNDS DIRECTLY TO THE
CONSUMER THEMSELVES OF MOSCOW TO
THE WATER SERVICE PROVIDER SO
THAT MADE EACH MAJOR
DIFFERENTIAL IS THAT THE WATER
BOARD'S PROGRAM IS THAT THE AS A
LARGE UTILITY LEVEL THAT CAN
TAKE. AN AGGREGATE NUMBER OF-
RESEARCHES AND PAY THEM ALL AT
ONCE WHEREAS LIVEWATCH IS A ONE
CUSTOMER ONE APPLICATION
APPROACH- THE L. IT'S A LITTLE
MORE COMPLICATED BECAUSE THEN WE
HAVE TO ENTER TO ENTER INTO A
MULTIPLE. DIRECT PAY AGREEMENTS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- THIS
QUESTION A FOR FINANCE IF THERE
ARE UNSPENT FUNDS WITHIN THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. COULD THEY BE REPURPOSED
TOWARDS A CARE LIKE PROGRAM TO
ASSIST. WITH DISCOUNTED OR
ADJUSTED WATER BILLS FOR LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS AS IT STILL
ALONG THE SAME MODALITY OF
CREATING AFFORDABILITY FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE WATER NEEDS. IT'S NOT A
PART OF FINANCE I THINK THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE TO- HAVE FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS GOING TO SAVE- HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION I WANT TO
SPEND THE SAVINGS IF THEY'RE
ALREADY. I WOULD. POINT OUT I
BELIEVE THERE'S A SENATE BILL BY
SENATOR DODD S. B. TWO TWO TWO
THAT MAY CREATE. THE MECHANISM
THAT IS THE CARE LIKE FOR.
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE- LOW
INCOME WATER USERS IN OUR STATE
AS THE MODEL FOR US TO LOOK
TOWARDS TO SEE IF IT'S
APPLICABLE- AND WOULD LOVE. TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CURRENT
FUNDS ARE WITHIN STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD THAT
HAVE BEEN ON SPENT THUS FAR- AS
WELL AS THE DENOMINATOR THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT WHICH IS THE TOTAL
FOR ME REGIS. THAT WILL BE
NEEDED AS WELL- AND WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD OPEN ALL CST ISSUES
PENDING ACTION AT THE MAY
REVISION HEARINGS. AND WE WILL
NOW TRANSITION TO PUBLIC COMMENT
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL OF. OUR PANELISTS. AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON ANY ISSUE WHICH IS
ON THE AGENDA. WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF. SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START WITH IN
PERSON PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM- IF YOU WILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO MAKE A COMMENT-
GOOD AFTERNOON. MICROBES IN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS. YOUR PUBLICLY OWNED-
MUNICIPAL WATER ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. I'M REALLY I'M HERE
ON THE LAST ITEM ON THE THIRD
ITEM ONTHE CAP PROGRAM AND
APPRECIATIVE OF- THE DIRECTORS-
TESTIMONY WE THE CMU I THINK CST
HAS DONE A WONDERFUL JOB ON THE
CAP PROGRAM AND- AND- AND
UNFORTUNATELY- AND I THINK THE
TESTIMONY FROM BOTH THE L. A. ON
THE DIRECTOR POINTED OUT THAT
YOU CAN. THERE'S STILL
SIGNIFICANT UNMET NEED THERE
AND- AND YOU KNOW FOR THE FOR
THE PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES ARE
STILL THERE'S- YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR SPENDING DID NOT COVERED IS
JUST FOR THE PO USE. AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
IN UNPAID BILLS FROM THE LAST
CYCLE AND THEN AT LEAST ANOTHER
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. SENSE SINCE THE
PROGRAM- YOU KNOW THE CUT OFF
DATE OF THE PROGRAM SO THAT SO
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT UNMET NEED
FROM FOR THE FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
WHO ARE WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO PAY
THEIR ELECTRIC BILLS. WE THINK
THERE IS A SOLUTION WE'VE BEEN-
YOU KNOW REACHING OUT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND HOPING YOU
KNOW MAYBE THAT IN THE MAY
REVISE AND IF NOT IN THE REVISED
AND- THEN YOUR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE CAN ENTERTAIN THE IDEA
THAT. WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO BE
AT LEAST ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
LEFT OVER FROM- FROM THE FEDERAL
MERICAN RESCUE ACT- FUNDS AND
THAT YOU CAN GET. A THAT YOU
HAVEN'T SPENT AND THAT YOU CAN
REDIRECT- YOU KNOW SOME OF THAT
MONEY. TO TO CAP AND OR TO THE
GENERAL FUND AND- AND FUND THE
UNMET NEED. AND WE'RE HOPING TO
MAKE THAT- EFFORT TO REACH. IN
THE BUDGET. AND HOPE YOU HELP
WITH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW GO ON TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AS A
REMINDER. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COURT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS YOU CAN ALWAYS CALL THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. GERMAN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS MAY ENTER THE
QUEUE AT ANY TIME BY PRESSING
ONE BUTTON ERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
TO JOIN THE QUEUE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. I'M SURE AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE ARAMBULA
NUMBERS MY NAME IS SPINNING
CULVERDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION. HEARING
TODAY WITH AN OUTSTANDING UPDATE
I'M PROGRAM MY INPUT ACTUALLY
TOUCHES ON ALL THREE PANEL I
WOULD THE BIG CONCERN THAT A
FIGHT FROM THE CHILD CARE DATA
UPDATE THERE WAS NOT MENTION OF
THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS
THAT WERE REMOVED LAST JULY.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF THAT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR THE PURPOSES
OF PORTING WHOLE FAMILY NEEDS IN
ADDITION TO THEIR EXPERTISE IN
CONNECTING INCOME ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES THE CHILD CARE. THESE
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
STRENGTH THEY PROGRAM THESE
PROGRAMS ENROLL INCOME ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES FOR SERVICES AND ARE IN
A POSITION TO FOURTEEN ROMANCE
OTHER INCOME ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
AND OTHER PROGRAMS. WE ARE
ALREADY THIRTEEN AND SUPPORTING
MANY CAL WORK FOSTER FAMILY
MIGRANTS AND CHILDREN MANY OF
THE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE PROGRAMS
TO HAVE COME THROUGH A CAL WORK
AND THE WORK THAT BY CHILD CARE
PATHWAY. THAT THEY BRING TO THE
TABLE THE REAL WORLD IMPACT YOU
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY AND
HAVE THE INTERNET UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT. THOSE SEEKING SERVICES
ARE NEEDING. ANY OF OUR FORTY
FIVE BUT YOU PROGRAM ALL HAVE OF
THE FIGHT CHILD CARE. WITH CASE
WORKERS AFTER CONNECT PARA THAT
THEY- THAT. FOR FOOD
TRANSPORTATION. IMMIGRATION
AMONG THE LEFT FURTHER IN
RESPONSE TO THE INCREASE OF
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IN THE
COMMUNITY. MANY AGENCIES TO HAVE
SECURED BRANSON OUTSIDE FUNDING
TO HIRE ON SITE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT FROM
IMPORTANT CARE. FINALLY THIRTY
EIGHT OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ALREADY CONTRACT
OUT THERE CAL WORK CHILD CARE
PROGRAM FIFTEEN UNITY A PEACE.
WE ARE RECOGNIZED RESOURCE THAT
ALREADY HAVE CASE MANAGERS QUIT
AND MEETING WITH FRAZZLED
PARENTS AND FAMILIES. NOT
INCLUDING THE EIGHTEENTH AT THE
TRUE PARTNER IN THIRTEEN FRAGILE
INDIVIDUALS AND CHILDREN IF THE-
REAL NEXT. OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
. THANK OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE
OH TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PETER MACKLER
ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY- LAST
YEAR CAP UTILITY BILL ASSISTANCE
BUT HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND HELPED
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS. AND DESPITE
THAT FACT THAT THERE IS
REMAINING AND YOU NEED I'D
PACKED WE ESTIMATE THERE IS THAT
ALL FIVE MILLION THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS LEFT IN ARREARS
INCLUDING COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND WOULD
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROPRIATE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION IN FEDERAL COVERED
RELIEF AND- THE FURTHER HELP
CUSTOMERS THERE BY PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES WHO ARE UNABLE
TO PAY THEIR UTILITY BILLS. DUE
TO THE COMPANY TEAM PANDEMIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NO. ONE MOST
. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COOK
CRICKET IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO COMMEND THE DEPARTMENT ON THE
EFFICIENT- THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
LAST YEAR'S PROGRAM IT WAS MOST
EFFECTIVE AND- TREMENDOUSLY
EFFICIENT AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW THE
CONSUMERS WHO BENEFITTED FROM
THE PROGRAMME APPRECIATE THAT AS
WELL. SECONDLY I WOULD LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF BOTH MR WILSON AND
MISS ACTOR- THERE IS A NEED TO
CONTINUES AND WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THOSE NEEDS
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK YOU OPERATOR I WILL
TAKE THAT AS THE CONCLUSION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR TODAY I WILL
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK ALL OF
OU PANELISTS BEGINNING WITH.
THE ADMINISTRATION DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND SO MANY WHO PROVIDED
EXPERTISE FROM THE L. A. O. TO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
WELL AS TO TACK IN THE SERGEANTS
AND DGS. BUT FINALLY I WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND JUST THANK THE
STAFF ON BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HAS ALWAYS DONE A GREAT JOB OF.
CREATING THE AGENDAS AND
CREATING THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
TALK ABOUT THE PROBLEMS OUR
STATE FACES. REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT HARD WORK AND COLLABORATION
AND PARTNERSHIP- BUT ULTIMATELY
I WANNA FINALLY THANKS THE
PUBLIC IS THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE I ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE
PARTICIPATION. THAT YOU PROVIDE
AND HOW YOU MAKE OUR PROCESS
BETTER. WITH THAT WE ARE
CONCLUDED FOR TODAY WE ARE
JOINED.